Ja, wir haben sie!
Das war's für heute.
So.
Mal gucken, ob OBS immer noch nicht eingestellt ist.
Scheint so.
So.
Das ist das, was wir immer machen.
am Sonntag.
Wir gucken uns Github-Trends an.
Ich labere ein bisschen über irgendwelche Sachen,
die ich gerade im Kopf habe. Wir gucken uns ein paar
YouTube-Videos an.
Und dann gehe ich Nudeln mit Lachs futtern.
Aber ohne euch.
Wobei, heute gibt es gar keine
Nudeln mit Lachs. Stellt euch das mal vor.
Es gibt auch keine Spaghetti Bolognese.
Es gibt Nudeln mit
Pilz.
Also Pilzen. Nicht einen Pilz.
Einen Pilz wäre vielleicht ein bisschen
wenig.
Moin.
BlackHD,
Dankeschön für den Sub. 58 Jahre.
Pog Subscription.
Moment, Chat, Chat, wir müssen mal
eine Sache zum Stream-Einstieg
machen. Haben wir schon lange nicht mehr gehört.
Einfach besser, besser Twitch
Song.
Almost heaven, older Twitch chat.
All these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're older, everyone's moved on.
I remember Twitch chat, from those days that are gone.
Twitchy Moans
Long ago
Made you feel
You're not alone
Kappa Pock Champ
Keep a forehead
Bible Thumb
Twitchy Moans
I remember
Typing Dan's Game
Hailfish
Kappa Pock Champ.
Keep a forehead.
Bible Thumb.
Witchy Moms.
Still hear his bark in the morning hour he calls me.
His doggy emote reminds me of a time far away.
Looking at a chat I get a feeling that I miss emotes from yesterday, yesterday.
Twitch emotes from long ago made you feel you're not alone.
Pog ist Pogchamp.
Cap ist Cappung.
Bibletongue.
Twitchy Moles.
Peppermint.
Bibletongue.
Twitchy Moles.
So.
Jetzt bin ich ready.
Kommen wir nachher.
Max wird Veganer.
Ey, ich habe tatsächlich so gut wie kein Fleisch gegessen die letzten drei Wochen.
Muss mal kurz Licht anmachen.
Hier ist irgendwie ein bisschen dunkel.
So.
Exzellent.
Jaja.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich wirklich Veganer werde.
Im Sinne von auf gar keinen Fall irgendwie fleischhaltige Sachen essen.
Aber ich habe vor einer Weile Artikel gelesen, dass hoher Fleischkonsum das Darmkrebsrisiko steigert.
Habe ich mir gedacht.
Eigentlich müsste ich zu den meisten Zeug, weiß ich sofort, da gar kein Fleisch dabei futtern.
Und seitdem esse ich weniger.
Ich glaube diese Woche
Hab ich
Ich glaube das einzige Fleisch
Was ich die ganze Woche gegessen hab
War
Also Fisch lassen wir mal weg
Da hab ich tatsächlich
Am Freitag in der Kantine was gefuttert
Das einzige Fleisch
Was ich gegessen hab die ganze Woche war
Ich hab mir so einen Salat
Ja, wie nennt man das?
Teller ist es ja nicht.
So eine Salatschüssel zusammen gemixt.
Auf der Arbeit in der Kantine.
Und da gab es Bohnen.
Und bei den Bohnen war so ein ganz kleines bisschen...
War das Schinken oder sowas dabei?
Das war es aber auch.
Ein paar Gramm.
Es fehlt stark an...
Weil wir auch so viel Ayaya-Content hatten.
Was würdest du denn gern für...
...Content sehen?
Ja stimmt, was hat denn der Morpheus für neue Videos?
Die letzten waren einfach zu lang.
Also zum angucken.
Die Open-Source-Community bricht zusammen.
40 Minuten.
Wenn wir sonst nichts anderes mehr haben heute, weil 40 Minuten...
Ihr kennt mich.
Also nicht, dass das Video schlecht wäre.
Die Videos sind meistens echt gut.
Aber wenn ich ein 40 Minuten Video...
Fuck, was ist das wieder für komische Empfehlungen, Alter.
Das Ding ist, wenn ich ein 40 Minuten Video gucke,
dann bin ich mindestens eineinhalb Stunden beschäftigt.
Ok, der AF-Programmer, der kriegt jetzt Ayaya-Content.
Moment, ich muss erstmal den...
Ich muss erstmal den Linux-Mini-PC starten.
Starte das verdammte Spiel.
Ich will nicht, dass es lädt.
Booting.
Ja, und dann müssen wir noch mal updaten.
Und dann müssen wir wahrscheinlich mal rebooten.
Massive Passwort.
Unknackbar.
Fünf Zeichen.
Oder?
Nee, sechs Zeichen.
Ups, ich hab links nicht gestartet.
Zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, zack, da sind wir.
Linux-Stells am Start.
So, Firefox mal starten.
Hallo?
Firefox mal starten.
Terminal mal starten.
Session Restoren.
Und jetzt Update.
Und den Reboot, den schenken wir uns heute.
Weil ich keinen Bock habe nochmal die Tastatur umzustöpseln.
Yes, yes, yes.
Gibt es hier Updates?
No Pass.
Keine Updates.
Gibt es hier Updates?
VLC Plugin K Wallet.
Warum habe ich so einen Schrott installiert?
Weg damit.
Okay, quick, quick.
Ich lasse einfach mal die Finger davon.
Der Update, der wird schon wissen, was er macht.
Hoffe ich mal.
Bist du eigentlich noch mit deinem Fiat zufrieden?
Ja.
Ja, ja.
Das Einzige, was mich bei dem Fiat ein bisschen nervt,
im Vergleich zu dem Auto, was ich davor hatte,
ist, dass der Kofferraum, also der Deckel vom Kofferraum,
Oder wie beschreibe ich das jetzt am besten?
Da, wo die Klappe ist hinten.
Der ist schräg, also relativ schräg im Vergleich zu dem Agila, den ich davor hatte.
Ich hatte ja bisher immer nur ganz kleine Autos.
Und beim Agila war das hinten relativ gerade, relativ senkrecht.
Da hast du mehr reingepackt.
Also hat mehr reingepasst.
Beim Fiat ist es relativ schräg.
Und wenn du größere Sachen in den Kofferraum laden willst, passt das nicht so gut.
Also wirklich viel Platz hast du in dem Fiat nicht.
Das ist aber auch das Einzige, was mich daran nervt.
Manchmal wird es ein bisschen eng, aber ansonsten finde ich das super.
Einzige, was mir jetzt noch fehlt, ist in irgendeiner Art und Weise selbst erzeugter Strom.
Weil das lohnt sich bei einem Elektroauto ja auch richtig.
Aber ansonsten würde ich mir den wahrscheinlich wieder kaufen.
Also, jetzt drei Jahre später oder so,
wann ich den gekauft habe,
oder vier Jahre später,
ja, vier Jahre würde ich sagen,
ist es ungefähr her,
habe ich den jetzt,
würde ich jetzt sagen,
okay, wahrscheinlich würde ich mir jetzt
eine neuere Variante oder so davon kaufen,
aber so im Nachhinein betrachtet,
würde ich den wieder kaufen.
So, was machen die Updates?
Ich muss mal kurz die Klimaanlage anmachen.
Hier ist übelst warm.
Was haben wir denn?
26,5 oder so?
Ich mache mal kurz die Klimaanlage an.
Moin. Und Leute, was war bei euch so die Woche los?
Bei uns wurde Linux-mäßig wieder sehr viel gepatcht.
Die haben was witzig fand bei uns auf der Arbeit.
Bei CopyFail haben die übelst Panik geschoben.
Sonderwartungsfenster, wann was gemacht werden muss.
Und oje, oje. Und ganz furchtbar schlimm.
Und Leute müssen am Wochenende das jetzt patchen.
Und hier und dann.
bis zum Deadline, bis zum so und so
und viel, so, okay.
Sag ich ja gar nichts dagegen, ja.
Ist ja auch irgendwo gerechtfertigt,
ja. Aber, was ich witzig
fand, ist, danach, eine Woche
später, kam
wie hieß
es? Frack?
Cash Frack?
Dirty Frack.
Dirty Frack hieß das, ne.
Eine Woche später kam Dirty
Frack, also Sicherheitslücke,
Dirty Frag und letztendlich
hatte es genau die gleichen
Auswirkungen wie Copy Fail.
Du konntest mit einem unprivilegierten
User gut werden.
Easy. Es hatte genau, es war wirklich
gar kein Unterschied
von dem, was es, also
die Auswirkungen davon, wie es funktioniert hat,
war schon ein bisschen anders, aber
es waren letztendlich, die Auswirkungen
waren exakt die gleichen. Bis heute
interessiert sich keiner für
Dirty Frag bei uns
auf der Arbeit.
Wie gesagt, bei Copyfail übelst Attacke gemacht, bei Dirtyfrag nicht mal irgendwie eine E-Mail, bis wann das gefixt werden soll oder so.
Hat einfach keinen mehr interessiert.
Keine Ahnung.
Die Logik habe ich nicht so genau verstanden, ehrlich gesagt.
Guck mal, Docker geht jetzt nicht, weil wir Kernel-Updates gemacht haben.
Warum? Warum geht Docker?
Normalerweise ist Docker immer kaputt, weil man Kernel-Updates gemacht hat.
Oh, es gewittert, Leute.
Gewitter?
So, sind wir dann stehen geblieben hier?
Wir klappen.
Wir gehen einfach hier.
Oh, kurz gehen.
Seid ihr schon wach?
Ich hoffe nicht, weil es ist ja Aufwachen-Stream.
Oh Gott, sowas trinken
So
Und ansonsten
War glaube ich die Woche
Oh, wir haben 6, 7 Leute
Zuschauer, wobei das ja eigentlich schon wieder
Komplett outdated ist, sagt ja schon keiner mehr
Seit 5 Uhr morgens
Langes Gewitter
Das ist ja mittlerweile schon wieder komplett
Outdated, overrated
Wenn das bei den ganzen
Boomer-Leuten wie mir angekommen ist,
da können wir davon ausgehen,
dass Generation Alpha
schon wieder das nächste hat.
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, was das nächste ist.
Das dauert wieder ein paar Monate, bis ich das mitkriege.
Ich bin da einfach
nicht
mehr am Puls der Zeit, ja.
Dein Wubblos-Wecker
sorgt für Unmut.
Tja, da musst du überlegen, was wichtiger ist.
Der Wubblos-Wecker oder
der Frieden im Haushalt.
Also so gerne ich dich natürlich hier auch im Stream hab,
wenn du am Start bist, aber
wahrscheinlich ist es besser,
den Wupplerswecker etwas leiser zu stellen.
Bei uns hat es gestern oder vorgestern Nacht
bin ich aufgewacht, weil es übelst geplitzt hat
und angefangen hat zu regnen.
Das ist ja immer ziemlich laut,
euch das bei mir am
Roller an und alles.
Patch Day, ach ja.
Kaneloni.
Kanelonian.
Nee, sorry.
Patch Day, Sonntag, ja.
Patch, ist, ist,
was heißt, was heißt, das muss ich jetzt mal fragen.
Weil ich hatte es ja gerade da vorne,
aber hast du glaube ich noch nicht da.
Was heißt bei euch Patch Day? Ist es jetzt
für die ganzen Sicherheitslücken, die es in letzter Zeit
unter Linux, oder machst du überhaupt Linux?
Oder ist Windows-Stells angesagt?
Oder ist das so ein
wir haben zweimal im Jahr
Patch-Day und heute ist es soweit.
Wie ist das bei euch? Also ich kann nur sagen,
bei uns
ist das je nach
Service eingeteilt,
wann Patch-Day ist.
Und bei meinem jetzigen
Arbeitgeber, finde ich, ist das auch deutlich besser
gelöst als bei meinem letzten.
Weil bei meinem letzten Arbeitgeber waren
Betriebssystem-Patches und
System-Uptime immer so im Konflikt.
Also sprich,
da haben meistens die Leute
Recht bekommen,
die gesagt haben, System-Uptime
ist wichtiger. Du hast gesagt, ey,
gibt Sicherheitslücke, wir müssen patchen.
Ja, oder
keine Ahnung, wir müssen hier
neue Red Hat meiner
Version upgraden oder sowas.
Da kamen immer die Leute, ja,
aber demnächst ist eine wichtige
Abrechnung, ah, demnächst ist das und das
und das, da können wir jetzt nicht patchen, da können wir jetzt nicht
patchen, patchen, und witzigerweise
sogar die Security-Leute, was halt
komplett der Witz ist, weil genau die sollten es eigentlich
anders sehen, haben auch gesagt, naja, da warten
wir halt noch ein paar Wochen und machen das, also
beim letzten Arbeitgeber war das komplett lächerlich,
da wurde eigentlich so gut wie nie,
außer bei so wirklich harten
Sachen wie, wie, wie Hardbleed
oder sowas, ja,
an den Loadbalancern
am Eingang, wo man vom Internet rangekommen
ist und so, da wurde dann
gepatcht, aber ansonsten
Wurde nicht gepatcht.
Das ist, bei meinem jetzigen Arbeitgeber ist das viel besser gelöst.
Entweder es gibt eine Mail vom Chef, also vom Chef des Chefs.
Und der schreibt, ey, guck mal hier, Security hat mich drüber informiert.
Oder ich wurde drüber informiert.
Es gibt hier kritische Sicherheitslücken.
Laut der Einschätzung, bla bla bla, ist das so und so wichtig.
Bitte bis in 7 Tagen, 14 Tagen das alles gepatcht haben.
Das ist bei dringenden Sachen.
alternativ haben wir so ein schwachstellen scanner laufen im hintergrund der guckt anhand von bock
frag mich nicht von irgendwelchen cv datenbanken oder so guckt er was für pakete auf dem system
drauf sind was für packages installiert sind und errechnet daraus quasi einen sicherheits score
Kann ich nicht aussprechen, aber
Dankeschön für den Prime Sub.
Anhand von dem Namen würde ich wahrscheinlich drauf tippen,
ist es der Chainlord vielleicht.
Ne, das Synox ist das.
Aha, man muss das anklicken.
Exzellente Subscription.
Da wird dann so ein
Sicherheitsscore errechnet
und wenn du über einem bestimmten Wert bist,
wirst du angezählt.
Dann erscheint das ganz prominent in so einem fetten Dashboard.
Systeme, die über einem gewissen Score liegen.
Die erscheinen dann quasi in einem Dashboard und wandern in dem Dashboard immer weiter hoch.
Und keiner will oben in dem Dashboard stehen.
Zumal, also die sind ja auch bei sowas ein bisschen härter drauf.
Finde ich aber eigentlich auch ganz gut.
Das ist dann so.
Irgendwann stehst du halt ganz oben in dem Dashboard.
Und nach 45 Tagen eskaliert das Ganze, wenn du es innerhalb von 45 Tagen nicht gepatcht hast, eskaliert das Ganze zu deinem direkten Chef und nach 60 Tagen eskaliert das dann zum Abteilungsleiter. Und frag mich nicht, eskaliert das bis zum Chef von der IT oder bis zum Vorstand oder sonst was, wenn sich da nichts tut.
Und das will natürlich jeder vermeiden. Und noch besser, noch besser, Kollektivstrafe, wenn es einmal bis zum Abteilungsleiter eskaliert ist, solche Security-Dinger und keiner macht was, dann gibt es 0,1% Bonus weniger.
Ja, und jetzt haltet euch fest, nicht nur für denjenigen, der es verkackt hat,
nein, für das ganze Team, in dem die Services liegen.
Das heißt, du hast sehr viele Anreize, es nicht eskalieren zu lassen.
Kann man sagen, ist ja vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber finde ich nicht.
Ich finde das eigentlich eine gute Sache, weil man hat ja immer, ich meine, 45 Tage.
Ne, ne, ne, pro Eskalation
Mehr, sonst, mehr, mehr gibt's nicht
Ähm
Also, ne, Moment, Moment, Moment
0,1% ist Blödsinn
Das, ich mein nicht 0,1%
Blödsinn, 10%
Mal 0,1
Irgendwie sowas, ne, ne, 10% sind das
10% Bonus, nicht 0,1%
Das wäre ja bescheuert
Ne, ne
Das wäre, das wäre komplett sinnlos
0,1% ist es, das hab ich, äh, Blödsinn erzählt
Genau, und deswegen hat es
Also bei jeder Eskalation
Für alle in dem Team
Das heißt, stellt euch vor
Fünf Leute
Passen nicht auf, auf einmal kriegst du 50% Bonus
Und das macht richtig was aus, Leute
Das ist wirklich massive
Das sind ein paar tausend Euro weniger
Also das will auch keiner
Und soweit ich weiß, ist das auch noch nicht passiert
Bei uns im Team
Aber ich finde es, ehrlich gesagt, finde ich den Ansatz
ja eigentlich ganz gut.
Weil, dann hast
du an allen Stellen quasi
einen Anreiz, dass Security-Dinger
jetzt auch gepatcht werden. Weil es gibt doch nichts
schlechteres, wie
alle wissen drüber Bescheid, es gibt irgendeine Lücke.
Keiner
erachtet es als wichtig,
das zu patchen, weil irgendwelche Leute
halt sagen, du musst
jetzt auf meinem System das einrichten, das machen,
hier jenes machen, da ist was vollgelaufen, das geht nicht,
kannst du mal da gucken. So nach dem Motto, alles ist
immer wichtiger als irgendwelche Security-Patches einspielen.
Aber in dem Fall
kannst du einfach sagen, nee, guck mal
hier, wir sind über dem Score, wir müssen jetzt patchen.
Und
letztens, letztens war es tatsächlich,
passt, gutes Beispiel,
der Unterschied von meinem
jetzigen Arbeitgeber zu meinem letzten, ja.
Bei meinem letzten Arbeitgeber war es auch so, da haben die
immer gesagt, ah, aber System-Uptime
oder am Wochenende, da machen die Leute
dann irgendwelche Auswertungen, ah, und da werden
irgendwelche Reports generiert, wir können
erst irgendwie frühestens in zwei
Wochen um 4 Uhr 30
nachts patchen oder sowas.
Und dann wurde das auch immer, also so gut wie immer, akzeptiert
beim Arbeitgeber. So.
Bei uns, letztens war das so,
die Leute,
die für die Anwendung verantwortlich sind, die auf
diesem Service läuft,
also diesen Service quasi ausmacht,
die haben gesagt, oh ne, wir können jetzt nicht patchen,
am Wochenende gibt es wichtige Reports
und sonst was.
Und da hat mein Chef gesagt, okay,
wir sind jetzt rüber, sogar
sogar der, ähm,
unser Abteilungsleiter hat gesagt, wir müssen es bis da und dahin
patchen. Die haben jetzt zwei Sachen
zur Auswahl. Entweder
wir patchen
oder wir schalten das System
zum Stichtag ab. Die können sich
ausdenken, was ihnen lieber ist.
Abschalten oder patchen.
Und letztendlich,
wer hätte das gedacht,
die haben sich entschieden für patchen.
Und das
finde ich, das machen die auch gut da,
Die sagen dann auch gleich, wisst ihr was, wenn die sich querstellen, dann schickst du halt direkt zu mir.
So, du kannst dich halt da komplett rausreden mit, Leute, ich hab Vorgabe,
entweder wird das System jetzt am Wochenende gepatcht oder spätestens am Montag wird's ausgeschaltet.
Und wenn du die Auswahl hast, dann wird wahrscheinlich so ziemlich jeder Verantwortliche für eine Anwendung sagen,
ah ja gut, dann patch den Kram halt.
Ja, also das finde ich läuft deutlich besser da, wo ich jetzt bin, als beim letzten.
Generell muss man sagen, bei meinem letzten Arbeitgeber war echt sehr viel mehr Schein als Sein.
Also die haben mega viel Wert drauf gelegt, dass sie immer super gut dastehen und alles gut aussieht.
Aber intern, wenn man es kannte, war das halt teilweise das komplette Gegenteil.
Das ist auch so. Also wir haben beispielsweise einen Service.
Da ist zwar ein Loadbalancer davor.
Das ist irgendein HA-Proxy oder sowas, keine Ahnung was, aber aus dem betreiben wir nicht.
Und da gibt es zwei Backend-Server, wo irgendwelche Java-Anwendungsgedöns draufläuft.
Aber da schieben sie trotzdem immer Panik, so nach dem Motto, einer patchen und andere oben lassen geht nicht,
weil wenn jetzt mehrere große Verarbeitungen reinkommen, dann könnte es ja sein, dass der eine das nicht schafft.
Und da machen sie auch immer ein bisschen Panik.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Die Geschichten beim alten Arbeitgeber waren tatsächlich besser.
Weil da vieles abenteuerlicher lief. Das stimmt wohl.
Das stimmt. Zum Erzählen waren die Sachen auf der alten Arbeit besser.
Das System, mit dem wir täglich arbeiten und solche Geschichten.
Ja, das stimmt. Da hast du recht.
Wobei es ja ab und an auch ein paar lustige Sachen gibt.
dann setzt halt ein dritten auf das problem ist bei gekaufter software ist das oftmals
gar nicht so einfach das heißt neue lizenzgebühren vielleicht neue support verträge was auch immer
das ist gar nicht so einfach wie es auf den ersten blick aussieht solange wir uns im linux
open source umfeld bewegen ist das kein ding aber sobald du gekaufte software sondern software von
von IBM. Auf Java-Basis
von IBM. Irgend so was,
was es schon gefühlt seit 30 Jahren gibt.
Da kostet es wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung,
60.000 Euro Lizenzgebühren oder sowas.
Das Zeug ist ja immer
schweineteuer. Und das Schlimmste ist,
ohne Scheiß, Leute,
die Webseite, Leute. Diese Webseite
von IBM.
Kennt die jemand? Hat damit schon jemand
die Ehre gehabt? Die ist mittlerweile
besser als die alte.
Ja, die alte war noch beschissener.
Aber diese Webseite ist so dermaßen beschissen.
Das ist ganz, ganz schrecklich, diese Webseite.
Maxi war es bei den Java-Leuten, ich habe das noch nicht gemacht.
Icos sagt, ich bin jetzt schon eine Weile
arbeitslos nach meiner Ausbildung
oh, Sätke, ja du hast auch gerade
echt eine scheiß Zeit erwischt
das sagt, aber das wird auch wieder besser
es ist noch nicht so wirklich
abzusehen, so nach dem Motto
in einer Woche, in einem Monat, in einem Jahr
in fünf Jahren
das weiß aktuell keiner
aber es gibt Stellen, so ist es nicht
also, ich würde die Hoffnung nicht aufgeben
Weil ich weiß sogar, bei uns gibt es aktuell drei Juniorstellen.
Also zumindest...
Also drei insgesamt.
Bei uns im Team ist es eine.
Und zwar für Storage-Admin.
Junior Storage-Admin suchen die bei uns gerade.
Hast du das von Noel gesehen?
Nee.
Ich dachte, der macht keine Videos mehr.
Seid ihr da?
Ist die IT-Ausbildung wirklich tot?
Oh, das können wir uns angucken.
Warum sollte die tot sein?
Fachinformatiker.
2000, 2000...
Ne, was?
1997...
Okay, das gucken wir uns gleich an.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Jetzt habe ich die Chance auf einen Job.
IT-Admin für IT-Sicherheit beim Amt.
Mit guten Behalten und flexiblen Arbeitszeiten.
Das Problem ist, die wollen Active Directory.
Von deinen Streams habe ich viel darüber gehört, aber ich dachte mir, ich sollte es nicht vorverurteilen.
Ich soll es mal ausprobieren.
Und ja, ist absoluter Müll.
Naja, gut, ich sage ja immer, ich flame viel Windows-Gedöns, ich habe aber keine Ahnung davon.
Active Directory ist, um da jetzt mal tatsächlich auch was Positives zuzusagen,
Active Directory ist für das, was es macht, wahrscheinlich das Einzige und Beste, was es gibt.
die machen einen Unterschied zwischen normalem Neustart und Promotion-Neustart.
Normaler Neustart ist, wenn man auf den Neustart-Button drückt und Promotion-Neustart ist der Neustart, den man braucht, um Settings zu...
Ey, keine Ahnung, habe ich absolut keinen Plan von, aber ich glaube, dass das kacke ist, ja.
LDAP und Active Directory sind ja streng genommen nicht das gleiche, benutzt das aber auch immer synonym.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, ganz ehrlich,
beschäftige dich einfach mal 1-2 Wochen damit.
Und überzeugt die, dass du Ahnung davon hast und sichere dir erstmal den Job, weil...
Kein Job ist ja tatsächlich noch beschissener als was mit Windows.
Wobei...
Nee, nee.
Und was noch besser ist, gerade wenn du dann erstmal hier deinen Fuß in der Tür hast, bietet es ja wahrscheinlich auch Möglichkeiten, dass du intern auch mal auf eine andere Stelle wechseln kannst oder sowas.
Also ich würde da auf jeden Fall gucken.
Mach das lieber.
Also es macht ja keinen Sinn, quasi dauerhaft wählerisch zu sein und es gibt gerade sonst nichts.
Mach das hier, schnapp dir das, beschäftige dich ein bisschen mit Active Directory.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, wie gesagt, ich habe absolut keine Ahnung von Active Directory.
Aber es gibt so viele Leute bei uns auf der Arbeit, die sich mit Windows und Active Directory beschäftigen und mit Windows-Kram.
Und die sind gefühlt auch nicht mehr abgefuckt als die Linux-Admins.
Die sind halt über andere Sachen abgefuckt.
Also, mir hält das schon aus.
Das ist jetzt nicht, als wäre das irgendwie der Teufel oder so.
Bock hätte ich da auch nicht drauf, sage ich dir ganz ehrlich.
Aber wenn du da erstmal, und ich glaube, das ist wahrscheinlich echt das Beste,
wenn du da erstmal den Fuß in der Tür hast,
gibt es ja vielleicht auch noch andere interne Stellen,
weil die meisten Sachen werden ja erstmal intern ausgeschrieben.
Das ist es ja.
Bis es eine externe Ausschreibung gibt, dauert ja immer.
Ich denke mal, das ist beim Amt wahrscheinlich genauso.
und da kannst du intern nach neuen jobs gucken und sagen ach guck mal da da gibt es ja was in
dem bereich wo ich bock drauf hätte kann es immer noch wechseln erst mal fuß in die tür kriegen
glaube ich in dem fall echt das beste und gerade wenn du erst die ausbildung gemacht hast dann hast
du auch gleich mal 123 jahre berufserfahrung die drauf schreiben kannst und auch schon mal was wert
würdest du heute noch raten eine physikausbildung zu machen von dem man sich zu lesen ist echt schwer
eine arbeit zu finden falls man nicht übernommen wird nach der ausbildung naja das ding ist es ist
so ziemlich überall schwer also es dürfte schwer sein ob jetzt eine physik ausbildung gemacht hast
ob du irgendeiner vielen informatik studiengänge besucht dass es dürfte überall schwer sein und
es ist ja nicht nur in der it schwer es ist ja woanders auch schwer also meiner meinung nach
wir gucken wir gucken uns mal wir gucken uns gleich mal vom noel das video an meiner meinung
ist die fahreinformatik ausbildung noch eines der besseren sachen die man machen kann
ich war gestern wieder kurz davor video aufzunehmen und jetzt wird es aber kühl hier
was mit meiner klimaanlage los wie pustet ordentlich kühl naja 23,5 grad so kühl ist
ist jetzt nicht 24,1 sogar hier oben
frankfurt ist gewitter hier war auch gerade gewitter
das stimmt wohl hat der potato bob auch recht active directory wird man immer
brauchen solange es windows clients gibt und ich sehe nicht das ende von windows
Clients. Also Active Directory
kannst du dich lange mit
rumschlagen. Bis zur Rente.
Gerade bei einem Amt.
Gibt es das eigentlich noch?
Früher gab es ja diese
Novellen-Network-Geschichte
als AD-Alternative.
Bei mir an der Berufsschule,
by the way,
ich war ja in der besten Berufsschule
ever.
Werner von
Siemens Schule in Frankfurt.
Dort gab es
ganz am Anfang, wo ich
optimale, beste Bewertungen
ähm
da gab es ganz am Anfang
auch noch
Novell Network
oder sowas.
Exzellent.
Exzellentes.
Äh.
Was ist mit denen hier los?
Ein bisschen zugeparkt, würde ich sagen, ja
Das ist ja das beste Foto an der Berufsschule
Übernachtet erstmal der Penner um die Ecke
Aber gut, Frankfurt Bahnhofsviertel, ne
Und das sieht, guck mal Leute, das sieht wirklich aus wie ein Knast von außen
Findet ihr nicht auch?
Ah, yes, das musste, Leute, das musste unbedingt mal fotografiert werden
Den verschissenen Klo in der Werner-von-Siemann-Schule
Das sieht wirklich aus, bisschen wie im Knast
Ne, guckt euch das hier an
Ne, das hier unten vielleicht weniger, das hier oben
Alter, das
Okay, lasst uns grad mal
Die neuesten Bewertungen angucken
Äh
Chat
Konnte man, konnte man die Reviews
Nicht mal nach Zeit sortieren
Äh
Das ging doch mal
Warum kann man die nicht mal nach Zeit sortieren?
So vielleicht
Ich muss
Locked in sein, um mich für die
Alter, Entschädification
Hoch 10, was ist das?
Vielleicht muss ich auch auf Maps
Äh, das Apple Maps, Moment
Google Maps
Oh Gott, Alter
Entritification überall
Äh, ne, ne, hier, die da
Okay, Rezension
Darf man hier sortieren?
Ah, hier darf man sortieren
Dafür ist hier das Fensterabfack klein
Warum?
Warum sind Webseiten mittlerweile so ultra beschissen gemacht?
Okay.
Also die sagen...
Okay, was sagt der hier denn?
Vor...
Moment, hier vor einem Monat.
Es gibt viel Negatives über die Schule zu sagen.
Zum Beispiel ist sie extrem veraltet, teilweise schimmelbefallen und sehr unübersichtlich aufgebaut.
Ja.
Die benutzen bestimmt noch Overhead-Projektoren und sowas.
weil sie für smartphone optimiert ist ja haben die schon mal fast von responsive web design gehört
man kann webseiten so bauen dass sie sowohl auf dem desktop als auch auf dem smartphone
gescheit aussehen so kann man auch zwei versionen der webseite bauen ich meine für so ein kleines
in die unternehmen wie google ist das natürlich schwierig das verstehe ich schon einzig positiv
ist eine Handvoll äußerst engagierter
und begabter Lehrer.
Das Strettmatter.
Den kenne ich noch.
Bei dem hatte ich auch mal Vertretung.
Keck weh.
Der ist anscheinend noch da.
Guck mal, es gibt sogar Lehrer,
die ich noch kenne hier in den Bewertungen.
Nicht empfehlenswert.
Der Unterricht ist auf einem
sehr niedrigen Niveau.
Das stimmt.
Unterrichtsmaterial wird copy-pasted.
Der Unterricht ist wirklich auf einem sehr niedrigen Niveau.
Also ich bin immer sehr gerne,
also obwohl die Berufsschule richtig kacke ist,
bin ich immer sehr gerne in die Berufsschule gegangen,
weil Berufsschule war wie Urlaub.
Du musstest einfach sechs Wochen nicht arbeiten gehen
und konntest übelst chillen den ganzen Tag.
Du hast Einser geschrieben,
vielleicht mal eine Zwei,
ohne dass du zugehört hast,
ohne dass du irgendwas gemacht hast.
Das einzige Fach, wo mir mein Lehrer
Mal eine schlechtere Note
Gegeben hat, schlechtere Note war da anstatt einer 1
Eine 2, war weil er über das
Ladekabel von meinem Nintendo DS gefallen ist
Wo ich unter dem Tisch
Mario Kart gespielt hab
Während der, was war das? BWL
Oder irgendwie sowas
Hat er gesagt, ja
Max, du bist ja nicht immer aufgepasst
Und sonst was, du kriegst nur eine 2
Ja okay, kann ich mitleben
Hast du Sport gehabt? Ja
hatte ich.
Damals war ich unsportlich as fuck.
Also wenn da eure Azubis durch...
Wir hatten auch einen, der ist durchgefallen.
Das ist der gleiche, der
2 von 100 Punkten bei der Datenbankarbeit
bekommen hat, weil er zweimal Create Table
auf ein weißes Blatt geschrieben hat.
Und den Rest mehr oder weniger nur die Aufgabe
abgeschrieben hat.
Das war auch nichts für den.
Aber sogar der hat es im zweiten Anlauf geschafft.
An sich war das ein wirklich
sehr netter Typ.
Bin ich gut klar gekommen.
Aber Ahnung von der Sache hat er nicht gehabt.
Was zum Teufel bin ich hier sehend?
Hä?
Warum hat er eine Turban oder
irgendwie sowas auf? Na gut, Frankfurt Bahnhofsviertel.
Da ist das Standard mittlerweile.
Was das auch immer mit der Berufsschule zu tun hat
Was gilt hier ab?
Sanitäre Anlagen, wo Organisationen sowie Absprachlernschule sind
Auf dem untersten Niveau
Die Lüftungsanlage dient anscheinend nur zur Deko
WC-Brillen sind montags nach Öffnung
Noch alle vollgepisst
Ja
Vor den Toren hinter der Sporthalle
Schlafen morgens noch die Obdachlosen
Ja gut, das ist nix Neues
Das war bei mir auch schon so
Das sah ein bisschen nach KI aus, ja
Homeschooling
Moment, sowas kriegen die da schon auf die Reihe?
Da die Stuhl...
Also ganz ehrlich, bei mir in der Berufsschule hat das keine Sau interessiert, ob die Leute zu spät gekommen sind, weil die konnten eh nichts machen.
Ganz ehrlich, was soll so ein Lehrer machen, außer die eine schlechtere Note oder zu sagen, oh, ich muss meinen Betrieb anrufen.
Und wenn der Betrieb dann sagt, ja, juckt mich nicht, sind die Lehrer in der Berufsschule verbeamtet.
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Ich würde drauf tippen, wahrscheinlich so halbe halbe.
Die Alten eher, die Neuen weniger.
Keine Ahnung
Was, okay
Traue ich mich das Video anzuklicken, Leute?
Achso, das ist
Wo die Autos da stehen
Na egal, zumindest meine Berufsschule war ziemlich beschissen
Um das mal abzuhaken
Ein Katastrophengebiet
Wo fange ich an?
Erstmal das Gebäude
Alter, richtiger Roman hier
Ja, also die Berufsschule ist richtig kacke gewesen
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung
Wie bin ich jetzt überhaupt auf die Berufsschule
Ach genau
Weil die noch Novell Networks oder irgendwie sowas am Anfang hatten
Als ich da neu war
Jetzt weiß ich's wieder
Chat, ich weiß, bei euch gibt's hier ein paar Leute
Die auch in Frankfurt am Start sind
Die Chancen sind zwar relativ gering.
Ist zufällig jemand in Frankfurt auch an der Werner von Siemens Schule gewesen?
Wahrscheinlich. Also die Chancen sind wirklich gering, aber man weiß ja nie.
Hast du dich schon beworben? Ja, easy. Das klappt schon.
Das klappt schon.
Du kannst dich sicherlich überzeugen, dass du der absolute AD-Expert bist.
Wobei, wenn es eine Juniorstelle ist, musst du dich ja nicht mal großartig überzeugen,
dass du der krasseste Experte ever bist.
Also was bei mir in der Bewerbung gut ankam, ich habe keine Ahnung wie das beim Amt ist, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Was bei mir gut ankam war, dass ich trotz dem, dass ich kein Anwendungsentwickler bin, ein GitHub-Account mitgeschickt habe bei der Bewerbung.
und die haben die sich das an die haben sich bei github die haben sich mal nicht
nur plotz tv die haben sich mal geht haben wohl auch angeguckt weil die haben
über ein paar sachen mit mir in der in der klinik mal wieder aus man die über
ein paar sachen geredet in der bewerbung wir haben unter anderem zum beispiel im
vorstellungsgespräch über den fiat champ geredet damals damals hatte er aber noch
nicht 48 ungelöste issues und ein paar sachen ich habe ihnen gezeigt dass ich hoffe das habe
ich überhaupt noch ich habe ihnen gezeigt dass ich schon ein bisschen was mit kuba netz auf
das kann nicht sein das kann nicht sein alle maß seit wann bin ich da 2023 das war danach
zwar nach meiner bewerbung habe ich das gelöst habe ich gelöscht
oder nee moment ich hab doch so ein
ich hab doch so ein blödes dass da hier ich weiß auch nicht warum ich so eine
komische organisation aufbaut hier dass das habe ich gezeigt dass ich dass ich
hier sogar auf GitHub
Kubernetes-Config-Gedöns
am Start habe.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was wir da überhaupt
gemacht haben. Argo-CD-Gedöns.
Ja.
Also das kam bei meinem Vorstellungsgespräch
wirklich gut an mit dem GitHub-Account.
Kam richtig gut an.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sich das... Ganz ehrlich,
Beim Amt sind die wahrscheinlich noch unflexibler.
Was da nicht auf einer Checkliste zum Abhaken steht, interessiert sie nicht.
Aber bei mir kam das gut an.
Leider war ich damals noch nicht fit.
Heute würde ich den ganzen wegrennen.
Auch den...
Oder abhängen würde ich sie alle.
Auch den ganzen jungen Leuten.
Okay, vielleicht den jungen Fußballspielern da, die wir in der Klasse hatten.
Da hatten wir zwei Stück.
Die vielleicht nicht.
aber den Rest würde ich easy abhängen.
Damals war ich auch noch jünger.
Also wenn ich so fit wie heute wäre,
plus in dem Alter von damals,
dann würde ich die easy alle abhängen.
Bei der Stadt Frankfurt werden bei Vorstellungsgesprächen
nur ein Standard-Fragenkatalog gestellt.
Also sprich, es wird null irgendwie
auf die jeweiligen Bewerber eingegangen und umgedreht.
Oder wie? Das ist aber ganz schön dumm.
Weil du kriegst ja überhaupt nichts raus über die Leute.
Aber gut, was erwartet man da?
Okay, dann schauen wir mal.
Sekunde, Leute, ich muss mein Headset absetzen,
mein Ohr juckt.
So.
Dann gucken wir doch mal, was...
Achso, ich habe Chatterino ja gar nicht gestartet.
Immer hin und her switchen sonst.
also da lassen wir uns mal gucken was trendet denn heute nicht heute woche was
trendet denn diese woche so auf shithub money printer turbo das hatten wir schon
mal. Understand anything.
Ah,
KI, KI, KI,
KI, KI,
AI,
Python tool for converting files and office
documents to Markdown. Das ist von Microsoft.
Wollen wir mal gucken,
wollen wir mal gucken, ob es
ein Microslop-Projekt
ist.
Ey, wo ist denn überhaupt der Source-Code, Leute?
Hier, Packages.
Mark it down.
Source, mark it down.
Moment, Tommel?
Ist das, ich hätte erst gedacht, das ist Rust oder so.
Trenne das nicht schon seit 8 Wochen, kann sein.
Mark it down, Pi, okay.
Jetzt brauchen wir die Python-Kenner.
Ich tippe drauf, das ist auf jeden Fall mit Vibe-Coded.
Das ist doch, das ist doch Vibe-Coded, oder?
Das haben die bestimmt Vibe-Coded.
Ich kann Python-Code nicht so gut lesen, ob sie Vibe-Coded sind oder nicht.
Aber allein schon das, das ist bestimmt Vibe-Coded.
Okay
Microslop hat wieder zugeschlagen
AI
Geil, super, geile Woche, Leute
Es war ja bis auf
Es war bis auf 1
Alles AI
Und das was nicht AI war
Ist Vibe Coded
Top
Okay
Leute wir müssen uns mal eine Runde schocken lassen
Was trennt er denn bei C++
Kann man gleich ein bisschen rumflamen
Witzig ist bei C++ Projekten immer
Das
die Projekte,
die haben oftmals Beschreibungen und alles,
aber ich verstehe null. Die C++-Projekte
sind oftmals genauso wie die Sprache
selbst. Du guckst dir das Projekt an
und denkst dir, was wollen
die überhaupt von mir? Okay, das hier
verstehe ich, das ist KI.
Wasserzeichen entfernen.
Firmware Launcher for ESP32.
Warum brauchen wir einen
Firmware Launcher for ESP32
Boards? Was
wie jetzt?
So, das ist quasi, kriegt man ein Menü, wo man sich, ja gut, das ist jetzt für eigene
Entwicklung vielleicht nicht so spannend.
Serenity Operating System, warum ist das in C++?
Und
Das ist auf jeden Fall
von deutschen Entwicklern entwickelt.
Äh
Es hat ein bisschen was von
Windows 95, oder? Findet ihr nicht auch?
der grund war es ein lauf letter to 90s user interfaces mit der kasten unix like
core okay das ist quasi eher so eine demonstration was man alles machen kann
ich glaube nicht dass das wirklich dafür gedacht ist so als daily driver benutzt zu werden
Sieht doch wirklich aus wie Windows Pop-up-Nordisch.
Eigentlich ganz cooles Projekt.
Also wirklich nix vibe-gecodetes.
Coole Sache.
Ich will mal kurz reingucken
Ah, keine Ahnung
Das sieht auch nicht
Gut, C++ sieht immer eklig aus
Und das ist noch ordentliches C++
Aber die Syntax, Alter
Ich krieg immer Anfälle, wenn ich das schon sehe
Das ist so schlimm
Und das ist noch hübsches C++, ja.
Wenn ihr mal, also die mit Abstand, also C++ hat ja schon viel hässliche Syntax, ja.
Aber die mit Abstand, wo sie sich wirklich komplett selbst übertroffen haben,
ist eines der neuesten Features von C++.
Und das ist C++ Reflection.
Da hatte Heise sogar einen ganz guten Artikel dazu.
Leute, diese Syntax, ey.
Die müsst ihr euch geben.
Es wird noch schlimmer.
Guckt euch das an, Alter.
Guckt euch das an.
Was zum Teufel soll dann das Design?
Wer hat denn dahin geschissen, einfach mal in den Editor, als sie das entworfen haben?
Hier, guckt euch das alle ein, schon das da.
Guckt euch das...
Eckige Klammer auf.
Doppelpunkt.
Expand Standard Meta Enumerators off.
Hütchen.
E.
Doppelpunkt.
Klammer zu.
Ähm, Shift.
Alter, was zum Teufel
Das ist wirklich so
Das ist gefacerollt
Ich weiß wie das entstanden ist
Die haben den Editor aufgemacht
Und sind einmal facerollt
Was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Chat, Chat, was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Ich habe gefacerollt
Ich glaube, ich habe die
Wie kriege ich das jetzt wieder zu?
Oh, fuck
Jetzt ist es wieder weg
Okay
Was habe ich denn da gerade aufgemacht?
War das die Xbox
War das diese Xbox Game Bar
Die ich auf
Ah, diesen Schrott hier, geh mal weg
Wie mache ich das wieder weg?
Escape, okay.
Das ist auch so ein Feature.
Gibt es irgendjemand?
Gibt es irgendjemand
unter Windows, der diesen Krempel
verwendet?
Wie ist eigentlich der offizielle
Weg, es zu schließen?
Alles wegklicken, okay.
Nutzt das irgendjemand?
So, ja so ungefähr ist diese Syntax hier entstanden.
Die haben den Editor aufgemacht und sind einmal wild gefacerollt über die Tastatur.
Und da kommt dann sowas hierbei raus.
Anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären.
Jetzt Chat, Chat, Chat.
Ernstgemeinte Frage.
Ich weiß, wir haben einige.
Es ist zwar erstaunlich, aber...
Aber es ist so, wir haben tatsächlich einige richtig große C++-Fans hier im Stream, ab und zu zumindest.
Gerade wenn ich Microcontroller-C++-Zeug mache, die mir dann immer erklären wollen, das hat alles schon so seinen Sinn, warum das so ist, wie es ist.
Vielleicht haben wir jetzt ja auch einer von den großen C++-Fans hier.
Chat, gibt es irgendjemand
von euch, der wirklich
denkt, das ist
eine schöne Syntax
oder umgedreht, sagen wir mal, nicht eine schöne
das ist eine Syntax, die muss so sein
so und nicht anders und das
ist ganz klar, was es bedeutet
würde mich wirklich interessieren
ob es da überhaupt Leute gibt
weil wenn es da keine Leute
gibt und das frage ich mich
bei C++ Features oft
also so gut wie keine Leute gibt, dann frage ich mich
wie kommt das
durch das C++ Gremium überhaupt
durch? Sind die Leute, die
in diesem Gremium sitzen, so
krass detached von der Realität
dass die sowas
fabrizieren und durchwinken oder was?
Okay, keiner, das dachte ich mir
Niemand kann das schön finden
Das sieht so zum Kotzen aus
Guckt euch das an
Das ist so dermaßen hässlich
Unleserlich
Und voll mit kryptischen Sonderzeichen
Wo keiner weiß an welcher Stelle sie was bedeuten
Lass mal kurz heiße Kommentare lesen
Vielleicht nützlich
Okay
Aber lesbar
Okay, okay, was sagen die Kommentare?
Das haben wir doch schon mal gelesen, oder?
Ja, geil
Und, okay, okay
Und deswegen muss es hässlich sein, oder was?
Und deswegen muss es hässlich sein
Ah, okay, okay, ich verstehe
Die Begründung, warum es hässlich sein muss, ist
Weil es eh nicht viele verwenden.
Logisch.
Obviously. C++ Logik.
Features, die viele Leute nicht verwenden,
müssen anscheinend hässlich sein.
Okay, klar. Logisch. Was sonst?
Egal.
Ich darf jetzt nicht weitermachen, sonst rege ich mich wieder nur
halbe Stunde über C++ auf.
Wir verstehen das nicht.
Genau.
Das ist es. Ich verstehe es ja wirklich nicht.
Ich muss ja da immer eine halbe Stunde irgendwelche Erklärungen zu durchlernen, dass ich es verstehe.
Aber das kann ja nicht Sinn und Zweck von der Programmiersprache sein, dass du in fünf Zeilen Code schreiben musst.
Das ist ja nicht so, dass das absichtlich hässlich gemacht ist.
Das ist ja das, was ich bei C++ immer lustig finde.
C++ ist die hässlichste Sprache, die nicht hässlich sein will.
Ja, es gibt Sprachen wie Widespace oder Brainfuck oder so.
Die sind explizit dafür gemacht, beschissen auszusehen und kompliziert zu schreiben zu sein.
Aber C++ ist die am besten hässlichste Sprache, die nicht hässlich sein will.
Man kann Rust auch super hässlich programmieren, ja.
Und manchmal sieht Rust auch echt abfuck eklig aus.
Aber man versteht es, wenn man das dann Schritt für Schritt durchgeht.
Egal, gucken wir mal weiter durch.
KI, KI,
KI,
TXSQL,
aha,
Tendit,
Tencent, ah, China-Chinesen,
Microcontroller-Stells,
KI,
Lead-Code-Problems,
ESP32-Firmware,
Was ist das?
Also nix für mich, aber...
Keine Screenshots.
Zedke.
Uede.
Ah, hier.
Blazingly fast.
China-Chinesen-Kram.
Brutto-Buff.
React Native.
Es sind enorm viele
China-Chinesen-Projekte, die auf dem
ESP32 aufbauen.
Interesting.
So, gehen wir mal
zu Blazingly Fast, Krustentiere
über.
Hast du dir schon einen neuen 3D-Drucker gekauft?
Ne, ich drucke auch in letzter Zeit
so gut wie nix. Ich kaufe erstmal auch keinen.
Agent Multiplexer,
that lives in your terminal.
KI.
Document Parser.
Was wird da geparst?
Da wird erstmal
ran gesumt.
Äh.
War was?
Was?
Hä? Ich hab's nicht gecheckt.
Ich hab's. Ich check's nicht.
Was bin ich hier sehend?
der passt PDFs und dann
Standalone
Fast and Light Parsing
Aber
Aber was wie, hä?
Okay, das ist zu
high IQ für mich.
III
Was soll denn das sein?
KI-Stells
Ah, das hatten wir schon mal.
Das habe ich das letzte Mal schon nicht gecheckt, was das sein soll.
Nostril VPN.
Keine Description.
Tailscale. Okay.
KI.
Screenpipe. AI.
AI that knows
what you have seen,
said or heard.
records everything you do say or hear 24 7 local private secure ich will selbst
local keine private private ki haben die alles auf einem rechner aufzeichnet
das ist quasi microsoft recall nur selbst gehostet okay so schauen wir mal
was bei Go sich so tut die Woche.
CCX.
AX.
Open Source Distributed Agent Runtime.
Clans.
Wie gesagt, Leute.
H-Top.
Immer noch beste.
Achso, das ist was ganz was anderes.
Das ist was ganz was anderes.
Gab es nicht auch Clans?
Clans gab es das nicht auch so als Hardtop Alternative?
Die Cloud bilde mir ein, das gab es doch.
Ach ne, Clanses.
Clanses.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich bin immer noch Hardtop Fanboy.
Beste.
Das einzige, was ich mir noch wünschen würde für Hardtop, was mega wäre, wenn die das irgendwann mal einbauen
Ich meine, die haben ja erst innerhalb der letzten zwei Jahre oder so, oder drei Jahre
Haben die ja diesen I.O. Tab hier, den gibt es ja noch nicht so lange
Ja, dass du dir angucken kannst, welche Prozesse wie viel Disk I.O. und sowas verursachen
Warum machen die nicht noch einen dritten Tab für Netzwerk I.O.?
Dann wäre H-Top perfekt, komplett für alles, was ich überhaupt bräuchte.
Auch Netzwerk, Bandbreite und es wäre wirklich komplett perfekt.
Gibt es eigentlich... Gucken wir mal, ob es da irgendwelche Ambitionen für gibt vielleicht.
Suchen wir doch mal hier.
Network, mal gucken, was wir da so finden.
Ja, hier, guck mal, Feature-Wish. Schau, Network-Bandwidth-Usage per Process.
Au, das ist schon offen seit 2020.
Okay, naja, gibt's noch nix.
Aber das wär richtig nice.
Prometheus trendet.
Oder wie die Amis sagen, Prometheus.
Zu Recht.
Whitelist Bypass.
Okay, das bestimmt irgendwelche China-Chinesen-Sachen.
Notified Skillshare.
Cloud Native Vector Database.
Das klingt schon nach AI.
Sing Thing.
Das gibt es auch schon richtig lang.
ETCD.
Was ist das noch?
Gut, Kubernetes-Stells benutzt es halt.
Headscale.
Edgar Holm,
Krautsack,
Hires,
Hugo, das gibt es auch noch, das gibt es auch schon
Jahre, gibt es auch schon ewig.
So ein Static Sight Generator.
So, und dann als
letztes mal gucken, was bei
C-Sharp so trendet.
Skills, aber das machen wir jetzt schnell.
Meistens ist da nämlich überhaupt nichts Spannendes bei
Pixie Editor.
Was ist das?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das unbedingt so das Beste...
Ach, ist das so ein Pixel für Pixel Art?
Ah ja.
Ja, warum nicht?
Nichts, was ich bräuchte, aber coole Sache.
DNS-Server trennet.
umtrennten dns server in c sharp mit 86 stern was was ist denn an dem so so
besonders
warum das nicht dns mask oder sowas ok oder kann aber viel hier
Müsste ich mir irgendwas drüber lesen, warum das so geil ist.
Der hat ein Video zugemacht.
Ja, ja.
Habe ich auch letztens in den YouTube-Empfehlungen gesehen.
Ja.
Moment, das ist mein eigenes Video.
Gibt es eigentlich eine neue VeraCrypt-Version?
Wird doch mal Zeit.
Wann läuft das Microsoft-Ut-Zertifikat aus?
Bis dahin brauchst du, glaube ich, eine neue VeraCrypt-Version.
Okay, also wir haben jetzt alles geupdatet hier.
hier war auch geupdatet perfekt
aha mein code das heißt du verwendest das
Okay, dann wissen wir jetzt was auf...
Okay, Chat, eins noch, eins noch.
Weil hier jemand Pearl geschrieben hat.
Komm.
Das haben wir noch nicht gemacht.
Es interessiert mich auch nicht wirklich.
Mich interessiert nur, ob es da überhaupt was gibt.
Pass mal auf.
Pearl.
This week.
Exif Metatool.
Flamecraft.
Pearl 5. Pearl selbst trendet.
Guck mal, wie Pearl einfach nur 2,2
K-Sterne hat, lul.
Lan Raragi.
What the fuck?
Was?
Ah!
Das ist was für die Weeps.
Alles klar.
Ja, RF-Programmer.
Jetzt hast du Weep-Content.
Das ist nicht Toss.
Das ist doch verhältnismäßig
zurückhalten,
würde ich mal verlaufen.
Flamecraft ist geil.
Okay, wenn das jemand sagt, muss ich das mal anklicken.
Warum ist da dieser dumme
Mauszeiger jetzt wieder im Weg?
Ach, das ist das. Das kenne ich.
Das kenne ich, ja. Gucken kannst,
wie lang die Software
quasi bei welcher Funktion hängt.
So, wir gucken uns jetzt mal
Beautiful Pearl an.
Pearl ist auch so ein Ding für sich, ey.
Pearl ist echt so ein Ding für sich.
Ich find, Pearl sieht so hässlich aus.
Ich mein, ist nicht C++-Reflection-Level hässlich.
Aber schon hässlich, ja.
Also schon irgendwie hässlich, ja.
Schon hässlich.
Was ist das?
Ist das eine Endlosschleife in Perl oder was ist das?
While, auf, eckige, auf, eckige, zu, runde, zu.
Das könnte auch eine C++-Syntax sein, so kacke wie das ist.
Das kenne ich sogar, das ist zum Projekte analysieren, wie viele Lines of Code was ist, wie viele Kommentare und sowas.
Ich glaube, das ist so alt, in dem Fall ist Agent nichts, was mit KI zu tun hat.
Glppi Agent.
Okay, was auch immer.
Okay, jetzt haben wir auch gesehen, was bei Pearl so trendet.
Jetzt muss ich mal was trinken.
Eine Runde Tee.
Und dann gucken wir uns
das Video vom Noel an. Mal gucken, was der dazu sagt.
Ist die IT-Ausbildung wirklich tot?
So, aber vorher
Ich wollte aber den Chat lesen, weil ich in der Zeit, wo ich über C++ geflamed habe, null in den Chat geguckt habe.
Euren 3D-Druck habe ich nicht gekauft, ne.
Ne, okay, gut.
Excellent.
Nee, nee, will ich nicht.
Will ich nicht.
Nee, nee, nee, mach dir keine...
Discord bleibt.
Ich hab sogar reingeguckt letztens wieder.
Schrei mir immer viele.
Also, so lange das Leute benutzen,
werde ich es nicht dicht machen.
So.
Ist die IT-Ausbildung wirklich tot?
Dann schauen wir mal.
Was da mein Physikollege so dazu sagt.
Warum hast du aufgehört?
Ich habe da nie jeden Tag reingeguckt.
Ich benutze das jetzt genauso wie früher.
Kein Unterschied.
Er ist Anwendungsentwickler, das stimmt. Ja gut, aus dem Gesichtspunkt könnte ich mir vorstellen, gerade was Anwendungsentwicklung angeht, sehen ja alle so ein bisschen den Untergang des Entwicklers. Ich sehe es noch nicht, ich sehe es selbst noch nicht so, aber da ist auf jeden Fall mehr in Bewegung.
Nüte
Neat
Ist es Neat
Oder ist es
Sowas wie
Bite
Plus Neid
Dankeschön für den Prime Sub
Exzellente Subscriptions
Huge
Dann gucken wir uns das doch mal an
Dieses Video richtet sich an alle
Die eine Ausbildung in der IT machen möchten
Kurze Storyline
Ich hab letztens ein Video auf TikTok hochgeladen
wo ich Tipps zur Fachinformatika-Ausbildung gegeben habe.
Einfach so drei schnelle Tipps, die so ein bisschen allgemeingültig sind,
wo man gut durch die Ausbildung damit kommt.
Und dann habe ich das Video ein bisschen ruhen lassen
und mir anschließend die Kommentare angeschaut.
Und 90% der Kommentare waren Kommentare wie solche hier.
Tipp Nummer 1, lass es sein.
Tipp Nummer 1.
Sind das TikTok-Kommentare?
Das sind eher, das sind eher, ähm,
das sind auch so YouTube-Kommentare, oder?
Lass mal kurz lesen.
Lass es sein, mach es nicht, Arbeitsmarkt schwierig,
Du musst dafür leben, um später...
Kannst du nichts, bekommst du nichts.
Naja gut, ganz ehrlich, ich finde das irgendwie auch gerechtfertigt.
Warum soll man fürs pure Existieren Geld bekommen?
Mag Berufe geben, wo man bezahlt wird für pure Anwesenheit,
aber so prinzipiell finde ich mal, kannst du nichts, bekommst du nichts,
jetzt auch nicht so verkehrt.
Oder zumindest, umgedreht sollte es so sein, kannst du was, bekommst du auch ordentlich was.
So müsste man das eigentlich hindrehen, ja.
Wenn du was kannst, sollst du auch ordentlich was für kriegen.
Okay, mach es bitte nicht in kleinen Unternehmen.
Okay, das könnte ich noch irgendwo nachvollziehen.
Wie gesagt, da wo ich die Ausbildung, also wie gesagt 2007, ja, wo ich die Ausbildung gemacht habe,
das war jetzt auch nicht der allergrößte Laden, der hatte, also dieser lokale Internetprovider,
wo ich damals gewesen bin, der hatte glaube ich damals, wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe,
200 Mitarbeiter und davon 50 Azubis.
Die wurden dazu eingesetzt, um billig Server durch Deutschland fahren zu dürfen und sowas.
Ja, und der Laden, der war im Nachhinein betrachtet wirklich nicht so geil.
Auf der anderen Seite muss ich sagen, ich habe sehr viel gelernt damals,
weil es keine Ausbildung gab.
Du konntest entweder da komplett dein Leben chillen und die ganze Ausbildung durch
oder du konntest mitmachen und
musstest dann aber auch mitmachen und musstest
was lernen. Also ich hab da sehr viel gelernt.
Man konnte, also man musste da auch sehr viel basteln.
Also ich würde sagen,
so Base von dem, was ich heute immer noch
mache, hab ich da wirklich gelernt.
Aber der Laden an sich war nicht gut. Aber trotzdem
hat es dazu geführt, dass ich da bin, wo ich heute bin.
Das heißt, da aus dem Gesichtspunkt war es jetzt auch gar nicht so schlecht.
Wenn ihr keine
IT-Nerds seid,
macht den Rotz nicht.
Übelst langweilig, vor allem im falschen Unternehmen, nur First Level Support.
Ja, das ist das Problem.
First Level Support.
First Level Support ist ja auch absoluter Shit, Mann.
Tipp Nummer 1, wer hat keinen Fachinformatiker?
Ja, und was ist die Alternative?
EDK Regaleinräumer, oder?
Also ich meine, wenn du dich für IT interessierst,
ist es doch immer noch eines der besten Sachen, die du machen kannst.
Es einfach nur machen,
wie es die letzten Jahre so ein bisschen Trend war.
Jeder Depp, der auch keinen Plan hat,
wird umgeschult auf Fachinformatiker.
Die machen das, weil es Kohle gibt, haben aber keine Ahnung.
Ja gut, da seid ihr halt da falsch aufgehoben.
schnell, moin,
Drucker per Fernwartung fixen,
wie machst du das, hast du eine Drohne, die für dich dann
Knöpfe drücken kann,
aber Drucker fixen,
das ist ja wirklich eher was für
irgendwelche
Aushilfen oder so, also
Druckerpatronen tauschen und so, ich weiß,
es gibt Unternehmen, da müssen das auch die
Fisis machen, aber das ist ja schon irgendwie
verschenkte Mühe dann so, oder
verschenktes Potential,
es gibt, ja, es gibt tatsächlich
Leute, die gerne First Level Support machen.
Verstehen tu ich's auch nicht.
Ich check das auch nicht, warum das
jemand gerne macht. Ich hatte letztens
eine Schulung bei mir auf der Arbeit.
Da ging's so um
die neue, wie nennen wir das
mal hier, die
die neue Vision,
die unser IT-Chef
hat und was da alles noch
auf uns zukommt und sowas und
drumherum und da hatten sie uns zusammen
in eine Schulung gesteckt mit
die eine Hälfte
war IT-Leute, also nein, nein, nein, stimmt nicht.
Es waren alles IT-Leute, aber
die eine Hälfte kam so eher
aus der Admin-Richtung und die andere
Hälfte kam aus der Support-Richtung.
Und
da gab es welche,
die haben das richtig gerne gemacht,
Leuten zu helfen am Telefon in der Hotline.
Ich hab die auch mal
gefragt, ob es ihnen nicht teilweise richtig auf den
Keks geht. Und da haben
die auch zugeben müssen, ja, es gibt schon
Leute, die gehen mir richtig auf den Keks.
Es gibt, stimmt, du hast
Recht, du hast Recht, das ist eigentlich das Argument, was
man bei allem bringen kann. Es gibt
auch Leute, die C++ mögen.
Man kann sich nicht vorstellen, aber das gibt's
auch.
Am schlimmsten sind doch wahrscheinlich
die Leute, die keinen Plan
haben, aber denken, sie haben
übelsten Plan, oder?
Wir hatten ja auch schon im Stream Leute,
die das gerne machen.
Okay, gucken wir das Video jetzt. Also, die Kommentare
haben wir jetzt gelesen.
Fünf Jahre First Level.
Oh, Alter, da bin ich durchgedreht.
Aber wir sind halt alle nicht gleich gestrickt so im Kopf.
Gibt Leute, die mögen das, gibt Leute, die hassen das.
Also ich würde absolut Anfälle kriegen bei schon ein paar Tagen im First Level.
Ich würde mir dann einfach ein Steam Deck hinstellen.
Und immer, wenn mir einer auf den Sack geht, würde ich dann das hier abspielen.
Piss dich, Aldo!
Das Problem ist, dann hätte ich den Job wahrscheinlich nicht lang.
Oder alternativ auch...
Dann legen sie von selbst auf.
Nee, aber dann hätte ich den Job wahrscheinlich nicht lang.
Aber wie gesagt, das wäre auch nicht schlimm, weil ich würde den gar nicht machen wollen.
Also die einzige Person, für die ich noch gerne IT-Support mache, ist meine Mutter.
Ja, der helfe ich immer, wenn sie was auf dem Tablet hat oder irgendwelche anderen Dinger.
Da habe ich überhaupt keine Probleme mit.
Bei allen anderen Leuten, okay, den Mini-PC bei meinem Vater,
da habe ich jetzt, da musste ich jetzt schon drei oder vier Jahre nichts mehr dran machen,
was auch ganz gut ist.
Der hat Linux Mint von mir draufgehauen bekommen damals.
der hat so einen Mini-PC,
den er auf dem Schreibtisch stehen hat,
so ein bisschen von der Größe von einem Mac Mini,
aber ist ein ganz normaler
x86-PC, da habe ich den Jungs
mit drauf gemacht, mit Auto-Updates
und seitdem er das hat,
geht es einfach, es geht.
Seit 5 Jahren oder so, geht es einfach.
Also es ist nichts,
es geht einfach.
Ansonsten mache ich
für niemand mehr Support. Auch wenn mich irgendjemand fragt, sage ich immer, nee, davon habe ich
keine Ahnung. Früher war ich da immer zu, wie nennt man das,
mir zu fein zu sagen, obwohl es vielleicht auch gar nicht
stimmt, davon habe ich keine Ahnung. Aber mittlerweile sage ich bei allem, wo
ich keinen Bock drauf habe, was IT-Support angeht, nee, nee, da habe ich keine Ahnung von.
Selbst wenn es was ist, wovon ich Ahnung habe, sage ich, nee, habe ich keine Ahnung von.
Weil da habe ich keinen Bock drauf. Du hast die Leute
dann auch endlos an der Backe, wenn du denen
einmal geholfen hast.
Und am schlimmsten
sind die Leute, die dann ankommen,
so nach dem Motto, oh Hilfe,
was weiß ich, ah, mein Drucker geht nicht mehr.
Und
dann hilfst du denen, dass ihr Drucker wieder,
das ist jetzt nur ein doofes Beispiel, gebe ich zu,
ich glaube, das ist, was weiß ich, 30 Jahre her
oder so, wo ich letztes Mal einem bei einem Drucker geholfen habe.
Dann
hilfst du denen und letztendlich
lag es daran, dass
was weiß ich, du musstest einmal
Patronenreinigung machen oder so, keine Ahnung, ja.
So, und dann hast du
denen einmal geholfen und wenn das
nächste Mal der Drucker nicht mehr geht,
dann behaupten die, du hast
ihnen den Drucker kaputt gemacht.
Kennt ihr so Leute? So, Hilfe, mein Drucker
geht nicht mehr, ja, ich helfe dir. Und das nächste Mal
dann sagen, ja, du hast mir das letzte Mal auch
den Drucker kaputt gemacht.
Alter, so Leute, die
guck ich mir mal schnell an, ne.
Wie gesagt,
ich helfe keinem mehr. Ich helfe nur noch meiner Mutter
IT-Support mäßig, sonst helfe ich niemandem mehr.
So, aber jetzt gucken wir uns das Video an.
Weil, ich meine Chat, Chat, guck mal.
Das Video ist 32 Minuten lang.
Ich habe 26 Sekunden
von dem Video geguckt bisher
und 10 Minuten gelabert.
Wenn wir das jetzt mal extra polieren,
sitzen wir morgen früh noch da.
Meine Mutter nutzt kein Linux,
das liegt daran,
Wobei, kann man so nicht sagen.
Kann man so nicht sagen.
Meine Mutter hat Linux benutzt.
Schon vor Zeiten.
Da war das noch überhaupt nicht angesagt.
Die hat, äh, Warty Warthog benutzt.
Ubuntu.
Das war Ubuntu...
Hier, guck mal.
Ubuntu 20.04.
Äh, nicht 20.04.
WTF?
Äh...
Moment, Ubuntu...
Moment, was war das jetzt? Was war das für ein Ubuntu
2004?
Äh, welche Ubuntu-Version
ist das dann überhaupt?
4.10! 4.10!
Ja, 4...
4 Oktober, ja.
4.10. Die hat Ubuntu
4.10 damals benutzt. Die hatte
damals einen Linux
Desktop PC.
Den habe ich ihr
von alten Teilen auf der Arbeit
zusammengebaut.
Das war ein Pentium D.
Das war der erste, ich glaube
die erste Intel CPU mit zwei Kernen.
Pentium D.
Das Ding ist übelst laut und übelst heiß geworden.
Die hatte damals
schon Ubuntu Linux
mit beste
Mit Kompitz damals drauf.
Kompitz, Alter.
So geil.
Massive.
Oh, come on, YouTube.
Brage, Alter.
Geh jetzt mal.
Im Lambo erwischt.
Das habe ich sogar mitgekriegt.
Da haben sich Leute auf Reddit drüber lustig gemacht.
Das sind Fotos von ihm,
von Finanzfluss im Lamborghini.
Weiß nicht, warum die sich drüber aufregen.
Aufregen, ja?
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, hier.
Compets.
Wobbly Windows, Leute.
Also das wichtigste Feature von Compets
habe ich ja auch hier unter KDE wieder.
Wobbly Windows.
Ihr seht es, ja?
Also die Windows müssen wobbeln.
Genau.
Also das hatte ich damals meiner Mutter eingerichtet.
2004.
Ubuntu Desktop mit
ich glaube XFCE hatte die damals.
Xubuntu hatte die.
Xubuntu mit Compets.
Ja.
Und der feiert aber
seinen Würfel ordentlich.
No Front, aber schaffst du es bei der Arbeit auch nicht bei der Arbeit.
Oh ja, das habe ich da auch manchmal, dass ich sidetracked werde zu irgendwas.
Guck mal hier, wobbly Windows-Pässe.
Zumindest, die hat schon Ubuntu benutzt, bevor Linux-Desktop voll war, ja.
Bevor PewDiePie Videos gemacht hat zu Linux-Desktop.
Mittlerweile benutzt die kein Linux mehr, weil die benutzt nur noch Apple-Ipads
und iPhones.
Also sie benutzt nur noch ihr iPhone und ihr
iPad.
Sie hat keinen Desktop-Computer mehr.
Hätte sie noch einen Desktop-Computer,
dann würde sie auch Linux benutzen.
Das liegt
allein schon daran, weil ich kein Windows-Zeug
supporten würde.
So.
4.10, ja.
Ubuntu 4.10
das, das, meiner Meinung nach
war das die Peak-Ubuntu-Zeit
so damals rum
so diese 5, 6, 7 Jahre
so um diese
von diesem Release zu nach dem Release
und sowas
also
als die noch
quasi
nicht ihr komisches Unity-Desktop
hatten und noch
Kompitz. Das war das Beste.
Was wurde aus deinem Niri-Test?
Haben wir noch nicht beendet.
Ich habe in letzter Zeit so gut wie nicht gestreamt.
Außer sonntags zum Aufwachen hier.
Jetzt müssten wir eigentlich echt weitermachen.
Ich glaube, wir machen heute Mittag weiter Niri-Stells.
Fernseher stirbt aus.
So, jetzt müssen wir das Video aber weiter gucken.
Weil jetzt habe ich 26 Sekunden geguckt.
Und
noch
Viertelstunde gelabert.
Da sitzen wir morgen Mittag noch, wenn es in dem Tempo weitergeht.
Eins,
wer hat keinen Fachinformatiker?
Mach es bitte nicht in kleinen Unternehmen.
Macht es nicht. Der Arbeitsmarkt ist schwierig
und man muss dafür leben, um später gutes Geld zu verdienen.
Kannst du nichts, bekommst du nichts.
Mach das nicht. Wie gesagt, kannst du nichts,
bekommst du nichts, finde ich das prinzipiell immer gar nicht so verkehrt.
Ganz, ganz viele Kommentare, die
sagen, hey, so eine Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker,
bitte, bitte, bitte
mach das nicht.
Wie siehst du denn bei den ganzen Tabs noch durch? Gar nicht.
Und es gab dann den einen oder anderen Nutzer, der in den Kommentaren dann natürlich mal nachgefragt hat und meinte so, okay, macht es nicht, aber wieso eigentlich?
Und was ist der Grund, warum ich diese Ausbildung nicht machen soll?
Und das hat mich auch ein bisschen stutzig gemacht.
Warum sind die Kommentare in den YouTube-Beiträgen, in TikTok-Videos so negativ?
Wenn man dann aber beispielsweise auch auf Reddit geht, dann haben wir da dasselbe Spiel.
Da hast du super viele Posts, die habe ich jetzt hier ein bisschen umgeschrieben und anonymisiert,
wo es dann zum Beispiel heißt, hey, ich bin seit drei Monaten auf Jobsuche nach der Umschulung,
es gibt nur Absagen, geht es noch jemandem so?
Oder ich verdiene 1700 Euro netto als Anwendungsentwickler nach der Ausbildung.
Ist das normal? Klammer auf, nein, Klammer zu.
Oder hey, ich bekomme Mindestlohn nach der Ausbildung und Beschwerden über die Qualität,
jetzt nicht nur im Fachinformatiker-Subreddit, sondern auch im
Azubi-Subreddit generell. So, sorry, aber hätte ich
gemacht. Fachinformatiker-Subreddit, guck ich
nie rein. Wusste ich ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht, dass das existiert. Wusste,
dass ich das dritte Lehrjahr damit verbringe, aus KI-generierten
Dokumenten zu lernen, dann wäre ich einfach
in das selbe Studium gegangen. Oder hier
so sagen, hey, ich bin 43, frisch ausgelernt,
bewerbe mich aktiv, bekomme aber so gut wie keine Einladungen.
Was mache ich falsch?
Ja, der Job sagt gerade einfach hart.
Und generell diesem Stimmungsbild, das ist
ein bisschen besorgniserregend. Also habe ich mir mal die Frage
gesteckt. Was steckt da wirklich
dahinter? Woher kommt diese Stimmung?
Ich finde das übrigens cool mit dieser Präsentation,
die er hier, diese Endless-Scroll-
Präsentation. Das muss ich mir
merken. Das wäre für meine Sachen
auch nicht verkehrt.
Wisst ihr, was er
benutzt dafür?
Weil ich habe oftmals auch das Problem,
dass ich nicht weiß, was ich zeigen soll, wenn ich
eine Minute über irgendwas labere. Und da könntest
du so eine Präsentation machen, da kannst du ein bisschen rumscrollen
und so.
Was ist eigentlich gerade los im IT-Markt und in dem IT-Ausbildungsmarkt?
Und das alles möchte ich versuchen, mit diesem Video ein bisschen zu beantworten.
Wenn du also eine Ausbildung in der IT machen möchtest oder gerade in einer Ausbildung bist
oder kurz vor Abschluss bist und dich neu bewerben möchtest,
dann schau dir unbedingt dieses Video an.
Ich denke mal, dass es gerade so dieses Stimmungsbild ein bisschen stimmt,
aber es gehört natürlich immer ein bisschen mehr zum Kuchen als das, was man auf Reddit sieht.
Ja gut, Reddit.
Aber teilweise, vielleicht so ein bisschen in der Momentaufnahme.
Und da wollen wir jetzt mal ein bisschen tiefer reingehen.
Und ich habe folgenden Plan mitgebracht.
Ich erkläre dir mal ganz kurz, welche Daten ich für dieses Video rangezogen habe.
Dann schauen wir uns die offiziellen Zahlen für die Ausbildung an.
Wir schauen uns so ein bisschen an, hey, wo drückt denn der...
Wisst ihr, was ich witzig finde?
Dass immer noch rumgeheult wird wegen Fachkräftemangel.
Das passt halt so.
Ich habe schon immer gesagt, das ist kompletter Blödsinn.
Obsidian Canvas
Sekunde Leute, das muss ich wirklich mal kurz sidetracken lassen
nochmal kurz gucken, ob es das ist
weil das fände ich
Alter, wie mich dieses dumme
Ding hier abfuckt
Ist das das wirklich?
Ja
Da könnte ich auch einfach
Excalibur oder sowas
Könnte ich dafür auch benutzen
Wenn ich auch drinnen rumzoomen und machen und tun.
Das muss ich mir mal bookmarken.
Der Schuh jetzt eigentlich so wirklich.
Und warum es dort dieser Probleme vielleicht so einen sogenannten Fachkräftemangel geben kann.
Wir gehen da so ein bisschen drauf ein, um diesen Begriff auch mal ein bisschen einzuordnen.
Wir schauen uns mal so ein bisschen die Wirtschaftslage an, weil das ist auch ein großer Punkt, ohne dieses Video jetzt zu machen.
By the way, noch eines muss ich sagen.
Diese ganze Sache mit Fachkräftemangel, das war ja schon immer Blödsinn.
Die haben einfach nicht genug, also diese Statistiken zum Fachkräftemangel entstehen nicht dadurch, dass es wirklich zu wenig Leute gibt in diesem Beruf.
Das entsteht dadurch, dass es Jobs gibt, die nicht besetzt werden können.
Aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Also sprich, gibt es Stellen, die ausgeschrieben sind, wo sagen, die suchen irgendwie einen Lienungsadmin und finden keinen, dann ist das Fachkräftemangel. Warum die keinen finden, das hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Es gibt ja verschiedenste Möglichkeiten. Die bezahlen beschissen, der Laden ist beschissen, die Arbeit ist beschissen. Es kann ja zig Gründe haben, warum diese Stelle nicht besetzt werden kann. Aber trotzdem zählt das dann als Fachkräftemangel, weil Kackstellen nicht besetzt werden können.
... politisch werden lassen zu wollen.
Wir schauen uns an, was künstliche Intelligenz damit zu tun hat,
gehen dann nochmal auf die Reddit-Kommentare ein
und schauen uns aber vielleicht auch ein paar Gegenstimmen an,
die ein bisschen dagegen drücken.
Und dann sage ich dir am Ende des Videos nochmal konkret,
was das für dich bedeutet und was du dagegen tun kannst.
Lass uns mal kurz die nächste...
Ich kann mal sagen, was man dagegen tun kann.
Pfeifert sein und sich auskennen in dem, was man macht.
Ahnung haben hilft enorm.
Man glaubt es kaum.
45 Sekunden kurz nehmen, um zu schauen, worauf ich mich bei diesem Video stütze.
Also ich habe mir natürlich viele amtliche und primäre Datenquellen angeschaut,
wie zum Beispiel Daten vom Bundesinstitut für Berufsbildung.
Die haben super, super viele Daten, vor allem relevante und wichtige Daten,
rund um das Thema Ausbildung, Ausbildungsmarkt, Ausbildungsberufe.
Dann habe ich mir Daten von der Bundesagentur für Arbeit angeschaut.
Die schauen sich dann natürlich eher an, hey, wie viele Leute arbeiten gerade,
welche sind im Bestand, welche sind gerade arbeitslos.
Ja, das habe ich ja auch vorhin gesagt, Galaxy Force, dass es viele Umschulungen gegeben hat.
Und von vielen solchen Leuten waren halt wahrscheinlich auch die Kommentare,
so übelst langweilig, kein Bock.
Ja gut, wenn du jetzt den, nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel von mir aus der Berufsschule, den Steinmetz umschulst zu einem Fachinformatiker, dann ist das vielleicht nicht unbedingt der beste Job für ihn. Wobei ich da sagen muss, das muss ich jetzt nochmal sagen, es war eine wirklich sehr ehrenhafte Geste damals, dass sein Chef das gemacht hat.
Ich hatte in der Berufsschule einen, der war früher Steinmetz und hat jetzt Fachinformatiker gelernt. Warum? Der hatte einen Arbeitsunfall, dem ist irgendwie so eine große Steinplatte auf den Fuß gefallen und seitdem konnte er seinen ehemaligen Beruf nicht mehr richtig ausüben.
und daraufhin hat sein Chef gesagt, wo der Arbeitsunfall passiert ist, weißt du was,
ich hab da einen Freund, der hat eine Firma, die suchen Fachinformatiker
und da hat er den quasi dahin mit Vitamin B vermittelt,
dass er quasi was anderes lernen kann, wo er das quasi mit seinem kaputten Fuß noch machen kann.
Also es war wirklich, muss man sagen, ehrenhafte Geste, ja,
aber man hat schon ein bisschen gemerkt, dass es nicht so seins war.
wie sind so die Veränderungen und dann habe ich mir Daten vom Statistischen Bundesamt geholt, um zu schauen, was ist denn da eigentlich gerade unser Bruttoinlandsprodukt, wie viele Erwerbstätige haben wir und so weiter und so fort.
Dann gibt es noch viele Institute und Einrichtungen, die sich mit der Forschung beschäftigen.
Oh, Bitkom, wenn ich das schon lese.
Das heißt zum Beispiel das Institut für Arbeitsmarkt- und Berufsforschung, da hat sich gerade viel angeschaut, was KI macht.
Generell auch diese Forschungseinrichtungen habe ich mir für KI rangeholt, weil es da noch wenig konkrete amtliche Zahlen gibt.
Dann gibt es so ein paar, ich sage jetzt mal, Plattformen wie zum Beispiel StepStone, Indeed oder so, die natürlich so schauen, hey, was für Stellen haben die ausgeschrieben und so weiter.
Und so ein bisschen Stimmungsbild noch mal reinzuholen, aber so mit Vorsicht zu genießen, sind dann eben so Quellen aus Reddit und zum Beispiel so Verbände wie Bitkom oder so, die finde ich sehr, sehr biased sind.
Das zur Einordnung.
Jetzt magst du dir vielleicht auch die Frage stellen, okay, Noel, wer bist du eigentlich, dass du denkst, du kannst mir was darüber erzählen?
Und ja, fair point, deswegen mal kurz.
Wir haben sogar, by the way, wo wir gerade dabei sind, falls euch das Video vom Noel gefällt, vielleicht gefällt euch auch das Video, was wir zusammen gemacht haben, über die Fachinformatikerausbildung vor fünf Jahren.
Machst du heute noch Stellenanzeigen? Wir müssen die noch fertig machen, die alten, ja?
Das heißt, oh fuck, da hätten wir ja heute Stellenanzeigen und Niri.
Na, alles kann ich auch nicht machen.
Ich gucke jetzt aber erstmal fertig.
Zu mir noch. Hi, ich bin Noel.
Ich habe 2016 bis 2019 meine Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker für Anwendungsentwicklung gemacht,
die mit 95 von 100 Punkten absolviert.
Hatte ich auch. Ich hatte 95 Prozent in der mündlichen Prüfung.
Aber meine schriftliche Prüfung war schlechter.
Also keine Ahnung, was ich unterm Strich habe.
Er hat auf jeden Fall einen besseren Abschluss als ich.
Steckt nur Flex.
Ich bin seit 2024 selbstständig mit einer Lernplattform für IT-Azubis,
deswegen auch Hashtag Werbung.
Ach so.
Wenn du mehr darüber erfahren möchtest, dann schau gerne einmal in die Videobeschreibung.
Ich habe 2025 meine Ausbildung.
Ich denke, da ist auch zu einer Bank in Frankfurt mal gewechselt.
Ich bilde mir ein, da war auch Frankfurter Finanzbranche.
Lachschein gemacht und vor meiner Selbstständigkeit war ich als Freelancer tätig,
habe als IT-Berater gearbeitet und als Softwareentwickler.
Das so kurz zu mir und ich hoffe, das plus meine vergangenen Videos
befähigen mich so ein bisschen, das aus meiner Perspektive für dich einzuordnen.
Wir fangen mal mit der nackten Wahrheit an und das sind die neu abgeschlossenen Ausbildungsverträge
für den Ausbildungsberuf des Fachinformatikers von 2009 bis 2025.
Und da sieht man eigentlich ganz gut, dass über die letzten 10 bis 15 Jahre der Ausbildungsberuf des Fachinformatikers eigentlich eine Relevanz gewonnen und sehr im Wachstum.
Das stimmt schon. Was der Chat eben gesagt hat, da wurde halt wirklich jeder, ohne Abwerten zu meinen, jeder Depp, in Anführungszeichen, wurde umgeschult auf Fachinformatiker.
Auch Leute, die null damit zu tun haben, die du dann wirklich nur als Druckerpatronenwechsler benutzen kannst.
gestiegen ist. Wir sehen hier einen ganz klaren Wachstumstrend, aber wir haben 2023 das Hoch erreicht.
Mit 19.080 neu abgeschlossenen Fachinformatikernverträgen ging es seitdem nur noch bergab und zwar drastisch.
Von 2023 auf 2024 hatten wir eine Veränderung von minus 7 Prozent im Vergleich zum Vorjahr und von 2024 auf 2025 von 14,6 Prozent.
Und ich denke, das ist meine Hypothese, dass in 2026, das Jahr läuft ja noch gerade, dass es da recht ähnlich aussehen wird und wir da bestimmt auch nochmal fallende Zahlen für die Anzahl der Neuverträge haben werden.
Das sind jetzt erstmal die absoluten Zahlen. Das sind die Anzahl der Ausbildungsplätze. An sich gibt es gerade weniger als noch in 2023, aber wir sind ungefähr auf dem Niveau von 2020. Das heißt erstmal vielleicht noch gar nicht so schlimm, wenn man sich das im Big Picture...
Guck mal, meine Ausbildung ist doch nicht mehr auf dem Graph drauf.
Sag, dass du alt bist, ohne dass du alt bist.
Ne, wie, wie?
Sag, dass du alt bist, ohne mir zu sagen, dass du alt bist.
Meine Ausbildung ist doch nicht mehr auf dem Graph drauf, Alter.
Was jetzt aber durchaus relevant wird, ist, wenn man sich diese Zahlen mal im Vergleich zu anderen Kennzahlen anschaut.
Und da habe ich euch auch was vorbereitet.
Und zwar, wenn wir uns mal anschauen, das Angebot der Fachinformatikerausbildungen im Vergleich zur Nachfrage.
Und hier hat das Bundesinstitut für berufliche Bildung eine Kennziffer, die nennt sich die ENA, die erweiterte Nachfrage.
Wir haben entweder die Nachfrage, das zählt quasi die abgeschlossenen Verträge, plus unversorgte Bewerber ohne Alternative.
Und die erweiterte Nachfrage zählt zusätzlich auch Bewerber mit, die zwar eine Alternative haben, aber weiterhin einen Ausbildungsplatz suchen.
Also zum Beispiel, du hast jetzt keinen Ausbildungsplatz bekommen und dann machst du erstmal Schule weiter, obwohl du eigentlich diese Ausbildung machen möchtest. Und da sehen wir ganz klar, dass diese Diskrepanz zwischen Angebot und der Nachfrage immer weiter auseinander geht. Das heißt, wir sehen jetzt von 2010 bis 2010.
Max, wie viele Leute kennst du, die nicht im Banken- und Versicherungssektor arbeiten?
Äh, einige.
Also
Noch vom letzten Job
Vom vorletzten
Na gut
Von der Ausbildung
Von dem Ausbildungsbetrieb
Von dem danach
Was ja quasi auch mein Ausbildungsbetrieb war
Nur dann nicht mehr in der Ausbildung
Ich kenne auch ein paar
Ich kenne auch einige
und ich war letztens sogar erst wieder mit einem Mittagessen.
Korean Fried Chicken in Frankfurt haben wir gefuttert.
So mein Lieblingsladen mittlerweile zum Mittagessen,
wenn ich nicht in die Kantine gehe.
Das Einzige, was dem auf den Keks geht,
ist weniger die Lage,
wobei der auch schon zig,
was weiß ich, 15 Jahre Erfahrung oder so hat.
Das Einzige, was dem gerade auf den Sack geht,
ist, weniger
die aktuelle
Joblage, sondern sein
neuer Chef.
Also, der hat andere Probleme.
23. Das
Angebot steigt und die Nachfrage
steigt entsprechend auch, aber die Diskrepanz
ist noch nicht so groß.
Wenn wir uns jetzt 2025, das sind die
Zahlen, die ich habe, anschauen, dann sind wir
auf dem Niveau der
abgeschlossenen Verträge und des Angebots ungefähr auch 2020, aber mit einer viel, viel höheren Nachfrage, als was das Angebot hergeben kann.
Und das ist das Problem, was gerade existiert, wenn man eine Ausbildung haben möchte, womit alle konfrontiert werden.
Es gibt nämlich auch andere Ausbildungsberufe, da ist das nicht so.
Wenn wir uns zum Beispiel die Ausbildung als Kaufmann oder Kauffrau im Einzelhandel anschauen.
Ja gut, das will ja auch keiner machen.
Da gibt es die sogenannte erweiterte Angebots-Nachfrage-Relation, also das Verhältnis.
Und hier haben wir auf 100 erweiternde Nachfragen kommen rechnerisch rund 115 Angebote.
Beim Fachinformatiker sind es dagegen nur 74 Angebote.
Das heißt, wäre es ausgeglichen, dann hätten wir eine Relation von 100.
Ein Angebot entspricht der Nachfrage.
Beim Kaufmann-Kauffrau für Einzelhandel gibt es mehr Angebote, als die Leute nachfragen nach dem Ausbildungsberuf.
beim Fachinformatiker ist das genau umgekehrt und zwar ziemlich krass umgekehrt.
Man sieht also ganz gut, dass nicht der gesamte Ausbildungsmarkt gleich funktioniert.
In manchen Berufen gibt es rechnerisch mehr Angebot als Nachfrage und beim Fachinformatiker...
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es auch daran liegt, dass viele denken,
wird Fachinformatiker easy money, so easy Stelle, easy money.
Das muss ich erst mal rumsprechen, dass es vielleicht nicht unbedingt bei jedem der Fall ist.
Ja, genau umgekehrt. Das heißt, dass nicht jeder einzelne Reddit-Post oder TikTok-Kommentar repräsentativ ist.
Aber die Grundspannung ist durchaus da. Es gibt weniger Ausbildungsplätze.
Es wollen mehr Menschen eine Ausbildung in der IT machen, als es Ausbildungsplätze überhaupt gibt.
Aber das ist jetzt eine Seite der Medaille. Das war es noch nicht so ganz.
Denn es gibt nicht immer nur diesen einen Grund, auf den man etwas schieben kann, wenn etwas gerade nicht so läuft, wie man es vielleicht haben möchte.
Und vielleicht hast du es gerade mitbekommen, der deutschen Wirtschaft geht es nicht so gut.
Ich habe hier mal die Veränderungen und das Wachstum vom preisbereinigten Bruttoinlandsprodukt in Prozent.
Das bereinigte BIP-Wachstum in Prozent bedeutet, man misst, wie stark die Wirtschaftsleistung eines Landes im Vergleich zum Vorjahr gewachsen oder nicht.
Warum geht denn beim Minus noch der Pfeil nach oben?
Ach nee, das ist Minuswachstum. Minusprozentwachstum. Das heißt nicht, dass es kein Wachstum mehr gibt, sondern das Wachstum ist weniger als im Jahr davor.
Ah ja.
Geschrumpft ist, ohne dass reine Preissteigerungen durch Inflation das Ergebnis verzerren.
Und hier sehen wir ganz gut, in den letzten Jahren, seit 2023, haben wir negatives Wachstum, also wir schrumpfen, oder nur ganz, ganz geringes Wachstum jetzt 2025 von 0,2%.
Was ja quasi dann erstmal die Verluste wieder aufholen soll.
Wir hatten einen großen Dip in Corona, sind dann direkt uns wieder erholen gegangen und davor haben wir so zwischen 1 und 3% Wirtschaftswachstum gedümpelt.
was natürlich bei so einer großen Wirtschaft wie Deutschland natürlich aber auch viel ausmacht.
So, warum bringe ich das hier mit rein?
Das hat eine sehr große Kausalkette, die sich auf das Angebot der Ausbildungsplätze widerspiegelt.
Denn durch die Wirtschaftslage werden Betriebe vorsichtiger.
Jetzt ist die Frage, okay, Noel, warum werden die vorsichtiger?
Weil Ausbildung für Betriebe eine langfristige Investition ist.
Das bedeutet, Ausbildung lohnt sich vor allem dann, wenn Unternehmen glauben,
dass sie künftig wachsen, Aufträge haben und die Auszubildenden später übernehmen oder produktiv einsetzen können.
Das ist die Grundprämisse für die Ausbildung.
Ja, ein bisschen affig ist es ja teilweise. Also das leuchtet ja komplett ein.
Ein bisschen affig finde ich es dann immer nur so nach dem Motto, oh, wir brauchen Seniorleute, wir brauchen Leute mit Berufserfahrung.
Ja, wollt ihr neue Leute ausbilden? Nee, wollen wir nicht.
Wenn jetzt aber Aufträge, Umsätze oder Budgets unsicherer werden, vermeiden Unternehmen zusätzliche feste Kosten.
Und Neueinstellung und Ausbildung binden Geld, Betreuungskapazität und Zeit, bevor daraus Produktivität entsteht.
Denn ich muss ja erst mal die Stelle ausschreiben.
Da muss ich Interviews führen.
Da muss ich mich um den ganzen Papierkram kümmern.
Da muss ich mich um einen Ausbildungsplan kümmern.
Wenn der Azubi dann endlich da ist, muss sich fachkundige Mitarbeiter ihm zur Verfügung stellen.
machst weil du denkst ich kann damit gut kohle verdienen habe aber mit it und technik und juckt
mich überhaupt nicht dann ist es fragwürdig aber wenn ich das auch privat interessiert oder schon
immer interessiert hat dann ist das genau das richtige studium habe ich keine ahnung von damit
er eingelernt wird das heißt der mitarbeiter ist nicht in meinem betrieb verfügbar und der
azubi für den ich zwar jetzt kein hohes gehalt zahle aber dennoch ein gehalt ist auch erstmal
nicht produktiv und deswegen sind azubis und juniors am anfang eben sofort nicht wenn ich
Wenn es dich schon lange interessiert, dann mach das.
Fatsch, sind selten sofort produktiv.
Sie brauchen Anleitung durch erfahrene Mitarbeitende.
Und genau diese erfahrenen Mitarbeitenden sind in schwachen Phasen oft stärker.
Oder die machen das so wie in meinem Ausbildungsbetrieb.
So nach dem Motto, macht einfach mal.
Ausbildungsplan und Ausbilder haben wir nicht.
So war das.
Wir hatten dort, wie gesagt, 200 Mitarbeiter und davon 50 Azubis.
Ihr könnt euch vorstellen, es geht überhaupt nicht, dass man die alle ausbildet.
In meinem Ausbildungsbetrieb war das so,
ach Max, da müsste jetzt mal das und das gemacht werden,
guck mal, wie man das am besten macht.
So, das habe ich dann gemacht.
Und da habe ich enorm viel gelernt.
50 Azubis bei 200, ja.
Die wurden auch gerne quer durch Deutschland geschickt,
Server rumzufahren, weil es billiger war als mit einer Spedition.
Und die konnten auch damals gleich den Server anschließen.
sowas.
Tja,
so war das. 200 Leute,
50 Azubis.
Die konntest du gar nicht richtig ausbilden.
Wie viele haben die Prüfung bestanden?
Also ich hab nur von
einem gehört,
der während der Ausbildung noch
den Betrieb verlassen hat.
Der war aber auch irgendwie
ein bisschen neben der Spur.
Von dem Rest, glaube ich,
haben das alle geschafft.
Ich hab das nicht so viel mitbekommen davon
Weil ich war ja in Frankfurt, die anderen waren ja woanders
In Deutschland
Wir waren, aber wir waren auch in Frankfurt
Man darf sich das nicht überleben
Ich glaub wir waren in Frankfurt
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung
7, 8 Leute
7 Leute oder so
Und davon 3 Azubis
Du musst
Also im Prinzip war das so
Du hast entweder
alles gelernt, was du wissen musstest,
so selbstständig und
konntest dabei halt rumprobieren. Du hast halt
quasi Try and Error
gemacht, bis du es gelernt hattest
und ab und zu hat
dir mal vielleicht auch einer geholfen
oder aber du hast einfach nur
rumgegammelt und nichts gemacht die drei Jahre.
Ging beides, hat keinen
interessiert. Also die Ausbildung
war nahezu nicht existent in dem Sinn.
Die haben
uns dann irgendwann, das jetzt muss ich
überlegen allein schon da hätte ich eigentlich wissen können dass es ein
kackladen ist die haben uns drei azubis damals in ein eigenes büro
zusammengesteckt und wisst ihr auch warum wisst ihr warum dass wir nicht zu
viel ressourcen abziehen von den leuten die tatsächlich was arbeiten müssen
muss man sich mal vorstellen muss man sich mal vorstellen die haben uns ein
eigenes Büro verfrachtet.
Das war ein richtiger Scheißladen eigentlich.
Das habe ich damals nicht so richtig realisiert.
So ein richtiger Kackladen.
Aber es hat tatsächlich was gebracht.
Wir haben uns
alle drei sehr für Technik-Kram
interessiert und wir konnten halt
einfach alles machen, was wir wollten.
So nach dem Motto, ah, da muss
was gemacht werden in der und der Richtung.
Ja, ich gucke mir das an. Und da konntest du drei Wochen
dran rumbasteln. Ich hatte
damals als Azubi in der zweiten Woche
Hutzugriff auf alle produktive Systeme.
Ich hab auch
aus Versehen Sachen, ich hab erstaunlich
wenig aus Versehen kaputt gemacht, ja.
Aber ich hab auch aus Versehen schon Sachen damals
kaputt gemacht.
Hat dann auch keinen so richtig interessiert, solange es
nicht groß durchgeschlagen ist, ja.
Und eine Sache, wo ich heute noch sauer
bin, wo ich heute noch sauer bin,
ist,
ähm,
Die haben uns damals in den Rechenzentrum geschickt und haben gesagt, an diesen und diesen Ports Kabel abmachen.
Das sind die Kabel von alten ESX-Servern und die ESX-Server kommen raus, Verkabelung entfernen.
So, man muss wissen, unser Kabel...
Kabelschrank oder so sah ungefähr...
Ja, so.
Nur noch voller.
Noch voller.
Aber so ungefähr sah der Kabelschrank aus.
Also noch voller.
Also, der Schrank hatte eine...
Dass ihr euch vorstellen könnt, wie voll das war.
Der Schrank hatte eine Tür.
Die Tür hat sich aber keiner mehr getraut zuzumachen,
weil es das alles zu sehr gequetscht hätte innen drin.
Ja, also...
Es sah schon abenteuerlich aus.
So, und da haben die uns damals gesagt,
da und da Kabel raus.
Haben wir gemacht.
Wir haben exakt an den Stellen Zeug entfernt,
wo es zu entfernen galt, ja, und auf einmal kam einer rüber ins Rechenzentrum gerannt und meinte, ESX-Server sind ausgefallen oder ESX-Server haben Probleme.
Er sagt ja, wie, du hast uns doch genau diese Dinger gesagt, hier was ist, ja.
So, und dann kam halt irgendwie raus, dieser Schrank war halt so voll und so alt und so kaputt schon, dass anscheinend manche Kabel Wackelkontakte hatten.
Ich meine, ist ja klar, stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt einen Kabelschrank, der so aussieht wie der hier.
Stellt euch vor, ihr habt hier so einen Kabelsalat, ja, und dann habt ihr eine Tür vorne dran und die Tür quetscht die Kabel.
Also da kann schon Wackelkontakt sein.
So, und anstatt es jetzt zuzugeben, sie haben es einfach verkackt, ja, mit dem Kabelmanagement.
mit dem, ja, wie man das Ganze behandelt hat, haben die gesagt, wir hatten den Ausfall, weil die Azubis das falsche Kabel gezogen haben.
Wir haben nicht das falsche Kabel gezogen, wir haben exakt die Kabel rausgezogen, die verlangt wurden rauszuziehen.
Und das Ding war halt kaputt und gab Wackelkontakt.
Ich hab dann auch an allen Stellen erzählt
Es stimmt überhaupt nicht
Ich glaub es geht los
Ja
Naja zumindest
So war meine Ausbildung
Ich hab enorm viel gelernt in der Ausbildung
Aber auch im Prinzip nur weil ich es lernen musste
Weil es keinen Ausbildungsplan in dem Sinn gab
aber seit der Ausbildung kenne ich mich gut mit Linux aus.
Also ich wette, ich hätte in einer normalen Ausbildung, wo es wirklich einen Plan gibt,
Leute, die einem was zeigen und so, ich glaube, ich hätte unterm Strich nicht so viel gelernt,
weil ich lerne immer noch die Sachen am besten, wenn ich selbst ein Problem vor mir habe
und kann einfach zwei Wochen am Stück daran rumbasteln und probieren, wie ich will.
Ja, manchmal ist es nicht verkehrt, wenn du einen hast, der am Ende weiß, wie es aussehen soll
oder dir mal was sagen kann.
Aber ich glaube, für mich war das die beste Ausbildung, die ich haben könnte.
Es war eine scheiß Ausbildung, weil es keine Ausbildung gab.
Aber unterm Strich habe ich da am meisten gelernt.
Deswegen habe ich ja auch heute noch
ein Herz für Nagios.
Also Nagios ist eine...
Ups.
Nagios ist eine Monitoring-Software.
so, so sieht das aus
so sieht Nagios aus
genau so
ich hab noch ein Herz für Nagios, weil
das war in meiner Ausbildung
eines der größten Dinger
die ich, die ich gemacht hab, ich hab
komplett selbst
unser Monitor, also muss man sich mal
vorstellen, ne, der Azubi
der Azubi baut das Server Monitoring
System auf
ich musste alles selber machen
äh, also
nicht nur Nagios zu installieren, war easy,
ja, mir eine
Logik für die Config ausdenken,
also sprich, wie gruppiert
man das? Nagios kann
Config so vererben, du kannst
quasi einen Linux-Server machen und da
drunter einen Web-Server und da drunter
einen Frontend-Web-Server und so was
in der Richtung, ja, also ich musste mir
ein eigenes Schema für die
Config ausdenken, für alle Server
Configs anlegen, ich musste
für Red Hat,
Suse, also nein, für CentOS
Suse und Debian
die Nagios
Agents kompilieren, weil für Suse
gab's die nicht.
Da musste ich selbst NRPE und
Geschiss kompilieren, dass es
funktioniert hat. Ich hab da enorm viel gelernt.
Deswegen hab ich immer noch so ein bisschen
ein großes Herz für Nagios. Auch wenn
ich jetzt keinen neuen Nagios
mehr installieren möchte, geschweige denn
betreiben will, aber ich mag
Nagios aus genau dem Grund.
So, Hardcore Sidetracked, wir gucken weiter.
Kostendruck oder internen Umstellungen beschäftigt.
Wenn ein Unternehmen also sich nicht sicher ist, ob es in ein bis drei Jahren, weil die Ausbildung dauert ja in der Regel drei Jahre, genug Arbeit, Budget oder Übernahmemöglichkeiten hat, bildet es eher weniger aus oder stellt weniger Juniors ein.
Und kurz gesagt bedeutet das also, bei schwacher Wirtschaft sinkt die...
Ich sag mal, hat trotzdem immer noch ein bisschen kurz gedacht, wenn man dann Seniors haben möchte, aber nicht ausbildet.
... in Menschen zu investieren, die erst später produktiv werden. Und genau in so einer Phase befinden wir uns seit Jahren, was uns eben das Schaubild vom Bruttoinlandsprodukt ist und dessen Wachstum oder eher negativen Wachstum aufzeigt.
Jetzt ist es aber so, dass es halt nicht automatisch heißt, hey, das BIP ist runtergegangen,
deshalb gibt es genau 4.800 weniger Fachinformatikerverträge.
So sauber kann man das jetzt nicht kausal beweisen, aber es ist eben, ich sage es mal, ein starker Kontext, in dem das stattfindet.
Und das betrifft eben besonders Einsteiger. Da gibt es gleich noch eine spannende Kennzahl, die da auch vielleicht noch...
Aber ich muss sagen, also da sind die, wo ich jetzt arbeite, sind tatsächlich etwas weitsichtiger.
Die haben immer noch duale Studenten, Azubis, die auch übernommen werden. Bei uns ist das mittlerweile sogar so, das finde ich richtig gut, Azubis bei uns haben eine garantierte Übernahme für ein Dreivierteljahr.
Also selbst wenn die fertig sind mit ihrer Ausbildung und keines der Teams sagt, sie wollen den Azubi haben, also normalerweise läuft das so, du bist bei uns Azubi, gehst dann mal durch mehrere Teams durch, du findest was, was dir gefällt, du findest was, was dir gefällt und du dich mit den Leuten gut verstehst und die Leute sagen dann auch, ah ja, wir könnten noch einen gebrauchen und den Azubi hätten wir gerne nach der Ausbildung oder am besten auch schon das letzte Jahr der Ausbildung, ja.
dann landet er dort in dem Team, kann sich da nochmal komplett einarbeiten, wenn er mit der Ausbildung fertig ist, fängt er in dem Team an.
So, das ist der normale Vorgang.
Sollte es aber jetzt der Fall sein, dass es ein Azubi gibt, der aus welchen Gründen auch immer kein Team findet,
was ihn haben will oder er nichts findet, wo er hin will,
dann wird er garantiert trotzdem noch ein Dreivierteljahr oder ich glaube sogar, könnte sogar ein ganzes Jahr sein,
übernommen und sitzt im Zweifelsfall nur ein Dreivierteljahr rum.
Ist aber trotzdem angestellt, kriegt Gehalt, sodass er immer sagen kann, er hat ein Jahr Berufserfahrung. Das muss man auch erstmal Hut ab. Keine schlechte Regelung. Also bei uns werden Azubis nie arbeitslos nach der Ausbildung direkt.
Was machst du mit Azubis, die unfähig sind, aber die Ausbildung gerade so geschafft haben?
Naja, wenn es kein Team gibt, was die haben will, dann bleiben die ein Jahr bei uns und können sich in der Zeit was Neues suchen.
Die müssen ja dann auch nichts machen, die chillen dann halt den ganzen Tag.
Es gibt so eine extra
Organisationseinheit,
worunter die dann aufgehängt sind.
Organisatorisch.
Finde ich aber eine gute Sache.
Und bei uns werden tatsächlich aktuell
mindestens von denen ich weiß,
drei Junior-Positionen gesucht.
Einer davon ist bei uns im Team als Storage-Admin.
Anderen weiß ich jetzt aus dem Kopf nicht.
Und
da wird immer noch was gesucht.
ja wenn auch nicht mehr so viel wie wir noch vor ein paar jahren
also die denken tatsächlich ein bisschen an die zukunft
was macht man als storage haben ist gute frage ich bin kein storage hat man kümmert sich um
storage systeme man kümmert sich um irgendwelche storage zonierung sahen lüden geschichten man
Man kümmert sich um Syncs von einem rechten Zentrum ins andere.
Man kümmert sich um Berechtigungen auf NFS-Storages.
Man kümmert sich um irgendwelche Backup-Geschichten.
Irgendwie sowas.
Ich krieg von unseren Storage-Leuten auch nur auf der großen Team-Runde was mit.
Ansonsten keine Ahnung, was die so den ganzen Tag treiben.
Aber sowas in der Richtung, was ich gerade gesagt hab wahrscheinlich.
Ob die Festplatten selbst wechseln, bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher.
Was wir für Storage-Systeme haben?
Das ist eine gute Frage
Ich war die drei Jahre, seit ich da bin, einmal im Rechenzentrum
Ich glaube Dell
Ich glaube es gibt mehrere
HP, Dell und Hitachi, glaube ich, haben wir
Vielleicht auch IBM, Dell, HP und Hitachi?
Ach, keine Ahnung
Hitachi
Ja, gibt es tatsächlich Storage-Systeme?
Ob die Dinger so aussehen?
Keine Ahnung
Ich hab das noch nie gesehen
Wie gesagt, Dell, HP, IBM und Hitachi, glaube ich.
Warum sagt man eigentlich nicht mehr Serverraum?
Das sage ich doch auch noch öfters genug.
Ey, keine Ahnung, vielleicht auch.
Haben wir bestimmt auch.
aber das ist nicht in dem bereich wo ich jetzt groß aktiv keine ahnung was sie da ganzen tag machen
so guck mal weiter wichtig ist hat jetzt zu sagen dass der punkt nicht ist hey es gibt
keinen bedarf mehr an it so ist es eher so in einer schwachen wirtschaft werden betriebe
selektiver darin wenn sie neu aufbauen das ist mir ganz wichtig mit diesem video in diesem
Kanal. Nuance. Mal so ein bisschen
links und rechts zu gucken.
Die IT ist nicht tot. Das möchte ich euch
jetzt zeigen. Und genauer gesagt wollen wir uns anschauen,
was bedeutet das jetzt für den IT-Arbeitsmarkt.
Und wie gesagt,
von diesem ganzen Fachkräftemangel-Gelaber
habe ich am Anfang schon gesagt, darf man sich nicht
beirren lassen,
weil da geht es
um Stellen, die offen geblieben
sind. Egal aus welchen Gründen.
Also egal wie beschissen
die Stelle ist und deswegen nichts finden,
ist es trotzdem Fachkräftemangel.
Deswegen ist auch der Witz, das passt zusammen.
Ja, Leute finden, also es wird auf der einen Seite immer noch Fachkräftemangel gelabert, auf der anderen Seite finden die Leute nichts.
Das liegt daran, weil dieser ganze Fachkräftemangel kompletter Bullshit ist mit, ja, es gibt hier eine Stelle, Kackbetrieb, Kackbezahlung, Kackarbeit, ho, Fachkräftemangel, es findet sich keiner, der das machen will.
Ja, wer hätte das gedacht?
Markt aktuell.
Denn an sich gibt es Bedarf für IT-Fachkräfte halt einfach mehr für Ausgelernte.
Und da müssen wir uns auch anschauen, hey, was bedeutet eigentlich IT überhaupt?
Weil die IT ist ein breiter, breiter Feld. Ein breites Feld.
IT an sich ist kein Arbeitsmarkt.
Zum Beispiel das Bundesinstitut für berufliche Bildung schaut auf Ausbildungsberufe, zum Beispiel den Fachinformatiker.
Die Bundesagentur für Arbeit schaut aber zum Beispiel auf Berufsgruppen, sogenannte IKT-Berufe.
Stellenportale wiederum zeigen dann so ein bisschen auf konkrete ausgeschriebene Jobs,
aber nicht den gesamten Markt.
Und Reddit zeigt Erfahrungen und Stimmung, aber keine repräsentative Statistik.
Wenn wir über IT reden, müssen wir uns fragen, okay, welche IT ist gemeint?
Schauen wir uns die Ausbildung an, schauen wir uns Softwareentwicklung an,
Support, Systemintegration, Data, Cloud, Security.
Super, super viel.
Falls jemand das Video noch mal in Ruhe gucken will, ich poste es mal in den Chat.
breites Spektrum, was wir da abbilden.
Und die Bundesagentur für Arbeit hat so eine grobe Kategorisierung,
die man nochmal subkategorisieren kann.
Das sind die IKT-Berufe, die Informations- und Kommunikationstechnologie.
Und da habe ich mal Zahlen von 2024 mitgebracht,
die sich halt anschaut und sagt,
hey, im Vergleich zu 2023 ist der Beschäftigungsbestand
an sozialversicherungspflichtigen IKT-Fachkräften gestiegen um 4%.
Wir haben jetzt also gut 1,12 Millionen sozialversicherungspflichtige IKT-Fachkräfte.
Okay, aber der Stellenzugang ist um 23% zurückgegangen von 2024 im Vergleich zu 2023.
Heißt das also ITK, IT und Telekom? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Informations- und Kommunikationstechnologie heißt das.
Ja.
plus es sind 30% mehr Arbeitslose mit einem IKT-Zielberuf.
Also Leute, die sagen, hey, ich möchte in der Informations- und Kommunikationstechnologie arbeiten,
finde aber gerade nichts.
Oder die sagen, ich kassiere lieber Bürgergeld, weil sich das nicht lohnt sonst.
Und ist das nicht so ein bisschen ein Paradox, ein Widerspruch?
Wie kann es sein, dass der Beschäftigungsbestand steigt,
gleichzeitig aber weniger Stellen und mehr Arbeitslose existieren.
Was ist da los?
Ich bin jetzt natürlich kein Experte in der Arbeitsmarktforschung.
Ich bin kein Wirtschaftsweise, wobei das ist vielleicht auch gar nicht so schlimm,
was meine Kompetenz betrifft.
Ich versuche einfach, zahlendlich Recherchierer einzuordnen und so gut wie es geht zu erklären.
So, mehr Beschäftigte heißt, der gesamte Bestand an Menschen, die in IKT-Berufen arbeiten,
ist 2024 größer als 2023.
Mehr Arbeitslose heißt, gleichzeitig suchen mehr Menschen mit IKT-Zielberuf eine neue Stelle. Beides kann gleichzeitig passieren, wenn der Markt insgesamt groß bleibt oder weiter wächst, aber die Aufnahme neuer Leute schwächer wird. Denn viele IKT-Beschäftigte behalten ihren Job, dadurch bleibt der Bestand hoch oder wächst weiter. Gleichzeitig werden weniger neue Stellen gemeldet.
Wenn wir uns die Veränderungen anschauen.
Ich sehe das ja auch bei mir gerade auf der Arbeit. Es werden insgesamt weniger Leute eingestellt, aber bei uns wird überall erzählt, wir müssen effektiver werden und wir haben ja Arbeit mit den gleichen Leuten zu erledigen und so.
Jaja, das passt schon.
Neue Stellen entstehen, kommen Menschen, die neu einsteigen, wechseln wollen oder arbeitslos werden, schwerer wieder rein.
Es heißt ja nicht, dass nur weil weniger Stellen ausgeschrieben sind, gar keine Stellen mehr ausgeschrieben sind.
Es sind weniger Stellen ausgeschrieben.
Das heißt, wenn Leute wechseln wollen oder arbeitslos werden oder neu einsteigen, kommen sie schwerer wieder rein.
Zusätzlich aber wächst das Angebot an IT-Nachwuchs.
Wir haben mehr Informatikstudierende, mehr IKT-Ausbildungsinteressierte, mehr Umschüler und mehr Quereinsteiger.
Das heißt, wenn wir uns die Zahlen anschauen, dann sehen wir, dass in den letzten drei Jahren die Zahl zwar gesunken ist,
wir aber im Vergleich zu 2010 immer noch ein langfristiges Wachstum von 73% haben.
Das heißt, wir haben mehr Ausbildungsnachwuchs, auch wenn wir jetzt in den letzten drei Jahren,
2023, 2024, 2025 oder eben in diesen zwei Jahren einen Dip haben.
Muss man irgendwie in Aktiensprache auszudrücken.
Dadurch kann die Beschäftigung erstmal Hebel insgesamt steigen,
während die Konkurrenz am Einstieg und bei der Jobsuche Hebel auf Visis, Visiausbildung,
härter wird. Das heißt sozusagen,
der Raum ist größer,
aber die Tür, die ist enger geworden.
Vor allem, wenn wir uns noch mal anschauen.
Das trifft
eigentlich ganz gut, ja.
Ja, okay.
Der Raum ist größer, aber die Tür ist enger.
Schmaler.
Was jetzt bei den
Informatikstudenten der Fall ist.
Man sieht, die Zahl der Studierenden insgesamt,
die steigt, das ist jetzt auf
Informatik bezogen. Wir sehen jetzt,
im Vergleich zu den Studierenden steigt die
Zahl der Absolventinnen und Absolventen
nicht so krass. Aber was wir halt hier sehen,
wir haben zwar ein kleines Wachstum,
aber wir haben ein Wachstum seit 2014.
Wir haben nicht wie bei den Fachinformatikern,
dass es jetzt da auch weniger gibt. Das heißt,
auch hier seit 2014 haben wir
ein Wachstum von
Informatikabsolventen. Bei
Fachinformatikern Azubis theoretisch auch,
auch wenn sie jetzt die letzten zwei Jahre
gesunken sind. Aber das heißt ja gleichzeitig
auch für Azubis, die gerade
ihre Ausbildung fertig machen, dass sie jetzt
mehr und mehr mit Informatikstudenten konkurrieren, noch mehr als davor.
Das große, große Risiko ist aber...
Wobei ich sagen muss, wir hatten letztens einen Student, wo ich mir auch wieder gedacht habe,
okay, was ist da los?
Der meinte, ich habe gesagt, der wollte ein bisschen was gezeigt, ein bisschen was gezeigt kriegen,
was Kubernetes, Linux und sonst was angeht, also was wir da eigentlich machen.
und da habe ich
Kommandozeile aufgemacht und sonst wie
und hab dann gesagt, okay, du kannst jetzt ja auch mal was
machen, da meine ich die Kommandozeile
das, damit kommt dann nicht
klar
ja gut
wenn man Linux machen will, beziehungsweise was mit
Linux machen will und gar nicht Kommandozeile
das wird nix
das klappt nicht
Ohne Juniors fehlen später Seniors.
Und da gehe ich am Ende des Videos nochmal drauf ein, um mal auch eine Ansage an die Betriebe zu machen.
Was wir jetzt aber gelernt haben, ist ja eigentlich, okay, die Informatik, die IT oder Informations- und Kommunikationstechnologie...
Was bedeutet, kommt nicht mit der Konsole klar.
Ich übersetze das mal. Er mag die Konsole nicht. So würde ich das übersetzen.
Er bevorzugt es nicht, etwas, wenn es möglich ist, nicht mit der Konsole zu machen.
Und er wollte dann auch nicht.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass der die vorgeschädigte Windows, also die Windows vorgeschädigt ist.
Ja, weil das Windows Terminal und die Windows Shell halt jahrzehntelang absolut Bullshit, unterehrlicher Schrott war.
Er wollte auch nicht.
Die ist nicht tot. Und zumindest noch nicht, mag jetzt der ein oder andere sagen.
Denn was ist eigentlich mit künstlicher Intelligenz?
Da sagen doch alle, dass die uns ersetzen wird.
Deswegen habe ich mir angeschaut, ob Cloud Code jetzt alle Jobs klauen wird.
KI wird sicherlich einige Bullshit-Shops, die jetzt schon irgendwie nichts Eigenes im Hirn leisten müssen, ersetzen, ja, aber ich bin ja da mal, das habe ich schon oft gesagt, so der große Untergang, der da prophezeit wird, den sehe ich nicht.
Ich sehe, dass sich einige Berufe erweitern werden, ja, und dass es in Zukunft vielleicht auch Berufe geben wird, die es vorher nicht gab, so eine Art Vibe-Code-Experte, der dann quasi aufräumt, das was Claude produziert, aber dass es insgesamt so viel weniger wird,
auf lange Sicht
glaube ich das nicht
es gibt viele Sachen, die sehen erstmal so aus
so nach dem Motto, okay
ich habe 5 Entwickler, aber ich kann ja auch
einfach einen Prompt in die
KI reinhauen, da kriege ich dann irgendwas
was so aussieht, als würde es funktionieren
das mag aus Managersicht
vielleicht erstmal so aussehen, wie
ich brauche demnächst nur noch einen von
5 Entwicklern
ob das auf lange Sicht so
maintainbar ist,
habe ich so meine Zweifel.
Also ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass ein Manager,
der Vibe-Coded
eine Software rausbringen kann,
maintainen kann, erweitern kann,
auf langfristige Sicht.
Das sehe ich nicht.
Ja, dran vorbei kommst du nicht.
Wir benutzen im Stream ja auch mittlerweile regelmäßig KI.
Und sei es nur für Sachen wie, ich weiß, wie man das in Go macht,
sagt mir mal, wie man das in Rust macht oder sowas in der Richtung.
Ja, haben wir schon oft genug so Dinge.
Oder hast du noch eine Idee, wie man dieses eklige C++
in vielleicht nicht ganz so ekliges C++ umschreiben kann?
Für sowas ist das super.
Oder hast du eine Idee, wie man da und damit das machen kann? Ja, habe ich, könnte man so. Dann halluziniert sich vielleicht mal ein paar Funktionsaufrufe dabei, die es gar nicht gibt. Gerade für Inspiration holen und Idee ist das ganz toll. Gibt es nichts zu sagen.
und es ist mittlerweile auch enorm
beeindruckend,
wie weit man mit kostenloser
KI mittlerweile kommt, ich meine damit nicht unbedingt
zwangsläufig selbst gehostet,
ja, aber zum Beispiel
oh, what the fuck was ist hier
mit meinem OpenCode, hat
immer jede Menge kostenlose Models,
unter anderem gibt es da
sogar mittlerweile China-Chinesen
Models, die gar nicht so übel sind,
da gibt es
GLM 5.1 zum Beispiel,
kostenlos bei OpenCode, also da kommt man auch schon ganz gut weit mit,
wenn man kein Geld für Cloud Code oder Kodex oder irgendwie sowas oder Cursor
oder was auch immer ausgeben will, kann man schon einiges machen mit.
Und dass man das als Unterstützung für die Arbeit benutzt,
ich mache das zum Beispiel, eines meiner Lieblingssachen,
was ich gerne mache, ich schalte GPT auf, was ich KI frage ist so,
wie schedule ich
einen Ad-Job unter Linux
im 24-Stand-Format?
So. Kann ich mir nicht merken.
Fragst du KI, bam.
Und er sagt dir da einfach,
okay, das ist schon mal Blödsinn, was er hier zeigt,
aber du sagst,
Echo, hallo Welt,
gepiped nach Ad, 23.30 Uhr.
So. Für sowas ist KI
das Beste. Das ist besser als
Google,
besser als Stack Overflow, besser als Reddit, solche Dinger, dafür ist KI perfekt.
Was auch immer sich hier sonst noch so dazu halluziniert.
Achso, ne stimmt doch, stimmt doch.
Der macht das interaktiv, was du, was du da reinschreiben soll.
Ja, du kannst natürlich auch pipen.
Ja, für sowas, für sowas ist das super.
Ja.
und damit bist du natürlich auch deutlich effektiver
das heißt ich sehe es auch so
Leute die sich da komplett KI Sachen verweigern
werden einfach nicht so mehr am Puls der Zeit sein können
geht einfach nicht
oder auch sagen wir so qualitativ
nicht vielleicht unbedingt immer das liefern können
was möglich ist
oder vielleicht auch schlicht und ergreifend
einfach nicht so viel auf die Reihe kriegen
Hast du ein Cloud- oder Chat-GPT-Abo?
Nee, tatsächlich nicht.
Ich bin Open-Code-Fan.
Ich benutze Open-Code.
Und die kostenlosen Models davon.
Also was ich nicht mache, muss ich dazu sagen,
ich mache kein
agentic
Vibe-Coding mit
15 Agenten, die da im Hintergrund
laufen und Tokens verbraten.
Das mache ich nicht. Ich weiß, es gibt einige, die machen das.
Die schreiben dann
5 Seiten prompt.
Und lassen Cloud Code oder Codex oder was auch immer dann zwei Tage rödeln und bezahlen dann ein paar hundert Euro. Kann man machen, mache ich nicht.
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
Oder nicht. Und man muss sagen, die Forschungslage ist nicht so krass, was künstliche Intelligenz angeht im Betrieb.
Okay, Chat, ich muss jetzt noch tatsächlich nochmal unterbrechen, das ist interessant hier.
Warte mal, Chat.
Magst du noch eine Frage? Ich lese oft, ich soll zu meiner Physiausbildung am besten zu Hause noch ein Homelab machen.
Das sehe ich auch so.
Du musst kein Homelab machen in Form von, du zwingst dann alle Leute bei dir daheim inklusive dir nur noch deine Services zu verwenden.
Aber sich selbst damit zu beschäftigen ist, glaube ich, das Wichtigste, was es gibt.
Also, wenn ich Leute miteinander vergleiche, Leute, die so krasse Kellerkinder sind wie ich, die quasi privat vorm Computer sitzen und basteln, vorm Job vorm Computer sitzen und basteln und nachts davon träumen, vorm Computer zu sitzen und zu basteln, die sind unterm Strich deutlich besser in ihrem Job als Leute, die es rein als Job sehen.
Das ist einfach so.
Ich sage nicht, dass man das nicht machen kann,
aber die Leute, die ich kenne, von denen ich wirklich behaupten würde,
die haben richtig Plan.
Das sind alles Leute, die interessieren sich einfach brennend für Technik
und beschäftigen sich auch privat sehr viel mit Technik.
Das ist einfach so.
Und ich glaube, dass das in mehr oder weniger allen Berufen so ist.
Die Leute, die wirklich gut in ihrem Bereich sind,
sind Leute, die sich schon immer auch privat dafür interessiert haben.
Oftmals schon bevor sie diesen Job ausgeübt haben.
Hat natürlich auch den Vorteil, umso besser kennst du dich aus,
umso höher sind die Chancen, tatsächlich dann im Job auch das machen zu können,
was dich interessiert und was dich wieder noch besser macht.
Ja, aber sich daheim mit beschäftigen ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll.
Du musst jetzt hier nicht alles, was du benutzt, ablösen durch irgendwelche Self-Hosted-Geschichten,
Schichten, das muss nicht sein, aber was zum Beispiel durchaus sinnvoll ist, ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, hol dir ein Raspberry Pi, ja, und bastel ein bisschen mit Linux rum, bastel vielleicht ein bisschen auch mit Sensoren daran rum, so ein bisschen sich mit Elektronik und ein bisschen low-level-ligerem Zeug auszukennen ist zwar nicht erforderlich für die meisten Berufe, bringt aber viel Insight, wie man so schön nennt, ja, wie das unter der Haube funktioniert.
heutzutage ist vielleicht besser raspberry pi es ist ja aktuell ein sehr
teures hobby geworden vielleicht ist auch ein günstiger x86 mini pc ganz
sinnvoll da installiert den linux drauf du guckst wie du beispielsweise mit
ensemel da drauf die installation konnte die nicht die installation die
konfiguration automatisieren kannst du installiert den paar vms drauf lässt
darauf docker container laufen du kannst dir auch bei hetzner oder bei
irgendeinem anderen Cloud-Anbieter
ein paar Systeme mieten und
da mal irgendwie was mit einem selbst installierten
Kubernetes-Cluster ausprobieren.
Gibt's tausend Sachen, die du machen kannst
und alles bringt dir was.
Du musst ja auch
erstmal rausfinden, wenn du eine Ausbildung in dem Bereich
machen willst, du musst ja auch erstmal
rausfinden, was das
ist, was dich am meisten interessiert.
Es interessiert sich ja nicht unbedingt
jeder für alles. Ich interessiere mich auch nicht für alles.
Wobei man sagen muss, ich interessiere mich und
Das sieht man auch an den Stream-Inhalten.
Ich interessiere mich schon für viele Sachen.
Ich meine, wir haben ja schon alles hier mal irgendwie gemacht.
Von Elektronik gebastelt, Microcontroller, Linux, Kubernetes, Softwareentwickler.
Wir haben hier schon alles irgendwie hier mal durch.
Also wir haben die meisten Gebiete schon mal gestreift im Stream.
Es gibt halt ein paar Dinge, da kannst du mich jagen mit.
Du hast hier noch nie guten Rust-Code gesehen.
Ja gut, das ist möglich.
es gibt Sachen, da kannst du mich jagen mit
zum Beispiel Windows Server
haben wir aber auch schon im Stream gemacht
letztendlich dient es aber hauptsächlich dazu, sich ein bisschen lustig
über Windows Server zu machen
aber sogar das haben wir schon gemacht
du musst ja erstmal rauskriegen, was dir gefällt
und wenn du was gefunden hast, was dir gefällt
dann wirst du ganz automatisch
da drinnen weiter
basteln wollen
ja, Homelab ist auch
übertrieben, du brauchst jetzt ja kein
eigenes Rack daheim mit
zig Dingern drin. Kauft dir ein Raspberry Pi,
bastelt damit ein bisschen rum,
hängt vielleicht mal einen Temperatursensor dran,
guckt, wie du das ausgelesen
bekommst. Da hast du das
mit dem Raspberry Pi deutlich einfacher als
beispielsweise mit dem ESP32.
Und da lernst du auch automatisch
noch ein bisschen mit, wie man
Linux-Systeme per Command-Line
verwaltet, wie du dich da per SSH drauf
einloggst, wie du dich auf der Kommando-Zeile
bewegst. Und das aller allerbeste
ist, wenn du
im Linux-Bereich
dein Know-How verbessern willst,
das aller allerbeste ist,
gar nicht mal Homelab, das aller allerbeste
ist, verwende
Linux für deine tägliche Arbeit.
Ich meine damit nicht, dass du
dein Windows löschen sollst und darauf Linux installieren
solltest. Ich meine damit auch nicht zwangsläufig,
dass du Dual-Boot machen solltest.
Es gibt zwei Sachen, die ich sinnvoll finde.
Also ja, wer Dual-Boot machen will,
kann meinetwegen auch Dual-Boot machen, ja.
Aber es gibt zwei Sachen, die ich sinnvoll finde. Erstens, installiere dir Linux in der VM. Installiere dir VM in der Workstation, der Kram kostet mittlerweile nichts. Installiere dir Linux in Linux deiner Wahl, installiere dir das in VM in der Workstation und benutze das als tägliche Arbeitsumgebung.
Weil damit wirst du standardmäßig so viel Kram mitlernen, weil du dich damit beschäftigen musst.
Du wirst die Navigation auf der Kommandozeile lernen, weil du halt was machen musst.
Ach ne, Moment, ich starte XNiri, muss ich ja hier machen.
Du wirst so viel Zeug lernen, weil du nicht drumherum kommst.
Das ist sinnvoll.
Also Linux als Daily Driver zu verwenden im Endeffekt.
Oder wenn du sagst, ich will sogar noch ein bisschen mehr machen.
Ich will zum Beispiel auch ein KI-Model drauf laufen lassen können,
so ein bisschen ausprobieren oder auch Sachen spielen unter Linux.
Dann wäre es sinnvoll, kauf dir ein Linux-Mini-PC.
Kauft ihr einen Mini-PC?
Zum Beispiel
Kauft ihr, also ich hab hier einen
Das ist aber nicht mehr aktuell, da gibt es mittlerweile schon neuere
Ich hab hier so ein Ding zum Beispiel
Bei mir stehen
Mit 8 Ggramm, also das ist auch der
Mini-PC auf dem ich hier gerade bin
Ja
Ähm, hier das Ding
8 Ggramm
Ähm
8 CPU-Kerne.
Ich hab...
Hä?
Ich hab ne SSD drinne.
Zwei SSDs hab ich drinne.
Mit jeweils nem
Terabyte, glaub ich.
Und damit kannst du alles
machen.
Damit kannst du alles machen,
unter Linux, was du machen willst, mit so nem Mini-PC.
und am besten ist, du lässt das erstmal unabhängig von deiner normalen Windows-Arbeitsumgebung,
das heißt, wenn du mal was kaputt gemacht hast und was spielen willst und so,
dass das einfach funktioniert, musst du dich nicht stressen,
hol dir einen Linux-Mini-PC oder installiere deinen Linux auf einer VM
und benutze das als tägliches Arbeitssystem.
Du wirst so viel lernen damit, was dir auch später im Job,
wenn du Linux-mäßig was machst, was die Basis ist für das, was du später im Job machst.
benutzt Linux als Daily
Arbeitssystem
dann lernst du enorm viel mit
und wenn du rausgefunden hast, was dir Spaß macht
dann kannst du dich ja immer noch in dem Bereich
in die Tiefe gehen
wie nennt man das?
T-Shaped heißt es doch
heutzutage, oder?
also du kennst dich
breit aus
Ja, aber bei manchem auch in der Tiefe.
So, weiter gucken.
KI-Stells.
Ja, ich bin kein großer Fan.
Nelly, ich bin kein großer Fan von Dualboot.
Ich finde den zweiten PC oder VM deutlich angenehmer.
Aber was ich jetzt hier schon mal eine Kennzahl gefunden habe, ist, dass jetzt in 2025 mittlerweile jeder vierte Betrieb irgendwie generative KI in der einen oder anderen Form eingesetzt hat.
Ja, das wundert mich nicht.
Wir waren es bei 2023 natürlich erstmal nur bei 5% lag. Gut, was war da? GPT-4 in den Anfangsphasen? Keine Ahnung.
Machen wir auf der Arbeit auch. Ich weiß, es hört sich übelst an, als will ich schleimen, dass ich mehr Geld kriege bei der nächsten Gehaltsverhandlung.
Aber letztendlich guckt das ja keiner. Parsec habe ich ausprobiert. Ja, Parsec. Habe ich mit dem Fabian zusammen mal BDO drüber gespielt über Parsec. Leider kann man Parsec nicht unter Linux hosten. Nur Linux Clients gibt es. Das wollte ich jetzt sagen.
Ich finde es eigentlich ganz gut, wie die das bei mir auf der Arbeit gemacht haben. Die waren ziemlich schnell auf diesem Trend mit dabei, was KI angeht. Aber die haben halt auch gesagt, die Leute copy-pasten da so viel unternehmensinterne. Meine Mutter KI benutzt? Ne, ne, ne. Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Also nicht, dass ich wüsste.
und denen war halt auch klar, die Leute
pasten da so viel unternehmensinterne Sachen in die KI, die wollen das
eigentlich nicht, so deswegen haben die sich quasi so einen Chat-GPT-Fork
von Microsoft gekauft, also man kann sich bei Azure ein privates
Chat-GPT quasi mieten, was haben die gemacht
und das haben die dann auch
trainiert mit interner Knowledgebase
internem Ticketsystem, internem
Wiki. Das heißt, bei uns kannst du
unser internes Chat-GPT kannst du fragen,
ey, sag mal, es gab da doch
ein Ticket zu dem und dem Thema vor
drei Jahren. Hast du eine Idee?
Ganz ehrlich, das funktioniert mehr
schlecht als recht, aber vom Ansatz her finde ich
es gut. Und du kannst natürlich auch die
üblichen Geschichten fragen. Ey, wo ist denn hier die
Syntaxfehler in meinem Jammel-File?
Das einzig
doofe, was ich
finde, ist, die ruhen sich ein bisschen
zu sehr darauf aus,
Vielleicht bietet Microsoft auch nicht mehr an, das kann sein, das weiß ich nicht, weil wir haben jetzt erst vor ein paar Monaten GPT-5 bekommen. GPT-5, die sind bei GPT-5-4 mittlerweile schon und das merkst du. Also den Unterschied zwischen unserer KI und anderen aktuellen KI-Modellen, das merkst du schon den Unterschied.
Also die sind ein bisschen langsam
Aber immerhin, sie sind von Anfang an dabei
Und haben sich Gedanken zugemacht
Das ist ja auch schon mal was
Du hast schon ein
Quattro Boot probiert, WTF
Windows 10, Windows 11
Ubuntu plus Arch, aber warum?
Warum Quattro?
Also ich bin ja schon kein Fan von Dual Boot
Aber Quattro Boot
Was kommt als nächstes? Octaboot, oder?
Weitergucken, sonst werde ich nicht fertig.
So, das heißt, die Daten geben jetzt nicht her,
die ich gefunden habe, KI ist der Grund,
warum Fachinformatikerverträge zurückgehen,
aber die Daten geben her,
dass KI in Betrieben angekommen ist
und Anforderungen verändert an Arbeit
und eben besonders in IT.
Anforderungen verändern das auf jeden Fall.
Ich sehe das ja selber schon bei mir,
wenn ich jetzt eine Werkstudentenstelle ausgeschrieben habe.
Ich schaue, ob jemand schon mal Cloud Code bedient hat
oder Cursor bedient hat oder Codex.
Und ich schaue mir auch an, wie hast du das gemacht?
Das würde ich auch machen.
Wie hast du das zur Problemlösung genutzt?
Wie hast du damit vielleicht auch gelernt?
Wie hast du das genutzt, um zu challengen?
Das ist wichtig.
Das heißt aber auch, KI wird eingeführt,
Aber der strukturierte Kompetenzaufbau läuft noch nicht überall mit.
Also noch nicht jede...
Der strukturierte... Jetzt kommen aber hier die krassen Business-Dinger hier.
Der strukturierte Kompetenzaufbau.
Unternehmen, nicht jede Firma, hat irgendwie schon Schulungen...
Ich würde sagen, das ist eindeutig der Key zum Success.
... oder einen Lehrplan, um dir diese KI-Kompetenzen beizubringen.
Und Schule, Berufsschule erst recht nicht.
Für Anfänger ist das jetzt relevant, weil sie in einen Markt kommen,
in dem Tools bereits genutzt werden, aber Betriebe nicht unbedingt die Kapazität haben,
Grundlagen und KI-Kompetenz sauber aufzubauen.
Das DIW kommt für Softwareentwicklung auf ein sehr hohes Transformationspotenzial.
Ja gut.
Das heißt, ungefähr 83,7% der Tätigkeiten bzw. Kompetenzen gelten als...
Wie haben es denn das bestimmt? 83,7%? Das klingt so hyperwissenschaftlich.
Kann man das wirklich sagen? Also, dass es da ein Transformationspotenzial gibt in der Softwareentwicklung, das sehe ich auch so. Ich glaube, da wäre man auch blind, wenn man sagt, nee, das ist auf gar keinen Fall so.
als durch KI transformierbar.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass 83,7 Prozent der Jobs verschwinden.
Das stimmt.
Das heißt, ein großer Teil der Aufgaben kann sich durch KI verändern.
Code schreiben, Code erklären, Debugging, Dokumentation,
Tests, Recherche oder technische Kommunikation.
Und genau das verändert sich gerade auch bei den einen Firmen schneller,
bei den anderen Firmen langsamer.
Gerade typische Anfängeraufgaben können dadurch aber unter Druck geraten,
Weil einfache Routineaufgaben teilweise schneller mit KI erledigt werden können. Und das ist eben das große, große, große Problem.
Also, ich muss jetzt mal an der Stelle eine Sache sagen, wo man auch mal negativen Seiten des Vibe-Codings sieht. Und zwar, bei uns ist es so, für Änderungen an Server gibt es Change-Tickets.
So, ich glaube, das ist jetzt nichts Besonderes. Das gibt es bei den meisten, außer bei den ganz kleinen Klitschen, wo einfach nur gebastelt wird. Also Change-Tickets gibt es wahrscheinlich bei den meisten. Ja, das kennt ihr wahrscheinlich auch in unterschiedlicher Art und Weise, wie ausführlich das ist.
so und es ist so
die eigentlichen Changes werden dann auf unterschiedlichste
Art und Weise durchgeführt, ja das kann ein Terraform
Lauf sein, das kann ein Ansible Lauf sein, das kann ein
Skriptlauf sein, das kann sein
ich logge mich drauf ein, gebe drei Befehle ein
und da gibt
wie das passiert, gibt es ganz verschiedene
paar Fälle
jetzt hat
bei mir aus dem Team einer
ein Skript, ein Python Skript
geweibcoded, das
dem gibst du
eine URL
zu einem Ansible-Lauf
über Ansible-AW,
nee, AAP heißt das ja mittlerweile,
nicht mehr AWX und nicht mehr Tower.
AAP,
den gibst du einen Link zu einem Ansible-Lauf
und dem gibst du einen Link zu
einem GitHub-Merge-Request
zum Beispiel, oder
den gibst du einen Link zu einem Terraform-Pipeline-Lauf,
dann
zieht der sich, dann zieht dieses
Python-Skript die ganzen
Sachen ab,
also die ganzen Logs von dem jeweiligen Lauf, zieht das ab, konvertiert das in ein PDF, also mit Syntax-Highlighting und sowas,
weil die meisten Sachen sind ja ein bisschen schlecht lesbar, also hast du dann quasi den Div aus dem Merge-Request,
hast dann die zugehörigen Pipeline-Lauf und das daraus generiert, dass ein langes PDF, wo man halt auch das Syntax-Highlighting erhalten bleibt
und das PDF kann man dann an sein Change-Ticket hochladen als, guck hier, Change wurde umgesetzt, so und so, dass es passiert.
An sich eine richtig gute Idee, jetzt kommen wir aber mal zu den Schattenseiten von Vibe-Coding.
Ich habe dann gesagt, sag mal, können wir das nicht so bauen über die API von unserem Ticketsystem,
dass du gleich sogar das Ticket noch mit angeben kannst, dass es das darüber hochlädt
und da war die Antwort, boah, keine Ahnung, das ist Python, ich kann kein Python schreiben,
noch nicht mal richtig lesen und keine Ahnung, wie ich das jetzt einbauen soll.
Das sind dann halt auch so ein bisschen die Schattenseiten von Vibe-Coding,
wenn du dann halt was erstellst, von dem du nichts verstehst.
An sich ist das eine super Idee, ja, dieses Skript und das hilft auch viel.
Ich sage gar nicht, dass es schlecht ist.
Chat, bevor ihr jetzt zu viel flamed, schlecht ist das nicht. Das wäre nämlich was, was es vorher einfach nicht gegeben hätte. Schlecht ist das nicht. Aber du siehst halt die Schattenseiten so ein bisschen von Vibe-Coding.
das heißt nicht automatisch nur weil du was da
Vibe Coding erstellt hast, dass das jetzt
langfristig
relevant bleibt und gut gemaintained werden
kann oder weiterentwickelt werden kann
an sich ist es nicht schlecht
weil jemand der kein Python schreiben kann
der hätte sowas nie erstellt sonst
an sich ist das eine gute Sache
aber man sieht halt auch
so alles kannst du damit auch nicht ersetzen
Ach ja, ich habe mir dann übrigens die API angeguckt und mit einem passenden Curl kann man Anhänge hochladen an unser Ticketsystem. Ist gar nicht so kompliziert.
kompliziert. Das eigentliche Problem
ist jetzt, ich hätte auch gesagt,
ich baue das da ein, das einzige Problem
ist jetzt, dass wir von dem Server, wo die Leute das
laufen lassen, gar nicht an die API von unserem Ticketsystem
kommen. Aber ich werde tricksen,
werde ich aber nicht an die große
Glocke hängen, ich werde tricksen und zwar,
ich komme von
meinem Windows-Rechner natürlich an das
Ticketsystem dran. Von meiner
Linux-Admin-Kiste komme ich
nicht an das Ticketsystem dran.
Was ich jetzt allerdings machen kann
ist. Ich kann ein
SSH-Tunnel bauen
von meinem Windows-System auf meine
Linux-Kiste.
Und ihr wisst ja, sobald man SSH-Tunnel machen
kann, kann man so gut wie alles andere machen.
Dann leite ich nämlich einfach
über den SSH-Tunnel
Requests von dort an das Ticketsystem weiter
und dann kann ich demnächst auch
automatisch Anhänge an Tickets erzeugen
von meiner Kommandozeile aus.
Das werde ich aber nicht so an die
große Glocke hängen, weil ich mir nicht so ganz sicher bin,
ob das so gewollt ist.
Okay, Luku schreibt, bei uns hat einer mit KI-only ein Service gebaut, wo Dateien vom USB-Stick nimmt,
diese mit unterschiedlichen Antiviren-Software-Scans, also quasi ein bisschen sowas wie Virus-Total für den USB-Stick,
diese mit unterschiedlichen Antiviren-Software-Scans und freigibt oder halt blockiert.
Der hat auch null Plan vom Code und das Geile ist, die IT-Sieger gibt sowas einfach frei, wird nicht geprüft.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, weil die es auch nicht verstehen.
Wenn ich T-Mux haben will,
muss das durch tausend Instanzen durch.
Tja.
Das ist auch wieder sowas, wo man sagt,
die Idee ist ja gut, ne?
Die Idee ist ja gut.
Und für so einen Prototyp ist das bestimmt
auch nicht verkehrt, das komplett zu Vibe-Coden.
Aber trotzdem, so einen
Vibe-Coding-Aufräumer- und Versteher-
Position brauchst du dann trotzdem noch.
Also wenn du es ruhig ein gewisses Einsetzen willst.
Oh, ich hab einen dicken Mückenstich am Arsch.
Das juckt.
Der muss durch die Fahrradhose gestochen haben.
Unangenehm, ja, richtig unangenehm.
Also einfach so was, das keiner versteht, dann geht es durch.
Das ist so.
Ja, das ist wirklich so.
Also, klingt jetzt erstmal widersprüchlich,
aber ich war jahrelang beim alten Arbeitgeber,
auf unserem Cap. Wisst ihr, was
ein Cap ist? Ich meine damit nicht das Taxi.
Chatkill, wer weiß,
was ein Cap ist?
So tun, als wüsste ich
was über ITIL-Begriffe.
Was ist ein Cap?
Nicht
Capper. C-A-P.
Change Management.
Ja, fast, fast, fast.
Das ist das Change Advisory Board,
Leute. Achso, Moment, der Alfred hat es ja schon geschrieben.
Genau, ja, richtig.
da werden anstehende changes besprochen mit den mehr oder weniger leuten die es betreffen könnte
change advisory board so und ich war jahrelang bei meinem alten arbeitgeber immer wöchentlich
auf unserem cap als quasi abgesandter so der linux ecke so moment ich muss mal ganz kurz
Ein bisschen gedudelt im Hintergrund, machen Sie mir zu ruhig.
Und was man da gesehen hat, ist Changes, wo es um einfache Sachen ging.
So, sagen wir mal, wie soll der Server heißen?
Oder auf welchem Port soll das laufen?
Oder, keine Ahnung, wie soll...
Gutes Beispiel, da habe ich sogar direkt eins im Kopf.
Wie soll das Datum in einer Log-Datei stehen?
Soll es quasi Ami-Datumsformat sein oder deutsches Datumsformat?
Über solche Dinger, die versteht jeder, da kann jeder mitreden.
Da kann auf so einem Meeting eine halbe Stunde drüber diskutiert werden mit noch fünf Folgenterminen.
Das ist gar kein Problem.
Ja, überhaupt kein Ding.
Wenn ich aber einen super komplexen Change habe, so ich deaktiviere jetzt auf unseren Eingangsloadbalancern bestimmte Hash-Algorithmen für TLS, bla bla bla, da sagt keiner was zu.
Weil es keine Sau versteht. Es werden komplizierte Changes, die potenziell einen riesen Impact haben, einfach durchgewunken und einfache Changes, wie in welcher Richtung soll das Datum geschrieben werden, werden wochenlang diskutiert. Das ist so.
Wenn es kompliziert ist, sag keine Sau was, es wird durchgewunken.
Es ist einfach, diskutiert God und die Welt mit.
Das ist wirklich so.
Ja, ja, ist so. Ist genau so.
So, Video fertig gucken.
Weil dann eben der Bedarf für Juniors sinkt und zum Beispiel für Azubis, für Werkstudenten oder für ausgelernte Einsteiger.
Gleichzeitig ist es aber auch ein bisschen paradoxerweise so, dass KI-Anfänger auch produktiver machen kann, wenn sie sie gut einsetzen können.
Ich habe doch mal vor ein paar Jahren gesagt, der wichtigste Skill eines Fachinformatikers oder jedes Mitarbeiters in der IT ist es, dass er gut googeln kann. Das gilt heute immer noch, aber ein weiterer Skill ist, der mittlerweile genauso wichtig ist, wie gut googeln können, KIs zu fragen.
Ja, wie ordentlich KI benutzen bei Problemen.
Das ist ein Skill, wie ich kann ordentlich googeln.
Ich kann mir ordentlich durch KI helfen lassen.
Das ist ein Skill, den müssen alle Leute lernen, wenn sie was ordentlich auf die Reihe kriegen wollen.
Früher war es, du guckst bei Google, du bekommst Ergebnisse von Stack Overflow und Reddit.
Und gut war, heute haust du halt auch nochmal ChatGPT oder irgendeine interne KI oder Cloud Code oder eines der anderen tausend Sachen an.
Das musst du heute auch lernen. Und du musst heute auch lernen, wie man eine KI am besten was fragt oder welche Stichworte ich vielleicht noch dazu schmeißen sollte, dass eine gute Antwort da ist. Da kriegt man dann auch so ein bisschen Bauchgefühl mit der Zeit für. Und es ist nicht damit getan, dass du schreibst, think extra hard, make no mistakes.
...wander Skills zu lernen, hey, wie setze ich KI ein?
Der Unterschied wird also größer zwischen Leuten, die KI macht mit Code quasi nur nutzen
und Leuten, die Anforderungen verstehen, Ergebnisse prüfen, Fehler finden und Verantwortung übernehmen.
Und das eben mit KI.
Ich habe mir da noch eine Forschung vom Bundesinstitut für berufliche Bildung angeschaut.
Wie soll ich denn mit KI Verantwortung übernehmen, hä?
Und die zeigt halt, hey, Forschungslage zu KI und beruflicher Bildung ist noch...
BIP-Quali-K.
BIP Quali-Key.
Sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr jung.
Und das sind die drei Quellen, die ich hier...
Hört sich ein bisschen an wie eine Hose fürs Fahrradfahren.
BIP Quali-Key.
Einmal rausgesucht habe, das Institut für Arbeitsmarkt- und Berufsforschung
hat sich angeschaut, okay, wie stark generative KI in deutschen Betrieben benutzt wird.
Das Deutsche Institut für Wirtschaftsforschung hat analysiert,
welche Tätigkeiten und Kompetenzen...
Doch Lars, ich finde schon, also jeder wie er lernen will, aber ich finde in einem Punkt bringt KI schon was.
Wenn du was fabriziert hast, ja zum Beispiel, wenn ich irgendwas ekliges in C++ programmiert habe für ein ESP32,
das schmeiße ich in Brocken tatsächlich mal ganz gerne nach KI hin und frage, kann man das noch hübscher machen?
Meistens ist das, was rauskommt in C++ auch nicht hübscher, aber es gibt manchmal nur so neue Denkanstöße, wie man es noch machen könnte.
also so als zusätzliche Idee
finde ich das immer gut, jetzt rein
als ich habe keine Ahnung davon
erklär mir das mal
finde ich das
auch nicht unbedingt immer so
doll
ja also nach dem Motto
ich würde gerne Rust lernen, bring mir Rust bei
das ist vielleicht nicht das Sinnigste
über eine KI
Aber zum Beispiel, ich habe diese Funktion hier in Rust programmiert, kann man das noch effektiver machen oder kann man das mehr idiomatic Rust-mäßig machen? Das macht natürlich dann Sinn. Muss aber jeder selbst rauskriegen. Es hat jeder so ein bisschen die eigenen Vorlieben, wenn er neue Sachen lernt.
Ja.
Das ist alles so ein bisschen mit Vorsicht zu genießen, gerade was die berufliche Bildung angeht.
Also, das heißt aus meiner Sicht ist KI nicht der bewiesene Grund für unbedingt weniger fachinformatische Verträge.
Vielleicht für weniger, ich sage jetzt mal, Tendenz in die Richtung.
Gerade, denke ich, hängt es mehr mit der Wirtschaftslage zusammen.
Das denke ich auch.
Aber das geht genau gerade durch die Köpfe der Ausbilder.
Warum sollte ich einen Azubi einstellen, wenn diese Aufgaben nicht auch KI machen kann?
Und deswegen gilt es für dich dann zu schauen, hey, KI ist in Betrieben angekommen und verändert, was als produktiver Einstieg gilt.
Wie kann ich das für mich nutzen, dass die Leute mich trotzdem einstellen wollen?
Weil ich glaube, dass mit KI eher mehr Bedarf an Softwareentwicklern entsteht, weil man dadurch mehr machen kann.
Und jetzt ist die Frage, gibt es denn noch Hoffnung?
Gibt es Hoffnung für Azubis, für Einsteiger, für Quereinsteiger, Umschüler, für alle, die in die IT wollen?
Und ich sage, ja, es gibt Hoffnung.
Das sage ich auch.
Also pass auf.
Was Reddit und TikTok also richtig fühlt und was Reddit und TikTok verzerrt. Ganz wichtig aus meiner Sicht, die IT ist nicht tot, auch nicht durch KI. Aber dieser naive, einfache Einstieg in die IT ist schwieriger geworden. Du kannst nicht einfach nur einen Abschluss machen und dir wird ein Job hinterhergeschmissen. Das wird nicht mehr passieren oder wird nicht passieren in den nächsten Jahren. Wer heute also einsteigt...
Ja gut, muss ich sagen, wie gesagt, die letzten Jahre, wo du Gott und die Welt auf Physi umgeschult hast, auch die damit überhaupt keine Schnittpunkte haben, das sah vielleicht auf dem Papier gut aus, wirklich gescheit funktioniert das ja auch schon nicht.
Muss klar zeigen, warum er oder sie produktiv werden kann. Du möchtest quasi dem Arbeitgeber Risiko nehmen. Du möchtest sagen, hey, wenn du mich einstellst, bin ich schnell für dich produktiv und kann Mehrwert für dein Unternehmen bieten. Sei es als Azubi.
Im Prinzip willst du dem erzählen, was er hören will. Du willst dem erzählen, was er hören will, dass du ordentlich Kohle bekommst am Ende.
Das ist halt ein bisschen schwieriger zu kommunizieren. Ihr seid Azubis, aber es ist halt leider gerade kein Bewerbermarkt.
Und was ich aber auch zeigen möchte, es gibt sie noch, die Gegenstimmen. In dem Subreddit Azubis fragen Ausbilder, was kann ich tun, um meine Ausbildungen zu halten.
Wir sind zwei Azubis.
Das ist eh so ein Ding.
Also eine Sache habe ich mittlerweile gelernt.
Hat auch ein bisschen gedauert, ja.
Gerade in der IT hat man ja oftmals ein etwas, wie soll ich sagen,
negative Sicht auf die Dinge.
Wisst ihr, was ich meine?
Also man sieht halt viel, was falsch läuft.
So nach dem Motto, da wird immer noch zu langsam gepatcht.
Da wird Uralt-Software eingesetzt.
Die sind immer noch auf Java 1.8 und so.
Also du hast da einen relativ negativen Sicht drauf.
Da gibt es immer noch keine Backups, die kennen sich immer noch mit ihrer Software nicht aus, die programmieren immer noch unperformanten Shit und sowas. Ihr kennt das wahrscheinlich. Aber wenn ich eins gelernt habe, ist, wenn man es wirklich darauf anlegt, wenn man der Hardcore-Karriere-Grinder sein will, was ich ja eindeutig nicht bin.
Wenn man der Hardcore-Karriere-Grinder sein will, dann ist es deutlich besser, man erzählt, was die Leute hören wollen, als das, was wirklich die nackte Wahrheit ist.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn euer Chef sagt, stellt euch vor, ihr seid bei Microsoft.
Stellt euch vor, ihr seid bei Microsoft und euer CEO schreibt eine Mail,
KI first, das ist jetzt übrigens mal nicht ausgedacht, das war ja wirklich so,
KI first und eigentlich kann sich jeder fast verpissen, der keinen Bock auf KI hat.
So sinngemäß gab es ja ein paar Mails bei Microsoft.
So, wie machst du da besser Karriere bei Microsoft? Wenn du sagst, oh, krasse Vision, Alter, KI First, warte mal, ich muss husten, so, oh, KI First, Alter, ich wipecode jetzt das Startmenü neu in JavaScript und React und verkaufe es als die beste Änderung in Windows-Seitgeschnittenbrot.
oder du sagst, Leute, vielleicht sollten wir mal ein bisschen vorsichtig mit unserem
Vibe-Code sein. Wir haben mittlerweile 70% mehr Bugs,
70% mehr unzufriedene Leute. Vielleicht sollten wir ein bisschen mehr auf Qualität
als schnell mit der heißen, genadelgestrickten
Vibe-Coded Features setzen. Was meint ihr denn, mit welcher
Einstellung ihr einfacher Karriere macht bei Microsoft dann?
Ich bin aber eindeutig mit der ersten.
Wenn ihr eurem Chef das erzählt, was er hören will, seid ihr auf lange Sicht erfolgreicher. Ob es jetzt technisch das Sinnvollste ist oder nicht. Ich handhabe es mittlerweile so, weil ich habe da keinen Bock drauf.
also ich hab keinen Bock drauf
alles als toll zu verkaufen, was ich scheiße finde
aber ich bin ja auch nicht der Hardcore-Karriere-Crinder
in dem Sinn, ja
aber ich mach's mittlerweile so
wenn ich irgendwas blöd finde
dann sag ich, was ich da dran blöd finde
und wenn die dann der Meinung sind
das muss trotzdem so sein
dann sag ich mir, gut
ihr bezahlt den Kram am Ende
mehr als sagen, kann ich's euch nicht
machen wir das halt so
Ich hab paar Tabs offen.
Moment, ich hab nicht nur da Tabs offen, ich hab da Tabs offen.
Und pass mal auf, ich hab noch ein paar Tabs offen.
Ja, so mach ich das mittlerweile.
Also es gibt genug Dinger, wo ich sag, ey, ob das so eine gute Idee ist.
Und dann sind sie der Meinung, doch, doch, das ist ganz toll.
Ah ja, dann machen wir das halt so.
Zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel.
Ähm, wir haben einen Service.
der ist als gar nicht mal so wichtig klassifiziert.
Aber die Leute, die für die Anwendung zuständig sind,
die halten diesen Service so ziemlich für das Wichtigste, das es gibt.
Diese Diskrepanz kennt ja vielleicht auch der ein oder andere.
Also das Service selbst ist so, was Verfügbarkeit angeht,
alles wird als überhaupt nicht so wichtig eingestuft,
aber die Leute sind der Meinung super wichtig.
So.
Da ging es jetzt drum, wir müssen,
oder wir wollen, oder wir sollen, besser gesagt,
Wir sollen dafür sorgen, dass in Zukunft Betriebssystem-Updates automatisch installiert werden.
Was auch Reboots beinhalten kann.
Glaubst du, dass die ganze Blockchain-Sachen wichtig sind bei dir auf der Arbeit?
Naja, jetzt aktuell nicht.
In Zukunft schon.
Also wenn du aktuell davon ausgehst, dass es das ist, womit viel Kohle verdient wird,
ne, wird aktuell nicht viel Kohle mitverdient.
In Zukunft könnte ich mir das gut vorstellen, dass das wichtig ist, wichtig wird.
Das habe ich nicht mitbekommen, aber ich habe mitbekommen,
dass Amazon, Amazon hatte ein internes Rating für KI-Benutzung.
Ach Chat, das ist das geil.
Das muss ich euch...
Eine Frage an euch.
Was meint ihr, was passieren wird, wenn man die Mitarbeiter bewertet nach einem internen Ranking, wo es darum geht, wer viel KI-Tokens verbrät, ist oben in dem Ranking?
Was wird dann wohl passieren?
Ja, zumindest was passiert ist, die haben Prompts entwickelt, dass die KI möglichst viele Talkens verbrät.
Die haben KI quasi dazu angestiftet, möglichst viel unsinnige Arbeit zu verrichten, damit sie oben in diesem Ranking stehen.
Und daraufhin hat der Chef sowas sinngemäß gesagt
Ja, das kann er gar nicht verstehen
Er wäre ja eher dafür
Dass KI nur dann benutzt wird, wenn KI sinnvoll ist
Ja, ach, wer hätte sowas ahnen können
Wenn dieses Ranking eingeführt wird
Alter, wenn du, das ist wie
Das ist wie wenn du ein Ranking einführst
Du bezahlst deinen Entwickler nach Zeilen
Nach Codezeilen, ja klar
Dann wird die Singleton Manager Factory Abstraction Factory Manager gebaut.
Das ist halt richtig bescheuert.
Ja, das gab es bei Amazon.
Amazon KI Ranking.
Hier.
Da.
Amazon schaltet KI Leaderboard ab.
Nachdem Beschäftigte per Token-Maxing die Cloud-Rechnung hochtrieben.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen...
Was anderes kann ich dazu echt nicht sagen.
Wer hätte nur damit rechnen können, wenn man sowas einführt?
Wer hätte nur damit rechnen können?
So, aber um jetzt mal die Sache von der Arbeit zu beenden.
Was wollte ich denn jetzt eigentlich erzählen?
Achso, genau, dass ich sage, was ich nicht sinnvoll finde und wenn sie es dann trotzdem machen wollen, soll es trotzdem machen.
Also, von der Arbeit gibt es einen Service, der ist insgesamt als überhaupt nicht so wichtig klassifiziert.
Die Leute, die die Anwendung betreiben, denken aber, das ist der wichtigste Service ever.
Kann ich aus ihrer Sicht auch voll nachvollziehen. Ja, kein Ding.
Warum? Oh ne, ich wollte das jetzt gar nicht aufmachen. Kann man das aufmachen?
Ja, ist ja eine total bescheuerte Metrik.
Ist der alt?
Ja, natürlich, der wird eigentlich jünger.
Okay, aber jetzt mal zurück.
Also, wir haben auf der Arbeit einen Service,
der ist als nicht so wichtig klassifiziert.
Die Leute, die für die Anwendung zuständig sind,
denken, das ist der wichtigste Service ever.
Kann man irgendwie auch verstehen.
So, und jetzt ging es darum, wir sollen in Zukunft gucken,
Gerade wahrscheinlich auch, weil es jetzt durch KI immer mehr Sicherheitslücken und das immer öfters was rauskommt.
Wir sollen gucken, dass wir Betriebssystem-Updates möglichst automatisiert durchführen.
Am besten einmal in der Woche oder mindestens einmal im Monat.
Ja, klingt sinnvoll. Ja, sehe ich auch so. Sollte man machen.
Jetzt ist es allerdings so, das habe ich jetzt dort angekündigt, in dem letzten Meeting zu diesem Service.
Ich habe gesagt, hier, wir müssen automatische Betriebssystem-Updates machen.
Die meisten anderen Services machen es schon, der Service macht es noch nicht.
Das können wir einrichten.
Dann haben die gesagt, ja, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Da sind ja auch Reboots dabei.
Dann steht ja das Service nicht zur Verfügung.
Und was machen wir, wenn nach dem Reboot das Service nicht mehr richtig hochkommt durch Betriebssystem-Updates?
Ich meine, seriously, wie oft habt ihr schon erlebt, dass eine Java-Anwendung nach einem Red Hat Security OS Update nicht mehr startet? Eins von tausend? Oder so? Also die Chancen sind äußerst, es ist äußerst gering, ja.
Habe ich dann auch gesagt, Leute, wann ist denn das schon mal passiert?
Da wird ja keine Java-Major-Version geupdatet oder irgendwas.
Da wird LibXY von 1.1.2 auf 1.1.2 Patch 1 geupdatet oder so.
Ja, Windows-Admins frage ich bei sowas nicht.
Die kennen das ja zu Genüge.
Ja, da passiert nichts.
Und wenn, ich meine, das kann man auch nicht ausschließen.
Man kann nichts ausschließen.
Natürlich kann man es nicht ausschließen, aber die Chance ist sehr gering und ich kann mich an keinen Fall erinnern, wo ich das wirklich erlebt habe, dass ein Red Hat Update eine Java-Anwendung kaputt gemacht hat nach einem normalen OS-Security-Update, dass sie nicht mal gestartet hat.
Also, wie gesagt, außerdem, genau, außerdem haben wir noch Testsysteme, Integrationssysteme, wo das vorher passiert.
Also ich sehe da wirklich kein großes Risiko.
So, haben die gesagt, ah, das ist ihnen aber nichts.
Ähm, sie wollen, dass man nachguckt, dass die Anwendung nach dem Update, also ersten, genau, Moment, Moment, das ist das erste.
Sie wollen, dass man nachguckt, dass die Anwendung, nachdem man gestartet, also die Server-Reboote hat, auch ordentlich wieder läuft.
Und das zweite ist, sie wollen, dass die automatischen US-Updates auch gefälligst nur am Wochenende passieren, weil dort keiner den Service benutzen kann.
Also nicht in der Woche, nachts und morgens gucken wir oder so.
Wohlgemerkt, der Service ist nicht als sonderlich wichtig gekennzeichnet.
Habt ihr Replikas von dem Service? Nö.
Es gibt, allein schon aus Lizenzgebühren nicht.
Das Zeug ist schweineteuer.
Das ist irgendeine komische, frag mich nicht,
File-Transfer-Software oder so von IBM.
Da haben wir ganze zwei Services in Produktion.
Zwei Server mit zwei Services,
die auch schon teuer genug sind.
Da gibt es keine Replikas.
Und das läuft auch nicht um Kubernetes-Klasse.
Das sind Oldschool-VMs.
So, also zwei Sachen.
Sie wollen, dass geguckt wird,
dass der Service ordentlich hochkommt.
Und sie wollen, dass das nur am Wochenende passiert.
Und da habe ich gesagt, also, ich sehe ganz, ganz kleines Risiko nur das, was passiert.
Und das Service ist nicht als wichtig markiert, wichtig genug dafür markiert, dass da sich am Wochenende für einer hinsetzt.
Aber, wenn ihr das machen wollt, ihr könnt ja auch nachgucken am Wochenende.
Ihr könnt ja auch am Samstag euch einloggen und gucken, ob noch alles gesta...
Warte mal.
Ihr könnt euch da auch am Samstag einloggen und gucken, ob noch alles gestartet ist.
Und da haben die tatsächlich gesagt, ja, das wollen sie machen.
Und sie hätten gerne eine Rufbereitschaft dafür, dass wenn der Service nicht richtig hochkommt, dass sie jemand von uns anrufen können.
Und da habe ich mir dann gedacht, jawohl, das mache ich, kein Problem.
Gib mir 500 Euro
Easy Money am Samstag
Ist okay, kein Problem
Ich mach 24 Stunden Samstag
Ich mach von Samstag Nacht bis Samstag
Bis Sonntag, dann mach ich Rufbereitschaft
Kein Problem
Mach ich
Kein Ding, wenn ihr das wollt, mach ich das
Und in Zukunft wird es ja so laufen
Einmal im Monat
Bekomm ich
500 Euro quasi
zusätzlich für nichts.
Weil ich hab dann von
Freitagabend
bis Sonntagmorgen
hab ich Rufbereitschaft. Das gibt dann so
über Daumen gepeilt 500 Euro.
Ja, vielleicht ein bisschen weniger. 400, 450.
Und ich weiß,
dass nix sein wird.
Zu 99% wird nix sein.
TinySmall,
danke schön für den Sub.
69. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Es wird nichts sein. Und wisst ihr,
mehr als sagen kann ich es nicht.
Das ist das, was ich meine, wie ich es mittlerweile
in der Hand habe. Ich sage, dass ich das nicht für sinnvoll
halte. Und wenn sie es wirklich haben
wollen,
dann kriegen sie es halt.
Und in dem Fall hat das eigentlich nur
Vorteile für mich. Ich weiß, dass
mit an Sicherheitsgrenzen der Wahrscheinlichkeit
so gut wie nie was passieren wird.
Und ich weiß, dass ich einmal im Monat
Easy Money kriege.
Also,
Warum soll ich mich dagegen großartig wehren?
Und unterm Strich hat es jetzt sogar nur positive Effekte für mich
Bei der nächsten Rücksprache wird dann wahrscheinlich von den Serviceleuten erzählt
Oh, was für einen Einsatz der Max zeigt
Der ist sogar am Samstag bereit, für unseren Service zur Verfügung zu stehen, wenn da was kaputt geht
Also unterm Strich hat es nur Vorteile für mich
Ich hab gesagt, ich find's Blödsinn
Okay, sie wollen's trotzdem, dann machen wir's halt
Ey, wenn's danach geht
Ich mach für alle diese Services Rufbereitschaft
Jeden Samstag, kein Problem
Das ist nicht das Karriere-Maxing-Crineset
Das ist das
Das ist das Easy-Money-Crineset-Mindset
Max, du musst dann aber Samstag zu Hause sein
Das ist richtig, das muss ich, tatsächlich
Ich hab, ähm
Eine Stunde, innerhalb von einer Stunde
Muss ich am Rechner sitzen
Das ist richtig, einen kleinen Nachteil hab ich dadurch
Das ist richtig, ja
Ich hab aber keinen so großen Nachteil
Weil ich eh Informatiker-Kellerkent bin
Und auch Samstags
Vorm Rechner sitze und bastle
Ist das nicht so schlimm
Das Einzige, was ich nicht machen kann, ist größeren Ausflug mit dem Fahrrad. Das sagt ein bisschen. Was ich theoretisch machen könnte, wenn ich total übertreiben will und ja sehr konfident, wenn ich sehr überzeugt davon bin, dass wirklich nichts passiert, könnte ich mein Handy und Laptop in den Rucksack packen und trotzdem Fahrradtour machen.
Weil da könnte ich einfach mein Handy rausholen und mit dem Laptop über WLAN mich einloggen.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, dann mache ich halt keine große Fahrradtour an dem Samstag.
Das ist nicht schlimm.
Dafür gibt es Easy Money.
Also das ist wirklich easiest Money überhaupt.
Und Fahrradfahren kann ich theoretisch schon.
Da müsste ich halt einen Rundkurs nehmen,
wo ich im schlechtesten Fall
halt maximal eine Stunde entfernt bin.
Das ist ja auch immer noch eine große Runde, ja?
Also das geht.
Das ist alles kein Ding.
Das ist wirklich easy money glitch.
Und die wollen das. Ich habe ja gesagt, dass ich es nicht für sinnvoll halte.
Aber sie wollten es trotzdem.
Was willst du machen, ne?
Dann machen wir das halt.
Ja, aber ich weiß nicht, das ist mir nichts.
Ich sitze dann schon lieber daheim am Rechner, wenn wirklich was ist.
VNC auf dem Handy.
Okay, nee, ich glaube, das funktioniert richtig.
Ey, nee.
Na gut, jetzt wurde ich wieder hardcore sidetracked.
Wir haben das Video übrigens nach über einer Stunde immer noch nicht fertig.
Wir haben hier Azubis Tipps, wie ich die Bedingungen verbessern kann.
Ich will es besser machen.
Oder hier, gib nicht auf, es lohnt sich.
Ich war kurz davor, alles hinzuschmeißen.
Heute habe ich einen Job, der mir Spaß macht.
an alle, die gerade zweifeln, durchhalten.
Hier ein neuer Tarifvertrag mit Verdi,
Stelle nach der Ausbildung gefunden.
Es ist momentan nicht ideal, aber so hoffnungslos ist es nicht.
Fangt früh an, euch zu bewerben.
Wartet nicht, bis die Prüfungen rum sind.
Ja, das ist in der Tat sinnvoll.
Es ist immer eigentlich sinnvoll,
wenn man nicht wartet, bis man quasi komplett am Abgrund ist.
Man hat vorher einfach deutlich mehr Optionen
Und muss dann auch nichts annehmen, was einem gar nicht schmeckt.
Was ich aktuell spiele?
Kein Battlefield 6.
Ich habe Battlefield 6 ignored.
Ich spiele gerade sinnlose
Kreisel-Crime-MMOs,
die 20 Jahre alt sind.
Hier,
besonders für mich gerade relevant,
das ganze Gejammer hier vor der Prüfung
hat mir richtig Angst gemacht.
Am Ende war alles machbar.
Glaubt also nicht.
Das ist genauso wie auf fachinformatiker.de, falls es die Seite noch gibt. Da denkst du auch immer, Wunder, was da dran kommt. Am Ende schafft die Prüfung jeder, der sich ordentlich vorbereitet hat. Und das Wichtigste, warum streamst du die nicht? Was meinst du? Was soll ich streamen?
Achso, die Games
Weiß nicht, weil das wahrscheinlich die meisten überhaupt nicht interessiert
Ähm
Genau, was ich zur Prüfung sagen wollte
Bei der Prüfung kommt es ja hauptsächlich darauf an
Dass man sich damit auseinandergesetzt hat
wie die IHK fragt und was für Fragen da so drankommen.
Wer sich ordentlich auf die Prüfung vorbereitet,
schafft die Prüfung,
selbst wenn er absolut keine Ahnung von seinem Job hat.
Er muss Ahnung von der IHK-Prüfung haben.
Jedem Doom-Post auf Reddit oder auf TikTok.
So, also, was heißt das jetzt für dich konkret?
Nee, AF-Programmer, so einfach ist das nicht.
Wenn du gar so viel Zeug streamst,
was die Leute nicht interessiert,
dann unsubscriben die dich auch.
Und unfollowen dir und sowas.
verständlicherweise weil du willst ja nicht da informiert werden max ist online und streamt
keine ahnung hätte online oder sowas grundlegend schauen wir die grundregel am einstieg vergleichen
betriebe dich nicht nur mit anderen anfänger bei the way warum ist eigentlich die sachen
hier auf englisch unten das ist youtube oder youtube ist wieder der meinung ich will das
auf Englisch wissen.
Aber der Titel ist in Deutsch
und der...
YouTube, Alter, dieses Auto übersetzen ist so dumm.
Hast du eigentlich
einen 3D-Drucker? Ja.
Die fragen sich vor allem,
wie schnell du im Job wirklich mitarbeiten kannst.
Betriebe stellen vorsichtiger ein,
weil die wirtschaftliche Lage unsicher ist.
Reine Einstiegsstellen sind seltener ausgeschrieben
als noch vor wenigen Jahren.
Viele Rollen erwarten heute mehr Praxis
und nicht nur einen Abschluss.
Künstliche Intelligenz übernimmt
also ein Teil der einfachen Aufgaben, mit denen früher oft Anfänger gestartet sind.
Deswegen hilft es dir, früh sichtbar zu machen, dass du Aufgaben übernehmen kannst.
Bewirb dich also nicht nur.
Das hat er schön aus Business-Sicht zusammengefasst.
Ich glaube, so ein genereller Tipp ist, wo ich mir auch immer schwer tue,
weil ihr wisst ja, Business ist nicht unbedingt meins,
aber es hilft bei vielen Sachen, sich mal in die andere Seite reinzuversetzen.
Wir bauen ein Produkt nicht nur, weil wir es technisch geil können, sondern weil wir mit dem Produkt am Ende Geld verdienen wollen. Und was von dem Produkt verdient denn eigentlich für uns am meisten Geld? Mal aus anderer Sicht sehen, so was aus der Business-Sicht sehen, ist gar nicht so verkehrt, wenn ich das auch ungern mache.
Zeig konkret, was du schon kannst. Setz dich damit ein.
Deswegen, man muss denen oftmals einfach das erzählen, was sie hören wollen. Und dazu muss man sich erstmal reinversetzen in die Lage, rauszukriegen, was die denn hören wollen.
auseinander. Bau ein Portfolio auf.
Mach Beispielprojekte. Wie du das machst,
gleich dazu mehr.
Lass mich raten, was seid ihr im Kurs?
Komm uns mal die Situation an, wo du gerade stehst.
Suchst du entweder einen Ausbildungsplatz?
Bist du schon in der Ausbildung? Steigst du
quer ein oder schulst du um? Oder wickst du
gerade ab, hey, Ausbildung oder
Studium? Wenn du gerade
einen Ausbildungsplatz machst. Oder so.
Gute Frage.
Was tut man
gegen einen unerfahrenen und belehrbaren
Projektleiter, bei dem die Projekte immer gegen die Wand
laufen und die Techniker es jedes
Mal ausbaden dürfen. Es gibt
zwei Sachen, die du machen kannst. Also zwei Sachen, die man
bei sowas immer machen kann. Ich sage nicht, dass
das die ultimative Lösung dafür ist und
es ist eine beschissene Situation, die bleibt
nach wie vor. Gerade wenn
der Chef dieses Projektleiters da
auch unbelehrbar ist. Eine Sache
hilft,
dokumentieren.
Schreib auf, was gesagt wurde.
Schreib auf, dass du es bis
dann und dann geliefert hast.
Und da kann dir keiner mehr gegen den Karren pissen, wie man so schön sagt.
Wenn es darum geht, es soll A oder B gemacht werden, du sagst, aus technischer Sicht für die Stabilität am sinnvollsten ist B zu machen,
der Projektleiter sagt, nein, wir machen A, aufschreiben, dokumentieren.
Und wenn dann einer kommt, warum habt ihr das so kacke gebaut, kannst du sagen,
am 23.04. hast du gesagt, wir sollen A verfolgen und nicht B.
das Beste, was man gegen, generell,
was man gegen
Leute, die einen Abfakt machen können,
ist dokumentieren. Aufschreiben.
Weil
die ziehen oftmals ihre,
ihre,
ihre Stärke daraus,
dass du dich nicht mehr erinnerst.
Du weißt, dass es so ist, ja, du weißt
genau, ihr habt das besprochen, aber du kannst
es nicht mal direkt sagen, also die,
Nee, nee, da musst du was falsch verstanden haben. Ich hab doch ganz klar gesagt, bla bla bla bla bla. So Leute labern, reden sich immer gut raus. Das Beste, was du machen kannst, ist dokumentieren. Ja, und das Zweite, was du machen kannst, ist mit deinem Chef drüber reden, weil er in der Regel dein Chef, der für dich personell verantwortlich ist, nicht der Projektleiter ist.
Du kannst mit deinem Chef drüber reden.
Und dann ist es natürlich noch besser, du hast das schön dokumentiert,
dann hast du auch was, wo du deinem Chef sagen kannst,
ey, guck mal hier, mit dem Projektleiter gibt es immer nur Stress.
Da sagt er das, da beschwert er sich, dass wir das gemacht haben, was er gesagt hat.
Macht ja keinen Sinn.
Noch viel besser, wenn du es dokumentiert hast.
Ja, ich verstehe, dass das beschissen ist.
Ja, ja.
Ich verstehe, dass das beschissen ist.
Du musst das dokumentieren,
dass du
klar sagen kannst,
wir haben es so gemacht,
wie der das wollte,
dass es halt dann im Endeffekt
die Entscheidung des Projektmanagers war.
Blöd.
Was, wenn es kein Projektleiter gibt?
Irgendjemand, der den Hut auf hat,
muss es ja geben.
Dann kam öfters, das habe ich nicht so gesagt, gemeint, dann ist noch besser, wenn mehrere Leute das dokumentiert haben.
Ja.
Oder, genau das ist das, was ich als nächstes sagen wollte, wenn das gar nicht hilft, Protokoll rumschicken.
Genau das wollte ich auch gerade sagen.
Also wenn selbst dokumentieren und das dann abgestritten wird, ja
Und wenn es sogar bei mehreren Leuten, die das gleiche sagen und dokumentieren, dann abgestritten wird
Protokoll rumschicken
Und gleichzeitig vielleicht mal gucken, ob man nicht woanders hin kann
Weil auf Dauer ist das natürlich auch nichts
Es sei denn, du bist jemand, der sich gerne permanent streitet
Das macht aber auch keinen Spaß
Also das verstehe ich
Du wirst es wahrscheinlich nicht zu deiner Zufriedenheit geändert kriegen, wenn der andere das partout dagegen ist.
Also nach was anderem gucken ist auch nicht verkehrt.
Weil man will sich jetzt ja auch nicht ein Jahr abfacken.
Moin, hast du schon mitbekommen, dass die ersten Unternehmen jetzt schon berichten, dass KI teurer ist als Mitarbeiter?
Ja, habe ich mitbekommen.
Moin, Delua. Dankeschön übrigens
für eure beiden Subs. Huge Subs.
Äh.
Warum hat das jetzt die Katze aufgemacht? Ich habe da überhaupt nicht
drauf geklickt. Also ich meine nicht,
dass es schlimm wäre, dass er die Katze aufgemacht hat, aber...
Äh.
Kommt der da? The fuck?
Ich...
Ich will den Desktop umschalten
und beim Desktop umschalten
geht er immer auf die Katze.
Chat, wer von euch ist das?
Ist das nicht normal, so Protokolle in einem Share-Dokument zu finden?
Ganz ehrlich, wenn ich gut mit den Leuten klarkomme und da sinnvolle Entscheidungen in der Regel getroffen werden,
ich dokumentiere nicht jeden Scheiß. Das ist mir viel zu aufwendig.
Ja, wenn man den nächsten Sprint plant oder so,
Ja, dann schiebst du die Dinger im Ticketsystem so hin, schreibst mal Updates rein, aber für jeden scheißen Protokoll schreiben, da hätte ich gar keinen Bock drauf. Und in der Regel, wenn die Leute gescheit sind, erinnern die sich ja auch noch dran. So nach dem Motto, haben wir das letzte Mal nicht besprochen, so und so, ach ja, stimmt, da war ja was.
Aber bei uns ist es ja auch so, dass die meisten Leute keinerlei Probleme haben, zuzugeben, wenn sie sich mal geirrt haben.
Ja, keiner macht das gerne. Ich mache das auch nicht gerne.
Aber ich sage auch, stimmt, stimmt, da habe ich nicht mehr dran gedacht.
Das ist dann überhaupt kein Problem.
Fliesenvertreter, danke für den Prime-Sub.
Danke für eure ganzen Subs hier.
Letzten Minuten wurde ja hier gesuppt ohne Ende.
Informatik heute nochmal studieren, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Es werden bald sicher keine Entwickler mehr in der Masse wie heute gebraucht.
KI wird programmieren und die Hand von Vollengel für Hardware.
Das wird immer so hingestellt, als das ist auf jeden Fall so.
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass das unumstößlich auf jeden Fall so kommen wird.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Ist es bei euch erlaubt, Audio aufzunehmen und danach mit KI Zusammenfassung zu erstellen?
Gute Frage, keine Ahnung, macht aber auch keiner.
Also ich schreibe mir auch viel auf, ja.
Ich habe auch so ein paar Textdokumente, wo ich alles reinschreibe.
Das versteht dann aber meistens außer mir keiner.
Aber ich habe auch so gut wie nicht die Notwendigkeit, etwas zu protokollieren,
dass ich dann später jemand darauf hinweisen kann, er hat was anderes gesagt.
Das kommt bei uns eigentlich nicht vor.
Also die meisten Leute geben schon durchaus zu, wenn sie sich geirrt haben und ich auch.
Also bei uns ist das eigentlich sehr harmonisches Arbeitsklima.
Da brauche ich keine Beweise.
Und selbst wenn
ich oder die anderen sich nicht mehr
daran erinnern und einer sagt, doch, ich weiß genau,
das haben wir besprochen,
dann würde ich auch sagen, okay, ich weiß es nicht mehr,
aber ich glaube dir das halt einfach.
So, jetzt müssen wir echt mal weitergucken,
weil ich kriege langsam schon Hunger und wir haben noch nicht mal
ein Video geschafft.
Bewirb dich früher als nötig, damit du nicht von einem einzigen Betrieb abhängig bist.
Wenn du nächstes Jahr eine Ausbildung machen möchtest, bewirb dich schon jetzt.
Große Konzerne, große Betriebe haben jetzt schon ihre Stellen ausgeschrieben für die Ausbildung im Start 2027.
Schau dir auch mehrere Fachrichtungen an.
Zum Beispiel beim Fachinformatiker gibt es vier.
Systemintegration, Anwendungsentwicklung, digitale Vernetzung und Daten- und Prozessanalyse.
wenn du keinen Job als Anwendungsentwickler findest.
Also, Mery, Olli, ich glaube, ganz viele Bullshit-Jobs werden ersetzt, ja, die jetzt schon nichts machen, außer quasi das, was KI jetzt schon besser kann. Ich könnte mir auch durchaus vorstellen, dass die ein oder anderen Management-Jobs durch KI ersetzt werden, aber gerade was Entwickler angeht, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
Ja, du kannst mit Geweib-Code sehr schnell Sachen erstellen. Das ist ja mittlerweile hinlänglich bekannt. Ja, schnell Prototypen erstellen, auch meinetwegen schnell was releasen, das funktioniert. Aber du siehst es bei Microsoft wohl als prominentestes Beispiel, was für krasse Qualitätsprobleme die Inventors zurzeit haben.
und das kommt vieles mit Sicherheit durch KI-Nutzung, da wette ich drauf.
Und ob man mit ein paar schönen Prompts und einem schönen initialen Produkt
auch was langfristig betreiben, verkaufen, maintainen, weiterentwickeln kann,
da habe ich so meine Zweifel dran.
Es wird auf jeden Fall Stellen geben, die es jetzt noch nicht gibt,
also sowas wie KI-Versteher.
Ja, also Leute, die dann quasi mit Hirn-Vibe-Coden bzw. nur bestimmte Stellen-Vibe-Coden lassen, das überprüfen und gucken, ich habe selbst keine Ahnung, wie solche Positionen aussehen werden.
Ich nenne es mal Vibe-Coding-Versteher.
Wird es auf jeden Fall geben müssen.
Und auch normale Entwickler, ich sehe nicht, dass die große Massenarbeitslosigkeit hier irgendwie durch KI kommt.
Das werden wir aber erst in vielleicht fünf Jahren mal rückblickend sehen können oder zehn Jahren, ob das wirklich stimmt, wer da recht hatte.
Ja, medizinische Diagnosen, ja, ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass da KIs zu, sagen wir mal, 95 Prozent vielleicht, also bei den üblichen Sachen, das genauso gut hinkriegen bei den Symptomen und Ärzte.
Aber ganz ehrlich, gerade bei Ärzten ist ja auch eine gehörige Portion Zwischenmenschliches dabei, um die Sachen erstmal rauszukriegen und bei den jeweiligen Leuten richtig einordnen zu können. Und was da noch ein viel größerer Faktor ist, wer hält denn den Kopf hin, wenn mal was nicht stimmt?
Ja, du kannst Ärzte von Diagnosen nicht, du kannst, auch Ärzte können falsch liegen, das wird auch oft übersehen, so nach dem Motto, frag lieber einen Arzt anstelle KI, der liegt dann eher richtig.
Ne, es gibt da auch ganz viele Leute, die auch kacke sind, das ist doch wie bei vielen Berufen, so 90% der Leute haben keine Ahnung von dem, was sie machen.
Ja, das kann man vielleicht dann auch mit KI ersetzen.
Aber bei KI und Ärzten frage ich mich eher, wer hält den Kopf für hin, wenn es verkehrt ist.
Aber dass es da KI als Unterstützung geben wird und vieles auch Neues entstehen wird,
gerade bei irgendwelchen Bildanalysen von irgendwelchen Ultraschalls, CTs, MRTs und sowas,
bei der Analyse von solchen, wie heißt es immer so schön, bildgebenden Verfahren,
Da wird KI garantiert in Zukunft auch im großen Stil eingesetzt werden. Wenn nicht jetzt schon. Garantiert. Jetzt müssen wir aber echt mal fertig gucken, sonst kommen wir nicht mehr durch.
Die ersten 18 Monate sind laut Rahmen der Plan eh gleich. Es hängt eh sowieso vom Ausbildungsbetrieb ab, was du machst.
Und du kannst immer ein bisschen beimischen und dich dann später immer noch spezialisieren.
Bewirb dich auch bei kleineren Betrieben. Schau dir mal Behörden an. Schau dir vielleicht mal ein Krankenhaus an.
Die haben manchmal auch Fachinformatikerstellen. Oder Dienstleister. Wichtig ist, dass du dich schon mal auseinander...
Im Krankenhaus könnte ich nicht arbeiten. Ganz ehrlich, ich könnte IT-technisch so gut wie überall arbeiten, wenn es was ist, was mich interessiert.
Ja, ich könnte bei Banken, Versicherungen arbeiten, ich könnte in der Automobilindustrie arbeiten, ich könnte in der Rüstungsindustrie arbeiten, das wäre mir alles egal, wenn es was ist, was mich interessiert. In Krankenhäusern könnte ich nicht arbeiten. Das liegt daran, weil ich da deutlich zu viel von Krankheiten mitbekommen würde und mir wahrscheinlich laufend einbilden würde, ich hätte irgendwas. Das könnte ich nicht. Im Krankenhaus arbeiten könnte ich nicht.
dass du vielleicht mal ein echtes Projekt baust,
das ein konkretes Problem löst.
Und da soll es nicht nur um deinen Code gehen
oder was du gemacht hast, sondern auch dein Denken.
Wie bist du vorgegangen und was hast du daraus gelernt?
Und ein gutes Anfängerprofil zeigt,
dass du schnell lernst und schon erste Dinge selbst umsetzen kannst.
Noch keine ausgebildete Fachkraft bist.
Das erwartet niemand von dir.
Ich will wissen, bist du lernbereit?
Ja.
Und wie gehst du vor? Passt du zu uns?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich eine Sache,
die mich bei unseren Azubis früher auch immer,
Das ist eines der ersten Sachen, die mich interessiert hat.
Ich meine, ich hatte nichts da wirklich mit zu entscheiden, ob die als Hubis genommen werden oder nicht.
Die kamen dann nur mal irgendwo bei uns in der Linux-Ecke an.
Und ich habe mich darum gekümmert.
Mache ich übrigens immer noch gerne.
Und das Wichtigste für mich war, erstmal zu sehen, okay, das ist jemand, der interessiert sich dafür.
Sobald das gegeben war, war der Rest easy.
Du hattest aber auch Leute, wo du gleich gemerkt hast, die machen das.
Zum Beispiel, weil der Vater gesagt hat, du kriegst von mir keine Kohle mehr, wenn du jetzt nicht endlich eine Ausbildung machst. Hatten wir auch einen. Hat der Vater gesagt, gib kein Geld mehr. Mach eine Ausbildung oder gib kein Geld mehr. Also hat er eine Ausbildung gemacht. Hat er halt keinen Bock. Hast du sofort gemerkt.
Wenn du schon in der Ausbildung bist, dann bitte, bitte, bitte fang dich mit der Jobsuche erst nach der Prüfung an. Etwa sechs bis neun Monate vor dem Abschluss baust du dir ein klares Profil auf. Klares Profil ausbauen heißt auch Nische finden. Double down in eine Nische, in der du ein Experte wirst.
Und schon mal frühzeitig abchecken, wie es mit Übernahme aussieht.
Und sich nicht so sehr von Gelaber beeindrucken lassen.
Weil die wissen genau, wenn sie das lange rauszögern mit dem Vertrag und der Übernahme,
sind viele Leute bereit, für weniger Geld da anzufangen, weil jetzt kurz vor knapp ist.
Ja, also das sollte mit der Übernahme, sollte schon alles frühzeitig geregelt sein,
sodass man sich auch anderweitig umgucken kann.
Weil ansonsten erzähle die, ja, ja, Übernahme, das machen wir, das machen wir wie immer,
das machen wir wie immer, wir machen das, machen wir wie immer.
Und wie sieht es aus mit der Übernahme? Ja, da sind wir dran, das machen wir wie immer, das kommt dann schon.
Und dann irgendwann, eine Woche vor Prüfung,
ah, wir können dir leider nicht den normalen Vertrag anbieten,
du musst jetzt leider für weniger arbeiten bei uns.
Ja, doof, du hast ja keine Chance, dir mehr was anderes zu suchen.
Also in ordentlichen Betrieben macht man das zu gegebener Zeit und nicht kurz vor knapp.
Und wenn die nicht zu Potte kommen mit der Übernahme, dann kann man sich durchaus auch mal woanders umgucken.
Man sollte sich nicht hundertprozentig darauf verlassen, dass man übernommen wird, nur weil die das sagen.
So, ja, das machen wir, wir übernehmen, wie immer, wie immer, ja, ja.
Der dir Spaß macht, dieser Bereich.
Halt fest, wo du ein Experte wirst, der dir Spaß macht.
Nische finden. Double down in eine Nische, in der du ein Experte wirst.
Ja, sehe ich genauso. Also ich finde beides wichtig. Es ist wichtig, sich breit auszukennen, denn dann hat man schon mal den Einstieg. Also ich kann mich relativ schnell, sieht man ja auch im Stream öfters, in neue Sachen reindenken und einarbeiten, weil ich ein bisschen Grundlagenahnung von vielen Bereichen habe.
Ja, ich kenne mich mit Microcontroller-Gedöns aus, ich kenne mich mit Go.net, ein bisschen mit Rust, ein bisschen mit Python, ein bisschen mit Java, alles aus. Ich komme da ganz schnell rein. Ja, aber natürlich, gerade was Linux-Server, Hochverfügbarkeit, Kubernetes, Cloud-Geschichten angeht, da kenne ich mich dann in der Tiefe aus.
Aber ich weiß auch bei anderen Bereichen, wo ich nachgucken muss. Also deswegen finde ich es ganz gut, wenn man sich doch schon breit interessiert auskennt, aber dann von dem Bereich, der einen wirklich interessiert, richtig tiefgreifend Ahnung hat.
Spaß macht dieser Bereich. Halt fest, woran du im Betrieb wirklich gearbeitet hast, damit du es später zeigen kannst. Wenn du Lücken hast, dann schließe das mit eigenen Projekten. Wenn dein Betrieb bestimmte Themen nicht abdeckt, schau dazu in den Ausbildungsrahmenplan rein.
und lerne die Grundlagen so, dass du sie erklären kannst.
Netzwerke, Datenbanken, Git, Basics zur Sicherheit,
so dass du sie freischnauze erzählen kannst.
So, dein Abschluss ist super wichtig.
Aber was du nachweisbar kannst, entscheidet oft genauso mit.
Das gleiche gilt auch für die Leute, die eine Ausbildung gerade suchen.
Wenn du gerade umstuhlst oder quer einsteigst,
dann ist es auch wieder hier wichtig, du brauchst klar...
Siehste?
Der Gamer Alex sagt genau das, was ich auch gerade gesagt habe.
Das wird nochmal bestätigt, vor allem der in der Situation war.
ihm wurde auch eine Woche vorher gesagt,
Vertrag kann nicht verlängert werden, obwohl sie ein halbes Jahr
vorher gefragt haben und mündlich
gesagt wurde, ja, ja, wäre kein Problem. Wie gesagt, da kann man
nichts drauf geben. Und wenn ihr nicht
zu Potte kommt, dann guckt euch einfach anderweitig
um. Ich kenne das von mir selbst.
Es ist super bequem zu sagen,
naja, das klappt
schon und die haben ja auch mündlich schon zugesagt,
wenn da nichts Handfestes bei rum
kommt, dann könnt ihr euch da
im Zweifelsfall nicht drauf verlassen.
Belege aus der Praxis, weil ein Zertifikat allein oft nicht überzeugt. Deswegen auch hier, zeig, welche Probleme du lösen kannst. Und das ist ganz, ganz wichtig, gerade bei Umschülern oder Quereinsteigern, nutz deine bisherige Erfahrung als Vorteil. Etwa dein Wissen über eine Branche oder dein Umgang mit Kundinnen und Kunden. Nutze deine Vergangenheit.
Das fanden die tatsächlich in meiner Bewerbung auch gut. Wie gesagt, jetzt arbeite ich bei einer Versicherung, davor habe ich bei einer Bank gearbeitet. Ich habe gesagt, ich kenne mich halt Frankfurter Finanzbranche schon ein bisschen aus, wie es da so läuft. Das fanden die nice. Also ich hatte schon mal ein bisschen was mit regulatorischen Vorgaben und so zu tun. Bei einer Bank ja noch mehr als bei einer Versicherung.
Deinem Vorteil. Such also vielleicht gezielt nach Rollen, in denen dein altes Wissen mit
IT zusammenkommt. Bewirb dich also nicht auch nur auf reine Junior-Entwickler oder reine
System-Administrator-Stellen, sondern vielleicht auch auf Mischrollen. Ein Quereinstieg gelingt
halt wirklich leichter, wenn es nicht so wirkt, als würdest du bei Null anfangen, sondern offen
deine vorherigen Erkenntnisse mit einfließen lässt. Ja, wenn es halt relevant ist dafür,
Kann ja durchaus sein, dass man früher, ich nehme mal wieder Steinmetz, ehemaliger Steinmetz-Mitschüler auf der Berufsschule. Je nachdem ist es halt ziemlich egal. Aber es kann natürlich auch durchaus sein, dass es in einem Bereich ist, wo man das gar nicht denkt, wo das von relevant sein kann.
In irgendeinem Industrieladen, wo auch handwerklich irgendwelche Sachen bearbeitet werden, da ist es bestimmt nicht verkehrt. Wenn du schon mal selbst in der Situation warst, dass du sowas bearbeitet hast und ungefähr weißt, wie da so die Abläufe sind, das macht Pluspunkte beim Arbeitgeber, wenn du sagst, okay, ich habe selbst schon mal mit so einer Maschine gearbeitet.
Wenn du dir jetzt überlegst, hey, Ausbildung oder Studium, dann sage ich so, beide Wege können funktionieren, aber keiner davon ist ein Selbstläufer.
Studium kann dir super später Türen zu Spezial- und Expertenrollen öffnen.
Die Praxis kommt oft erst spät, deshalb lohnen sich früh, ich sage es immer wieder, eigene Projekte.
Bei der Ausbildung bringt dir früh echte Praxis und Erfahrung im Betrieb.
Sie wirkt aber nur dann stark, wenn du sie aktiv nutzt und nicht absitzt.
Auch unter Informatik studieren ganz viele, deshalb entsteht auch dort Konkurrenz am Einstieg. Bei beiden Bildungswegen entscheidet nicht der Titel, sondern das, was du daraus machst. Und bitte komm von dem Gedanken weg, dass eine Ausbildung nur ein Plan B ist, wenn du kein Studium findest.
Ich habe erst eine Ausbildung gemacht, dann habe ich nochmal studiert für zwei Semester, habe gemerkt, das ist nichts für mich, habe es abgebrochen und habe angefangen zu arbeiten. Deswegen eine Ausbildung kann genauso gut in der IT Plan A sein wie ein Studium.
Ja, ist auch so.
Wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel ein kleines Miniprojekt machen möchtest, dann mach eine Ordnerstruktur, mach dir eine kleine Webseite, baue Screenshots ein, mach eine kleine Redaktion.
Und ja, ich denke mal, rein statistisch gesehen, also wenn man jetzt wirklich nur nach irgendwelchen Graphen und so geht, werden wahrscheinlich Leute, die studiert haben, im Durchschnitt ein bisschen mehr verdienen als Leute, die nur eine Ausbildung haben.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass das zwangsläufig auf euch individuell zutreffen muss.
Ihr könnt auch der absolute Checker in einem Gebiet werden,
mit einer Ausbildung und umgedreht und richtig fett Kohle verdienen.
Wichtig ist halt nur, dass ihr ein Gebiet findet, was euch interessiert,
so dass ihr halt auch privat da interessiert seid und es für euch voll reinhängt.
Weil nur mit Ahnung gibt es halt was.
Drucker, Patronen, Wechsler braucht man auch nur ein paar.
Readme-Datei, wo du erklärst, was das Problem ist und wie du das löst.
Wie man ein Projekt startet, wenn du zum Beispiel Entwickler bist oder wenn du jetzt Systemintegrator bist, machst du halt Bilder davon oder Screenshots.
Halte deine Entscheidungen fest. Erkläre, warum hast du etwas gemacht.
Du kannst als Admin auch ohne Probleme.
Es ist mittlerweile heute so viel Infrastructure as Code, sei es jetzt Ansible, Terraform oder sonst was, kannst du ohne Probleme in ein GitHub-Repo packen.
Professioniersten Kubernetes Cluster.
Bei Google.
Oder bei Hetzner.
Mit Custom.
Custom Klassen.
Und das macht sich gut.
Woran bist du hängen geblieben?
Und wie bist du weitergekommen?
Und macht sichtbar, dass du das Projekt weiterdenkst?
Also das sind vor allem Themen.
Wenn ich das bei dir sehen würde im GitHub-Profil.
Gut, ich finde, man muss es jetzt als Azubi nicht komplett übertreiben.
Ich sage ja auch immer, eine Ausbildung ist ja nicht unbedingt dafür da, dass du schon alles kannst, sondern du willst das lernen. Wichtig ist, dass du, dass sich das interessiert. Das ist für mich bei Azubis das Wichtigste, dass sich das interessiert.
und Leute, die es interessiert,
die haben halt auch schon im Vorfeld
zwangsläufig das eine oder andere gemacht,
weil wenn es dich nicht interessiert,
also nee, umgedreht,
wenn es dich interessiert, dann hast du halt davor auch schon
was gemacht, weil es dich interessiert.
Also du musst jetzt nicht,
du hörst jetzt fast, du willst so eine Ultra-Experte sein
für eine Ausbildungsstelle, nee, du machst das ja,
weil du es richtig lernen willst.
Und die besten Azubis, die ich hatte, waren die,
die interessiert waren,
denen klar war, okay,
also die wussten, okay, mich interessiert
der Bereich, wo du es auch gemerkt hast
dir interessiert das in dem Bereich
die aber nicht damit rangegangen sind
ich mach das ja hier nur, weil ich einen Zettel haben will
die Leute, die gesagt haben
ich kann ja schon alles, die Ausbildung mach ich nur, weil ich einen Zettel
von der IHK bekomme, die konntest du
meistens komplett vergessen
weil daheim
und sei es, dass die Leute daheim
im Raspberry Pi rumgebastelt haben
ist noch was ganz was anderes
wie wenn du in einer Business Enterprise Umgebung
Linux-System rumbastelst, wo es dann auch wirklich
darum geht, okay, der Ausfall
kostet uns jetzt 5 Millionen pro Stunde.
Ein bisschen was anderes
wie, oh guck mal, mein Temperatursensor
im Keller am Raspberry Pi geht nicht mehr.
Also
Olli, ich bin,
ihr kennt mich, ich halte von Zertifikaten
wenig.
Das ist so ein selbst erhaltenes
Ökosystem, die sich unter anderem
selbst untereinander viel Geld zuschachern
mit Ausbildung für Trainer,
Trainer bilden, Trainer aus,
Zertifikate, die ablaufen,
die du erneuern musst.
Es mag sicherlich
welche geben. Ich sag nicht, dass die prinzipiell unsinnig sind.
Mag sicherlich welche geben.
Und gerade,
wenn du ein bisschen so im
wie nennt man das?
Im
organisatorischen Bereich landest,
ja, die mögen vielleicht auf irgendwelche
ITIL-Sachen stehen und
ähm, ja,
einen Scrum-Master-Lehrgang hat auch nicht jeder,
falls du sowas machen willst, wobei das jetzt dann mit
IT auch wenig zu tun hat.
Naja, aber die meisten Zertifikate
finde ich unsinnig.
an einem Portfolio oder als PDF einfach angehangen,
dann würde ich sagen, ey cool, der macht sich Gedanken.
Der hat jetzt einfach nicht nur tutorialblind nachgemacht,
sondern du zeigst nicht nur das Ergebnis, das Ergebnis ist relativ egal.
Mir geht es darum, wie du denkst, wie du arbeitest,
wie gehst du mit Fehlern um, lässt du dich davon nicht unterkriegen,
schaust du dir auch Weg 1, 2, 3 an, entscheidest dich dann für Weg 2
und erklärst, warum du das gemacht hast.
Diese Prozesse transparent zu machen, sind für Arbeitgeber super, super, super, super, super wichtig,
weil sie ihm zeigen, wie du tickst und ob er dich in seinem Team sieht oder nicht.
Welches Problem kannst du lösen? Wie lernst du Neues?
Das stimmt wohl, wenn man im Netzwerkbereich unterwegs ist.
Das ist Cisco Certified Internet Engineer? Network Professional?
Weiß ich nicht. Zumindest CCIE ist eines der höchsten, die es bei Cisco gibt.
CCNA, sogar, Leute, ich habe keine Ahnung von Cisco Hardware, sogar ich habe einen CCNA.
Zwar abgelaufen mittlerweile, aber CCNA ist, naja, hat gefühlt jeder mal gemacht.
Was CCNP ist, weiß ich, was ist CCNP?
Cisco, ja und?
Network Professional, okay, habe ich recht, das ist Internet Engineer, ne?
Enterprise Infrastructure?
Was?
Internet
Internetwork Expert, ja genau, sowas
Wurde das umbenannt?
Ja
Immer
Ja, ich denke mal überall da, wo man sehr
Hersteller gebunden ist, sei es
jetzt im Netzwerkbereich mit Cisco oder im Storagebereich mit Storage an BTXY, da ist es
sicherlich nicht verkehrt, wenn man was vorzuweisen hat von eben dem Hersteller, den der Arbeitgeber
auch einsetzt. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein Pluspunkt, könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Zertifikate können durchaus auch sehr teuer sein. Wie gesagt, ich halte da nicht allzu viel von
von Zertifikaten.
Ein Zertifikat?
Z-Series?
IBM Mainframe Zertifikate?
Boah, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Ja gut, das in so einem Bereich, ja.
Okay, das lasse ich mir gefallen.
Ist ja auch nicht schlecht.
Vielleicht findest du ja irgendwann mal einen Bereich,
der dich besonders interessiert.
Warum sollte ein Betrieb
in dich investieren?
Das solltest du dir mal in Ruhe
selbst die Frage stellen,
gucken, ob du Antworten darauf findest und dann
schauen, ob du deine Bewerbungsunterlagen so in diesem
Rahmen scopen kannst.
Und ganz, ganz wichtig,
was heißt das jetzt für Betriebe?
Wenn du ein Ausbilder bist, wenn du ein Ausbildungsleiter bist,
bitte bildet mehr aus.
Wenn wir weniger Einstiegsstellen heute
haben, bedeutet das, dass wir weniger
Nachwuchs haben, der nachrückt.
Das bedeutet wiederum ein größerer
Fachkräftemangel für morgen. Wer heute
kaum noch Anfänger aufbaut, verschärft morgen
den eigenen Fachkräftemangel.
Befahrene Fachkräfte entstehen nicht von allein, sie brauchen
einen Einstieg.
Künstliche Intelligenz ersetzt die Ausbildung
nicht, sie verändert sie.
Gute Ausbildung braucht
echte Aufgaben, Begleitung
und klare Lernwerte.
Ja, deswegen hatte ich auch keine gute Ausbildung.
Aber ich habe trotzdem viel gelernt in der Ausbildung.
Weil es keine Ausbildung war.
Das war halt, mach einfach
oder du hast gelitten.
Liebe IT-Ausbildungsbetriebe,
wenn ihr da Unterstützung braucht,
meldet euch bei uns. Wir haben sehr viel
Kompetenz darin, Hashtag Werbung, sehr viel Erfahrung
und sehr viele Tools. Das war ein schön
eingewebter Sellout. Tools, um euch
dabei zu unterstützen.
Sehr cool. Mein Fazit für dieses Video
ist also, der Einstieg ist enger geworden,
aber er ist nicht unmöglich.
Wer heute einsteigt,
braucht früher Klarheit über drei Dinge.
Welche Probleme kannst du lösen oder möchtest
du lösen? Wie lernst du Neues und
warum sollte ein Betrieb in dich investieren?
Der Raum ist noch da,
die Tür ist enger geworden.
Ich hoffe, damit konnte ich einen guten, nuancierten Einblick in diese aktuelle Lage der Ausbildung und IT bringen.
Wenn dir dieses Video gefallen hat, lass gerne einen Daumen nach oben da.
Wenn du selber Feedback eindrücke, schreib sie gerne in die Kommentare.
Ich würde mich super freuen, wenn du in dem Video einen Daumen nach oben geben könntest und ein Abo dalässt.
Das würde mich in meiner Arbeit supporten.
Boah, Leute, ich hab jetzt, ich hab's euch ja gesagt, ich hab zwei Stunden, haben wir jetzt das Video geguckt, 36 Minuten Video, aber ich wurde ja auch zu Gott und der Welt wieder gesidetrackt.
Das schlechteste Gehalt Deutschlands, ja.
Tschätke, ich muss mal kurz mein Handy holen und gucken, was das Essen macht.
Ich krieg Hunger.
Hunger.
Was gibt's zu essen?
Ratet mal.
Ich glaub, ich hab's vorher schon gesagt.
Sogar.
So, wartet mal.
Lasst mich mal kurz checken.
Home Assistant.
Aufmachen.
Was macht die Mikrowelle?
Noch nix.
Okay, Leute, dann gibt es auch noch kein Essen.
Dann können wir noch ein bisschen streamen.
Ich hab übelst Hunger.
Wie hast du denn mitgekommen mit der smarten Steckdose?
Die kann dann erkennen, wenn
der Stromverbrauch
Stellenanzeigen.
Nee, das machen wir irgendwann anders.
Das machen wir jetzt nicht jetzt, Zwischentür und Angel.
So.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Was können wir uns denn sonst noch Schönes angucken?
Oh, Listening.
Alter, was?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich muss mal kurz neu starten.
Irgendwie ist das mega verbuggt.
Irgendwie ist das mega verbuggt und
switcht immer irgendwie
den Tab um.
Ja, jetzt geht's wieder. Nice. Oder?
Ja, geht wieder. Jetzt klickt es nicht.
Keine Ahnung. Was haben wir denn sonst noch
Schönes?
I have homelab mistakes I made
so you don't have to. Okay.
Rackmount. Okay, Rackmount.
Verstehe ich. Rackmount ist uns fehlt. Das könnte man sich angucken.
Was ist das denn?
Linux und BSD Distro Tierlist.
Okay, das gucken wir uns nicht an.
Wir gucken uns nur mal kurz das Ergebnis an, okay?
Was ist das denn?
Wait a minute.
Ubuntu und Red Hat sind Slob.
Also quasi die zwei verbreitetsten Distributionen im Enterprise-Umfeld sind F-Tier.
Debian ist Mäh.
Debian ist eindeutig S-Tier.
Das ist Cashew-S, oder?
Oh, keine Ahnung.
Mit...
Das ist irgendein BSD.
Das ist auch irgendein BSD.
das ist Gentoo, das ist Arch.
Okay, Fedora, Arch, Gentoo und FreeBSD
sind Peak.
Ist das hier nicht Cachy?
Nee, ist es nicht. Okay, Cachy
ist gar nicht dabei.
Dann habe ich keine Ahnung, was
das ist, irgendein BSD. Keine Ahnung, was das
für Distros ist. Ist es Alpine?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ähm, und
Peak ist NixOS.
Okay, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich dieser Tierlist zustimme.
Man müsste vielleicht eine Tierlist machen.
Für welchen Bereich?
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn wir mal...
Ist das Ragebait-Liste?
Ja, vielleicht ist das Ragebait.
Also wenn man da mal eine Server-OS-Tierlist machen würde, dann muss man sagen, im Business-Enterprise-Sektor eindeutig Ubuntu und Red Hat.
Und wenn ihr mich fragt, dann eindeutig Debian.
Also Debian ist S-Tier, gibt's nix.
Naja, das ist Ragebait.
Ah
Does this OS respect the operator?
Okay
Whatever
Nie wieder Daten verlieren
Ach, das ist doch langweilig
Rastic
Copia
Das ist bestimmt Borg hier, was die verwenden
Ich erkenne es nicht genau, aber ich tippe mal drauf
Ne, Airclone
Ja, nee, das müssen wir uns nicht angucken.
Oh Leute, ich hab so krass Hunger, Alter.
Ich muss was essen.
Aber es gibt noch nix.
Wir scrollen mal da drüber.
Mal gucken, was er für Mistakes hat.
Das geht auch nur sieben Minuten.
Da sind wir schnell durch.
My homelab used to be a second job.
Hier ist how I fix it. Okay.
Das ist schon mal nicht wie der Techno-Tim.
Der Techno-Tim, dem sein Homelab ist,
ein Full-Time-Job.
Jetzt roll mal vor.
Rackmounted Equipment.
Ja.
Ich bin auch rackmounted gewented.
Geiler Satz.
Ich bin auch
den Weg, ich habe auch den Weg
eingeschlagen mit rackmounted.
Ich habe so ein kleines Mini
Mini-Rack
2021.
Das ist schon ewig her.
Ein Mini-Rack
mit während dem Umbau mit Zeug
so ein kleines Rack, weiß nicht, 24 AE
oder irgendwas, das hat nicht so viel.
Ne, noch nicht mal, oder? Was ist das?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 14 HE oder sowas.
Viel ist das nicht.
Zumindest, ich bin immer noch sehr zufrieden damit.
Und sei es nur für das Patch-Panel und den Switch und das Zeug.
Ein Rack ist einfach, selbst wenn du in das Rack nur unten ein NAS reinstellst, ja,
und ein USB daneben und oben ein Switch-Mount,
Das lässt sich einfach ordentlicher machen, als wir stellen alles nebeneinander.
Weil Rack ist halt im Endeffekt auch nur ein Schrank, wo du dein Zeug drin anordnen kannst.
Ich finde Rack Mounted gut.
Was natürlich unsinnig ist, auf Teufel komm raus, alles Rack Mounted haben zu wollen.
Eine Rack Mounted Fritzbox zum Beispiel.
Ich weiß, es gibt 3D-gedruckte 19 Zoll Fritzbox, 19 Zoll Rackmount.
3D gedruckt.
Oder gibt es da sogar offizielle zu kaufen? Nee, oder?
139! Was ist das für ein Abfuckpreis für ein bisschen Metall?
Sind die komplett geistig oder was?
Da würde ich lieber
3D drucken
Ah
Guck hier
Für den Preis kannst du dir fast
einen künstlichen 3D-Drucker kaufen.
Naja.
Vielleicht nicht ganz.
Gibt's ja auch Sachen.
Nee, also das ist
nix.
Ja, das ist teuer.
Aber ich finde Rackmount nicht verkehrt.
Man hängt in Rackmount einfach das als 19 Zoll Gerät rein, was sich anbietet.
Ja, Patchpanel, Switch, vielleicht die USV, je nachdem.
Und den Rest kann man ja reinstellen.
Es gibt ja für Racks auch die Möglichkeit, Moment.
Sieht es glaube ich hier in meinem Rack ganz gut.
Wenn da nicht so viele Kabel davor hängen würden.
Wie gesagt, das war hier gerade beim Umbau.
Ähm, ich hab hier unten
Ja, hier sieht man's doch
Guck, ich hab hier so eine Schublade drin
Da sieht man nicht wirklich
Ja, ich hab hier, ich hab hier eine Schu...
Ja, hier ist eine Schublade drin, die kann man ausziehen
Da steht meine, äh, meine Fritzbox zum Beispiel drauf
meine fritzbox man unity mit meiner unity media kiste auf so einer auf so einer schublade
und die meisten schublade haben ja unten auch so dinger wurde dann
füßchen rein machen kannst wo die geräte halten oder so packt man
ein bisschen velcro drauf und und tut das dann klettverschlussen
Ich hab nen Anycubic
I3 Mega
Guck hier, da siehst du
Ne, da siehst du noch net
Wie gesagt, das ist grad beim Umbau
Moment, Moment, Moment
Wo soll ich das fertig umgebaute zeigen?
Mein Serverraum ist fertig
Sieht schon besser aus, ne?
Ja, sieht schon etwas ordentlicher aus
Mittlerweile, ne?
ähm, aber jetzt auf den
All-Unify-Access-Point, den ich da schon rausschmeißen
wollte und mittlerweile rausgeschmissen hab, guck
so hab ich einen Anycubic
ähm, i3 Mega
3D-Drucker
Druckerstelz
Ja, hier zieh ich die Schublade
raus, guck, hier
da sitzt mein, hier, ich hab hier unten
ich hab hier unten so ein bisschen Velcro dran gepappt
da sitzt mein
MikroTik-Router drauf und meine Fritzbox
und mein Unity Media Mode
sitzen da drauf
okay jetzt hier all da hatte ich da noch dicke arme vor fünf jahren
guck da
unsere schubladen sind auch praktisch also wie gesagt ich bin der meinung
rack mounted ist keine fehlerentscheidung für das sogar zum
organisieren so finde ich finde ich nicht aber gucken was er sagt
Das stimmt. Ich würde mir auch nicht, nur weil ich einen 19 Zoll Rack habe,
zwangsweise nur 19 Zoll Rack Hardware kaufen.
19 Zoll USVs sind viel teurer als irgendwelche Einstiegs-USVs von APC für 70 Euro,
die du dann an den Hochkant reinstellst. Im Zweifelsfall kannst du die auch aufs Rack oder neben das Rack stellen.
Aber für Verkabelung generell finde ich es von der Handhabung her viel angenehmer, wenn du 19 Zoll Rack hast.
Du hast halt quasi einen Schrank, der nebenbei auch, wenn du die passenden Server hast, auch gleich die passenden Anschraubpunkte hast.
Also ich finde 19 Zoll Rack nicht verkehrt.
Wir haben uns hier zusammen das NAS angeguckt, das Minisforum NAS.
Und das ist klein und kompakt.
das ist zwar nicht 19 Zoll, aber das kannst du auch in so ein Rack reinstellen.
Entweder stellst du es unten hin und die USV daneben,
oder du stellst es auf so eine Schublade.
Zumal du dann auch da mehrere Sachen nebeneinander bekommst.
Das passt schon.
Aber mal weiter.
Da kannst du,
habe ich auch schon oft drüber gesprochen,
RAID 5 ist meistens
gar nicht das Beste.
Auch wenn viele Leute standardmäßig
zu RAID 5 greifen.
Weil RAID 5 hat halt den Vorteil,
du verschwendest in dem Sinn
nur eine Platte
für Parity.
Es ist mit drei Platten betreibbar.
und es bringt sogar ein bisschen Geschwindigkeitsboost.
Also RAID 5 ist nicht schlecht.
Das Problem ist bei RAID 5,
wenn es mehr als drei Platten werden
und wenn es große Platten werden.
Warum nicht einfach RAID 1?
Ich mag RAID 1.
Ich bin RAID 1 Fan.
RAID 1 ist simpel,
ausfallsicher,
bringt dir Read Performance.
Ja.
Ja, RAID 1 ist nicht verkehrt.
4 TB!
ganz ehrlich da würde ich mir lieber 226 t drives schuppen aus den sie geld
dingern was hat mir das sie geld hat weg ich will mir ich will mir zwei 26
terabyte drive schuppen aus dem sie geld sie geld externen platten und red 1
drüber machen red 5 rebuild ist immer schwierig ja
Oh Leute, ich hab Hunger.
Ich merke das schon, ich kann mich gar nicht richtig mehr konzentrieren.
Das merkt ihr übrigens auch daran, weil ich bei jedem Satz gefühlt gerade sagen muss,
äh, wie ging's weiter?
Und unterzuckert hier.
My non-replaceable things are on my apps pool and I should have spent more time and more money with larger drives here.
I could put more irreplaceable data on this mirror and just swapped out the big deal pool for one huge 20TB drive.
Siehste? Siehste? Was habe ich eben gesagt?
Alternativ, die bisschen weniger einschneidende Variante,
holt euch zwei Laufwerke
und macht einfach nachts einen AirSync.
Das ist, glaube ich, so ziemlich die einfachste Variante,
die man machen kann.
Und es ist sogar in manchen Belangen besser als ein RAID 1.
Chat, mal Frage an euch.
Was könnt ihr euch so vorstellen?
RAID 1 versus gar kein RAID und nächtliches Backup PR Sync.
Was ist der riesen Vorteil von nächtlichem Backup PR Sync versus RAID 1?
Und umgedreht.
Fallen ein paar Sachen ein.
Jetzt sieht es so aus, als läuft hier gar nichts.
Habt ihr da eine Idee?
Festplatte nicht im selben Gehäuse, ja
Also, für mich ist der Vorteil
Von RAID 1
Eindeutig die Ausfallsicherheit
Ich rede hier absolut von der Ausfallsicherheit
Also von der Downtime
Also sprich, wenn die Festplatte kaputt ist
Dann ist euer
Storage
Weiter verfügbar
Oh, jetzt kommt der hier mit den richtigen geilen
Begriffen hier, genau
Ja, bei einem RAID 1 hast du keine Probleme.
Festplatte kaputt, RAID läuft weiter.
Dafür hast du bei einem RAID 1 ein Problem,
wenn du bei einem RAID 1 aus Versehen eine Datei löschst.
Dann ist sie nämlich weg.
Auf beiden Platten.
Synchron.
Heißt, du hast ohne Backup gelitten.
Wenn du einfach nur einen Backup machst, einmal in der Nacht,
dann hast du das Problem nicht.
Deswegen finde ich den Ansatz für einen Heimbereich, eine Platte für die Daten und eine zweite Platte für nächtliches Backup gar nicht so verkehrt.
Welt 1 plus Cloud Backup, wenn man seine Sachen in die Cloud schieben will, kann man das machen.
Oder ihr macht das so, wie ich das früher mit Karsten gemacht habe, einem Kollegen aus
Dresden.
Ich habe ihm ein bisschen Speicherplatz bei mir reserviert, er hat mir ein bisschen Speicherplatz
bei sich reserviert.
Wir haben dann per VPN die wichtigen Sachen dort gebackupt.
Machen wir aber nicht mehr.
Der ist jetzt Familienvater
und hat andere Probleme.
Alles woran er sein Backup speichert.
Ja.
Okay, weiter.
Mistake number three
was not going unified from the start.
Das ist kein Mistake.
Also,
mittlerweile mag das wieder stimmen.
Aber ich hatte eine Weile Unify und ich habe Unify wieder rausgeschmissen.
Ja gut, wir reden jetzt ja auch nicht davon, dass nur Unify das kann.
Es gibt durchaus noch mehr Hardware, die das kann.
Jeder billige MikroTik-Router kann VLANs oder MikroTik-Switch.
Beziehungsweise die Switch-Komponente des Routers kann das.
Wobei die auch...
Auch VLANs können die irgendwie über die CPU gehen.
Also jeder billige MikroTik-Gerät kann das auch.
Ja, aber dafür brauchen wir nicht Unify.
Ja, wenn einem das gefällt. Ich mag ja, also ich mochte, das Neue kenne ich gar nicht mehr.
Ich mochte das damalige Unify-Interface nicht.
hat es kritisch reichlich so wird für someone running services 24 7 in der
haus die time i've saved not fighting with consumer grade routers as paid for
the gear 10 times over ja man kann sich auch einfach ein mikrotik router kaufen
und hat die bastel möglichkeiten das todes also kannst kannst damit einfach
alles gefühlt machen
zum zentralen management ist wahrscheinlich nicht verkehrt kann ich
im großen Stil nichts zu sagen.
Mir hat das Webinterface damals auch nicht gefallen, aber das war noch
das alte Unify-Interface. Die haben ja mittlerweile ein neues.
Also ich
bin mittlerweile bei einer Kombination
aus, und das auch schon seit
einigen Jahren jetzt, ich bin aus
einer Kombination, einem MikroTik-Router,
einem
Uni-Ubiquity-Switch,
kein Unify-Switch,
ein Edge-Switch,
16, äh, 12,
nee, äh, warte mal,
12 Ports, SFP+,
4 Ports
10 Gig
AJ45 Ethernet
also quasi
ein 10 Gig Switch
dann ein MikroTik Router
und
Ruckus Access Points
die brauchen auch keinen Controller
können selbst Controller machen
da wird es mal Zeit
dass ich auf Ebay gucke, ob ich mal ein paar
neuere Generationen finde
Und dazu noch eine Fritzbox für VoIP und DECT gedöhnt, weil das will man nicht selber machen.
Oh, so sieht das aus.
Unify ist so Ubiquiti. Ja, aber Ubiquiti hat auch noch mehr als Unify.
Wie managt ihr denn WiFi-Access-Points?
Bei mir ist es so, ich habe hier Unleashed heißt das.
Bei mir sieht das so aus.
Weiß nicht, ob man da gescheit...
Interface...
Aber bei mir sieht das so aus.
So.
Ich habe so eine Oberfläche für meine Access Points.
Die brauchen auch einen Controller,
aber die Access Points selbst können quasi diesen Controller laufen lassen.
Da wird quasi auf dem stärksten und wenig ausgelastesten Access Point wird dann der Controller laufen lassen.
Bröselstein, danke schön für den Sub.
Huge Subscription.
Ja, so sieht das dann bei mir aus.
Mittlerweile, also der Hauptgrund, warum ich mir die damals gekauft habe, war,
weil Unify ewig gebraucht hat und es bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich es abgeschafft habe, nicht geschafft hat,
ein ganz spezielles Feature einzubauen, was ich unbedingt haben wollte für meine IoT-Geräte,
nämlich dass man extra WLAN-Passwörter vergeben kann pro Gerät.
Nicht nur pro SSID, sondern pro Gerät.
Und das konnte Unify einfach nicht.
Und die Dinger hier gab es relativ günstig auf Ebay und die konnten das schon ewig.
Deswegen habe ich mir die damals gekauft.
Mittlerweile kann das Unify angeblich auch.
Ansonsten waren die Access Points von Unify schon okay.
Leute, das Problem haben wir nicht.
Bei uns funktioniert alles First Try,
deswegen brauchen wir keine Kommentare,
keine Tests und keine Dokumentation.
So einfach ist das.
Was benutzt er denn für ein Wiki?
Was ist denn das für ein Wiki?
Erkennt man das?
Sieht hübsch aus.
Immer eine Ahnung, was das für eine Wiki-Software ist?
Das Book... Book... Book... Wie heißt das Ding? Bookstore oder so?
Wiki.js. Okay.
Bookstack. Bookstack meinte ich, ja.
und mein Kopf ist kein beliebiges Database.
Sechs Monate später bin ich in eine Box eingestiegen.
Nee, mein Head ist auch keine gute Database.
Wisst ihr, was die beste Dokumentation ist, die es gibt?
Bash History.
Beste Dokumentation.
Gut, auf der Linux-Kiste hier haben wir jetzt noch nicht allzu viel gemacht.
Aber Bash History.
auf der arbeit ist die best history meine meine meist genutzte dokumentation
ich erinnere mich daran so haben wir da nicht schon mal was drauf gemacht ich
körle nacht er ich suche nach köln ich suche nach der ip bären gefunden
schneller als jedes one note jedes wiki jedes ticketsystem sonstwas
Bash-History zu Splunk.
Boah, das wäre mal next level.
Da hast du dann zwar auch Sachen drin,
die du vielleicht nicht drin haben willst, aber wäre
top.
Wer braucht Windows Recall,
wenn er eine Bash-History hat?
Und ob dieser Cronjob wichtig ist oder ein Relikt aus einem Container, das du vor ein paar Jahren verlost hast,
ist das Ironische, dass ich jetzt ein öffentliches Wiki mit hunderten von Seiten für den Kanal runne,
und für die längste Zeit hatte ich keine internen Dokumentationen.
Welches Feature?
Ach, Windows Recall.
Das gibt's doch immer noch.
Ich glaube, in der EU kann man's nicht installieren,
aber geben tut's das.
Und das funktioniert nur auf Co-Pilot-PCs
oder PCs mit lokaler
KI-Beschleunigung.
Das gibt's immer noch.
Ist halt genauso Bullshit
wie früher auch.
Oh, da hat er recht.
Da hat er recht.
untested Disaster Recovery,
ja? Dir bringen die besten
Backups und alles nix,
wenn du noch nie versucht hast, die mal zu
restauren auf ein kaputtes
System. Da bin ich aber
auch
huldig.
Mach ich auch nicht.
Auf der Arbeit mach ich's gezwungenermaßen.
Was ich da eigentlich viel wichtiger finde,
ich weiß nicht, ob er das noch hat.
Nee, hat er nicht.
Was ich eigentlich viel wichtiger finde ist, dass du das mitbekommst, wenn deine Backups failen und sowas.
Ja, also so ein minimales lokales Monitoring mit egal was ist nicht verkehrt.
Ich habe bei mir lokal einen Subix laufen, weil ich den schon eine ganze Weile laufen habe.
Ich bin jetzt auch nicht der größte Zabbix-Fan.
Gerade Grafen und Dashboards sind in Zabbix abfuck.
Aber den habe ich einfach schon eine Weile.
Und für so kleine Sachen finde ich das auch nicht verkehrt.
Ja, es ist egal was, aber mitzubekommen, wenn was down ist, mitzubekommen, wenn Backups nicht laufen, das ist schon nicht verkehrt.
zum Beispiel das Nvidia Shield Tablet
im Wohnzimmer
das hängt sich regelmäßig ganz gerne
mal auf, wenn es im Standby
ist witzigerweise, also
das ist dann so einmal im Monat
oder so
und das wird jetzt einfach angepingt
von meinem Zabbix
und wenn das Ding down ist
dann ziehe ich den Stecker raus
und mache ihn wieder rein
so dass es keinen Stress abends gibt
dass der Fernseher nicht funktioniert
Und nichts war aufgeladen. All das, was du fangen würdest, wenn du die Rückkehrstelle tatsächlich getestet hättest. Eine Rückkehrstelle, die du nicht getestet hast, ist eine Rückkehrstelle. Das ist eine Idee.
musst du deine komplette Kiste abschießen und neu installieren.
Das ist dann immer ein Riesenakt.
Selbst wenn du Backups restorest, also hat keiner so richtig Bock drauf.
Du kannst dir natürlich eine zweite Platte kaufen,
machst die erste Platte raus, machst die zweite rein,
tust so, als wäre es kaputt gewesen, restorest.
Ah ja.
Man muss aber auch mal ehrlich dazu sagen,
im Heimbereich, ja,
da kann man auch mal durchaus
bisschen Downtime
vertragen
wenn man nicht den Fehler macht, alles auf
eine Kiste zu hauen, dass wenn dann
das dann im Haus gar nichts mehr geht, dass der
Fernseher nicht mehr geht, die Heimatomatisierung nicht mehr
geht, alle internen Sachen nicht mehr funktionieren
weil du alles auf einer Kiste drauf hast
das ist eine schlechte Idee
ja, dann sollte man
schon mal gucken, aber ansonsten
wenn jetzt das NASMA für einen Tag nicht
zur Verfügung steht, weil du dir eine neue Festplatte bestellen
musst so what das ist doch das ist doch wirklich kein michael fünf spiele jahren
dankeschön für den sap ja ja das ist auch wirklich kein problem
die alte ist es leider mit testen der in der feier wo ich es doch was possible
kann man findet ihr hose has a hole in it was denn ist es schedule resource
test actually tried to take machines and turn them back on again try restoring
die 99,99 prozent online teil müssten gewährleistet sein das haben die meisten
leute wahrscheinlich sogar bei sich daheim weil die hardware fehler ist also die fehler
rate ist ja jetzt auch nicht so hoch die die größte wahrscheinlichkeit dass was kaputt geht
ist wenn es neu ist und ab einem gewissen alter dazwischen fehlen die meisten sachen so gut wie
gar nicht ja es kann ja immer passieren aber wenn das wichtig ist dann legt legt euch lieber
eine zweite platte gleich daneben oder machten red 1 oder sowas ist der having working back
Oh Leute, die Mikrowelle ist an.
Gleich gibt's Essen.
Force Champ.
Okay, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Es gibt heute übrigens weder Nudel,
beziehungsweise Lachs mit Nudeln
und auch keine Spaghetti Bolognese.
Es gibt Nudeln mit
Pilzen. Penne.
Penne-Nudel mit Pilzen.
Chat.
Vielleicht gibt's am Mittag weiteren Stream. Wir müssen
einmal Stellenanzeigen machen und wir müssen
Niri weitermachen. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, was wir davon machen.
Was wir davon machen werden.
Ich mach jetzt aus,
denn es gibt jetzt Essen. Ich hab mega Hunger.
Ich fang schon an zu zittern,
so unterzuckert bin ich.
4 Stunden
15 Stream. Ordentlich.
Chat, wir sehen uns später, vielleicht. Bis dann, macht's gut. See you.
PepoFatTime, genau so sieht's aus. Bis dann, tschüss.